foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
the only player Magnus Carlsen was
motivated to defend his world
championship title against
now that's a world championship match we
may never get but today we do have a big
Winners final it is youth versus
experience as alireza takes on Magnus
Carlsen in a best deform match welcome
to the Champions Chester
[Music]
he blundered his Knight
it's full of traps you saw the reactions
like oh crap here we go like what is
this kid got in store he's gonna be a
Checkmate right I mean that King
Levon is freaking out he's got five
seconds it's over Checkmate on the
boards
he is so stressed out he knows he's so
close in this one
[Laughter]
all three divisions of the Julius bear
generation cup are getting closer to the
Finish Line the players are fighting for
money door points and a golden ticket to
the season and final we are expecting
mind-boggling chess and to make sure you
stay on top of each and every move in
the studio Grandmaster David Hall Ginger
GM Simon Williams
we've had dramatic chess the last two
days who's impressed you the most oh for
me it has to be alireza because alireza
has been on top form you know he
demolished star of three nil yesterday
he powered past Wesley so I mean it just
seems incredible
amazing performance by the 20 year old
alireza fuja and Simon he's been your
pick from this thought how do you assess
his chances going up against Magnus
today and he's got great chances I mean
he's playing really well he just beat
Wesley so who's a rock and uh well we've
got one hell of a match coming up later
on because Magnus wants to play Addy
razor and Ali razer's parents want him
to play Magnus as well so it's going to
be a brilliant match and uh he's got a
great chance
it's going to be a super exciting battle
when Magnus takes on alirez Albert all
through today we've got youth versus
experience in all the matchups David
what are you expecting that's right I'm
well as an experienced playing myself
I'm expecting the experienced players
the older players to really stake their
claim here but anything can happen I
think all three matches that we're going
to witness today are going to be
extremely close I think we'll see at
least one Armageddon it's hard to
separate them all in top form
all the players have been bringing on
their a game and we've had brilliancies
we've had blunders some of the players
feeling the fatigue it was a day of
nerves on day two
to me it looks like he's played some
really uh flashy clever moves in WoW
apparently a blunder on the board from
Fabiano what is this he's jumped out the
way with this bishop
this was based on the fact that the
White Knight will be hanging after a
rook trade but what is the winning blow
here for white there's more than one way
for Magnus to get a huge Advantage it's
more than one way he has chosen Simon's
moves the check and Magnus Carlson's
gonna mop up everything it's going to
take everything with check which export
as well now it's just one-way traffic
white will finally have a free hand to
stop pushing it's over yeah resigns
surrounding the white king as many
threatens making one is threatened
Bishop to E2 would be a Checkmate now
how does Magnus guard against that nice
you've got to come back with your knight
is that the only way to do it anyway
Rook would kick you to the corner and
Magnus is running but surely this is
going to end in disaster he's still
going for checkmate this is a cage
beautiful I think he's done it he has
he's won he's come back he's gonna win
he's gonna win two games in a row
against the the brilliant Magnus caster
and take it to uh Armageddon oh is is he
giving the pizza away no he's counting
on Rook takes night and then the two
Rooks will line up on the age lines but
look at the bars changed a lot due to
that 15 overall he's not making any
progress whatsoever here two more moves
oh Bishop takes G7 Bishop takes Pawn now
yeah well no unfortunately there's some
Rook checks is it gonna be a draw he
should have taken the Rook oh
Bobby did not realize it oh wow it it
automatically stops 50 move rule has
been reached and with that he had the
opportunity to keep going with the trade
on that last move
and Magnus Carlsen has got to be feeling
the relief after that
two events remain and four spots up for
grabs Magnus Carlson Hikaru Nakamura
nodded back up to satrov and Fabiano
caruana have all qualified for the
season and Final in Toronto we started
with eight players on Wednesday only six
remain Pavel El yanov and I'm in
tabatabai it was the end of the road for
them on day two two of the world top 10
are currently in the losers
quarterfinals we will be seeing uh them
in action today on their last live
Magnus Carlson alireza ferrugia
meanwhile continue their run in the
winners bracket and will be facing each
other later today Ivanka big matchups
which one are you most looking forward
to
I think I'm gonna look forward to the
match between West Iso and the young 16
year old Dennis lazovic remember both of
them are playing for this all-important
overall tour standings and if Wesley so
wins then he secured his spot in Toronto
yeah every match has something to offer
today I mean the big one though has to
be Magnus Carlson the best player in the
world against uh a potential future
world champion and erasers so uh there's
going to be lots of fire on the board
there but uh yeah Dave what about
yourself yeah it's three matches between
Generations experience versus Youth and
uh that clash between noribek Abdul
satorov and Fabiano caruana a lot of
recent history between the two I've used
a tour of beat Carolina in one of the
finals of the earlier tour events of the
chess kid cup and uh yeah recent history
on his side it's gonna be interesting
fascinating battles all throughout now
while some of the players have booked
their spot in Toronto the pressure of
qualification is off including for
Fabiano caruana and the Magnus Carlsen
but for alireza today it is a lot on the
line and for Wesley so as well it's a
narrow path to Toronto there are at
least three spots for tour standing so a
lot of players are fighting for these
critical tour points including in
division two and we saw some inspired
play by one of the most creative players
in the in modern chess
division 2 Lavon aronian was down one
nothing against The Talented Alexei
serrana after this Miss by Serana in
game two aronian found a critical
response with Rook H6 he proceeded to
suffocate White's position until a
forced mate was on the board this is
game over sirana resigns in a 70 move
game three aronian again found the
critical response following a mistake by
Serana in this position serrana played
Knight F3 check aronian found the right
moves and a queen sacrifice to make his
past Pawn Unstoppable oh and he finds it
and that's it Rana resigns after a draw
in the fourth game it was sealed aronian
took the match after an early deficit in
Division III super Grand Master chacriar
Mahmoud yarov and American Prodigy Sam
sebian won both of their games to now
meet in the winners bracket final
mavadov has yet to win a division so
that will be his goal as he faces off
against Sam sebion today a who was the
victor of division three in the air
things Masters
the winner of division two gets ten
thousand dollars and fifty tour points
including a ticket to the next division
one of the Champions Chester event and
these were our results from day two yeah
I'm in Boston
Advance too the winner is semi-finals
and we've got big matchups with Jan
facing Basim and artemia playing against
Lavon there is a lot on the line for
these players David or tamiyev against
Levon what do you think will be the
decisive factor in that match well yet
again Tanya we've been talking about it
a bit the older player here Iranian with
vast experience he is competing however
gets the really energetic really quick
artemia I think it might just come down
to whose nerves hold up it's such high
stakes especially for someone like
Iranian where 12 points are essential
and uh I'm gonna say he's gonna Thrive
under those conditions yeah it's gonna
be very close though isn't it I'll tell
me I've had such a great season a couple
of seasons ago and uh he's a very
dangerous player he's beaten Matt
Carlson on a couple of occasions so uh
yeah this is going to be a uphill
struggle uh for a ronian death
that he is very inspired and motivated
as we saw in his matchup against uh
sirana perana and today the games do
continue it's not just division two with
division three action as well and uh
he's still in the fight along with
famous fun Legend gatakamski but it will
be all eyes on the Winner's bracket
where chakra mama yarov takes on Sam
Savion yo we how would you describe the
styles of these two players well Sam
Savi and the young American has a really
powerful style and I have to say in this
particular format he seems to thrive I
mean I've seen him in several finals and
as for Shakira the shark mama jarov I
mean he plays in a really creative
aggressive style when he's there you
have to bring your Tactical a game so
expect a slugfest
and a really fun exciting uh battle you
know when they're shocked there is shark
attack Sam um samayam has won a division
three before can he have a repeat
performance of that one you can follow
all of division two action on chest
dojo's twitch Channel and division three
action on run Master then feingold's
Channel a lot of Juicy matchups in that
one in the studio we will be focusing on
division one with a big matchups and a
lot on the line and of course later
today we later today we've got world
number one Magnus Carlsen taking on
alireza farouza and this is what these
two players had to say about facing each
other
he's both very strong and uncompromising
players are always um always good what
are your thoughts on facing Magnus in a
matchup after quite some time
honestly I'm just happy that I'm I will
get more broadcast time because my
parents are watching you guys and you
guys never show me so now at least you
will show me and they could watch it so
this is a good news at least
he's definitely going to be on today's
broadcast the big matchup that we're so
excited to watch Magnus Carlsen uh has
had three appearances alireza ferruga
two Magnus with a double whammy two wins
in the tour so far and a really close
score it's going to be a close match
David what are the chances of this going
down to Armageddon I think it's very
likely of course four games between
these two Anything could happen
especially with such an uncompromising
style uh from farrugia as Magnus alluded
to but yeah they're both just in such
good form Magnus World Cup winner
farouzia winning two title Tuesdays and
then powering through this tournament I
can't wait either way yeah I'm very
excited as well I'm hoping for some
really attacking chess that's what uh
farusha loves doing and uh are we gonna
get it I hope so yeah it certainly looks
that way and I'm especially excited
because Magnus yesterday saying that he
was a little bit tired so we can't wait
to see what's gonna happen today
energy will be a big factor we did see a
fatigue Magnus Carlton also not happy
with his play yesterday and he said that
he's got to play better chess than what
he did against Fabby that match is
coming up later before that we do have
the losers quarterfinals with Wesley
taking on danislavik and Fabiano caruana
playing against not the back up to such
Rock Fabi not the back are already in
through to Toronto but a lot at stake
for Wesley and Dennis who are yet to
book their spot but Wesley it's easy he
wins today he's guaranteed a fourth
place finish and that means with his
store points he will be uncatchable he
will be at the top and he will get to
Toronto for Dennis lazowick he needs to
try to get as many of those tour points
and get as far as possible in this event
and we've seen what the 16 year old is
capable of it is going to be a big
battle uh David what are you expecting
in this matchup once again youth was his
experience yeah yet again the battle of
the generations and I think both players
will just stick to their strengths they
certainly have a comfort zone these two
are very defined style lasovic very
positional kind of plays those Catalan
openings he's a grinder Wesley so as
well like simplified positions with
minimal risk so I'm expecting some solid
chess and it might just be the first to
crack uh or whoever wants to maybe
finally take that risk uh that will come
out on top yeah I think it's gonna be
very close and it can well go to
Armageddon just because they're so solid
I think this match will be very
different to the Magnus match later on
so uh we have to wait and see lots of
berlins I'm going to be controversial
here and I'm going to say that Dennis
lazovic he's proved that he can win on
demand so I think that he might Edge it
out
we've seen brilliant play about Dennis
this entire event he did lose to Fabi
but it went down to the wild with the
Armageddon and yesterday making that
comeback against Amin tabatabai you
can't write this 16 year old off even
when he's playing the world number eight
we are expecting a close battle in that
one as well as this big matchup when
Fabi takes on Nutter back yovi is there
a favorite in this one that is a tough
question Tanya because look at this the
schools nothing can tell them apart but
in the last time they played in the
chess kid Cup Final it was Nordic Abdus
Turf that was a superior player so he
does Edge out Fabiano a little bit just
don't care about it's been a bit of a
heartbreak story for Fabi because he's
made it to so many finals of these
Champions Chester event it hasn't
managed to clinch a title yet not yet
but he has as a consolation prize kind
of secured a spot in the Grand Final but
you're you're right Tanya you know he
wants to win yeah every chance player
they're ambitious they're ruthless they
want to win the top dog prize a grudge
match for Fabi as well as motivation to
win the event let's take a look at the
regulations for the losers bracket it is
only a best of two which means there is
no margin for error 15 minutes with a
three second increment one and a half
points and you win the match as it's a
double elimination but these players are
on their last strike in the losers
bracket you lose you are out of the
Julius bear generation cup if you win
you continue through if it is a one one
there will be bidding Armageddon always
a lot of fun to watch an exciting play
and there we've got Fabiano caruana who
did have a tough day against Magnus but
there was some positives there David
especially in the last two games that's
right it was a really tough start for
Fabiano losing the first game uh quite a
close first game but the second game
having an opening disaster maybe the
worst opening we've ever seen from be
honored but after that he did bounce
back and took it to the wire one or two
moves away one or two accurate moves
away from taking that match against
Magnus to Armageddon so as you say some
positives but maybe not quite at his
best he needs to bounce back today and
not about needs to get through his uh
chair just about now because in seconds
from now we will have the action as the
Bears will play their first moves and we
are getting an update that the camera is
frozen so not the back is ready and
we've got
it's an invisible opponent currently who
Fabi is playing against
wow and uh it's not just okay the
invisible man is back magic trick but
he's not just that he's playing a really
risky opening this variation of the
Sicilian where you provoke White's Pawn
forward give white all the space in the
world this has got a slightly dodgy
reputation after the tour of definitely
playing provocative here and wow Fabiano
losing two moves for this Knight Simon
you're a Dutch defense player black has
just gained the move F5 for free but
what do you think of this opening
um well I mean just the speed that
Fabiano is playing is a bit worrying
because uh you only use noping like this
to Knight F6 if you want to surprise
your opponent because uh generally it's
it's not a great opening and you're
probably going to be a little bit worse
and it hasn't surprised Fabiano at all
Fabiano has moved quickly up to this
point he continues to move quickly and
to my eyes he's got quite a nice
position he can move his Queen he can
Castle Queen side he has pressure on the
open D file and um
um I'd imagine he's pretty happy the way
the opening's gone here
yeah
to me it looks beautiful for white uh
you've talked in past uh past days Simon
about having this white porn on E5 uh
just kind of cutting the board in half
to me it's okay it's going to be a
strategic kind of uh battle this next
few turns but looks like Fabiano he's
definitely done his homework and should
be happy
um yeah I don't know if anyone's had
experience in this variation of the
Sicilian personally my experience here
is zero
so I think we might have to learn a few
things from the players and there we can
actually see a new move according to the
databases uh before that white had only
really tried actually stepping forward
with the queen getting ready to Castle
the king to the left or playing Simon's
favorite move H2 H4 uh it's an
interesting position it's very
unbalanced very unconventional and I
guess the whole issue for black is just
where you're going to put the Bishops
and the move that kind of jumps out to
me is for black to develop the light
squared Bishop on the long diagonal by
and you do that by playing the move B6
as the players continue to develop their
pieces in a very non-standard opening it
does promise to be a big fight in this
best of two match from the word go and
we are getting the word that it is go
time in the other matchup as well
Wesley so danislavik ready to make their
first moves are we expecting the king
spawn opening once again for Wesley to
switch it up
yeah Wesley he's been varying between
one E4 King spawn openings and the reti
just uh kind of flexible approaches
there so uh yeah keeping less of less of
it guessing as well not sure which one
to expect but either way lazovic will
set up in a rock solid formation that's
what we've become accustomed to from him
here this whole Simon I think it might
be a Berlin
[Music]
I was gonna say no way I know I mean at
least we have the Italian variation
because uh I mean I I don't mind the
Berlin it's an opening I should actually
learn I never will but I should
um but it's just something we've seen a
lot of so far and the Italian we've also
seen this opening been played fairly
regularly but
um it's great for me because I'm
learning a lot more about this as we're
going on because uh the subtle Maneuvers
that the top players are actually uh
doing is is is really clever actually in
a lot of these games and the only
difference in this position is really
the pawn on C3 and blacks Knight on C6
so this gives white a little bit more
flexibility as white can try to advance
on the queen side but B4 or sometimes
with D4 in the center as well so I guess
that's where the advantage is really
that's where white is trying to uh Bank
his advantage on those Pawn pushes
common idea here and David you're
probably the expert in these lines of
menu you've played uh maybe you had you
had similar against Ali Ali Rays I don't
want to bring that memories up again but
I just did sorry guys
sorry about that that's okay I do in my
defense I do think Ella is a fruit is
maybe the world's leading expert on the
white side uh some fantastic results
using the Italian game and like you say
it's just very symmetrical but here the
advantage of the first move for white
the fact that you start first you always
uh seem to be one tempo up in these
types of middle games and okay lazovic
he's chasing hunting down that white
light Square Bishop he's going to
eliminate it and um this is still very
well known stuff I've seen aronian play
pretty much this side exact position uh
maybe with a couple of inclusions uh
before and yeah okay this one at least
is spicing up a big threat now on the
board from lasovich he's certainly done
his homework he's attacking the F2
Square Black's Bishop it's like an
Archer on the dark squares on A7 and it
has provoked white into stepping forward
in the center so maybe more exciting
than the usual kind of stodgy uh solid
Italian games that we used to but uh
yeah heating up it definitely feels like
both players itching for a fight here
less solid than I predicted
[Music]
I enjoy that things could get completely
liquidated so for instance if the Knight
were to recapture in the center is it
now time for black to break through
because okay well we might see on the
board
and then the position becomes very
complicated and very dynamic
yeah black needs to be quick here before
White's pieces start to develop come
forward that black knight now in White's
half is about to get kicked back and you
don't want to necessarily start
retreating so key moment for Dennis
lazwick he has the bishop power we
talked about that before in previous
days the bishop pair can be potent if
lines open up okay first he just
improves his Rook very solid play
yeah still in preparation here I was a
bit surprised when white gives up his
light Square bishop and uh the these
Italian openings were all Lopez openings
because that's one of the first things
you're kind of told not to do
um but it why I mean why does white do
it here he does it to open up the a file
to get some better development and those
nights of whites can come jumping into
the center quite soon as well but it is
something in the long term the two
Bishops they could work very well for
Dennis if he uh can just contain the
center here Bobby Fisher would be
turning right now he would be hating
this position for white he was so in
love with his lights going Bishops
especially when opening with 1e4 so he
wouldn't approve of what Wesley's doing
but uh we'll see if it pays off
looks like the opening has turned out
well for Dennis last week and open
position no structural weaknesses a
bishop pair those are some good
long-term strategic advantages to have
and this has been the unique quality
about denlas in this event from these
young players we often expect tactics
and boom boom bang Checkmate kind of
Chess so but it's not about the
aggressive play with a lot of strategic
technical stuff uh and I think this is
exactly the kind of position that he
thrives in yeah totally it's kind of
rare though to get a young person like
that oh we do have a move we will come
back to this but it is fire on the board
in our other matchup uh Fabiano taking
on another back and we do have
a lot of action in the other match and I
think we're gonna go straight to that a
queen side castling what is this crazy
position yeah first we need you to do
account because Fabiano by uh kind of
designer by accident here he has
sacrificed a piece he got his light
squared Bishop trapped and he gave it up
and look at White's Pawns in the center
they look beautiful look at White's
pieces centralized uh Super Active but
black is only one move away from
castling as you mentioned that Tanya and
Fabiano time is of the essence he needs
to attack he needs to justify his peace
sacrifice he's going for it now I think
this is a really accurate move uh before
it's too late and the evaluation Bar
says he's pretty much winning I think
this is probably preparation I mean uh
Fabiano has fantastic preparation this
this surprise move will move to
um it's becoming less surprising so
something maybe three years ago you
wouldn't have prepared for but I know
that um Niels used it against Magnus and
Neil's grandilius and some other players
have used it as well so I think it's
just something that Fabiano has prepared
and I reckon he's had this position
um back in his house already
um and uh it looks very scary for black
the queen is ready to come and check the
black king if black castles the White
Knight is going to jump in uh there's
there's a lot of Frets here yeah
really scary right yeah and sorry David
wants to show us exactly how this
position happened yeah I just wanted to
say as well we see the computer move
saying that black only has one move to
survive and minimize the damage but it
was here Fabiano as Simon mentioned
sacrificed a piece with his home cooking
this home preparation playing the move
G4 you don't come up with this quickly
within a couple of minutes uh unless you
have looked at it before and this
allowed the bishop on D3 to be trapped
simply nowhere to go for this bishop and
this was the secret ingredient Bishop
takes F5 uh just creating this huge Pawn
Center and this is the current position
white tonight jumping forward and uh
sorry they are for interrupting Ivanka
Queen check on the cards it looks like
blackaster Castle
only move according to the computer yeah
that's what I was going to say queen
Jack is going to be devastating you
really can't ignore that one so
there's only one move yeah there's a
nice line here isn't there I mean if you
play H5 you can play Knight F7 anyway if
you want to but uh you know just uh yeah
I don't know if you want to but I mean I
think this is just explains why uh you
have to Castle as black you have to get
that King as you say ivanka's safe on
the queen side even if it costs you some
material it's better than getting
checkmated that's that's pretty awesome
Knight F7 I love it time and time were
you influenced by Michael tal because I
always feel like you you always Channel
your dial in all your analysis I'm I
don't know I mean I I I love crazy moves
um definitely Mikhail towels was a hero
of mine probably my favorite world uh
champion and also a player we we're
going to mention later I think was a
another inspirational mind so uh we'll
come to that later on though but
um yeah I think black just has to Castle
I don't know if he has Castle yet but
what else can we do here David nothing I
feel yeah not yet he hasn't castled but
he has to as we see there just below the
board three computer suggestions
stockfish says okay King to C8 which is
Castle's Queen side that is by far the
best anything else look at that plus 4.6
plus 5.7 that is uh I mean those numbers
are from nightmares basically uh for
Abdus so you have to Castle and yes the
White Knight Will land on F7 as Simon
says but I think losing some material
here is the least of your worries you
simply cannot get checkmated it is and
another reason we know that uh Fabiano
is probably close to winning is that
muck he's got his super mug out and he's
drinking so much I mean you only drink
like that when you're very happy the
certain body language little tips from
the expert here that we can gauge from
the players you can see that naughty bet
their hand in the head he wants to hide
behind that hand like a big fan
and we see Fabiano now is not going to
bring his mug up is he but he's got a
massive mug what do we think he's
drinking I'm not sure but he's very
comfortable it's clear very very
comfortable he knows exactly this
position could be over soon I mean he
does have a great position you've been
talking about how this is part of the
prep but even when he went G4 right that
move that really turned it around for
him it felt like white had a huge
Advantage already so we'd love to know
how much of this was actually prep and
we'd probably get that in later but we
do have a move and it is not a queen
side Castle he hasn't gone for that and
I see in our studio you guys are
reacting to it Knight E7 what's
happening is it a check no we put that
in his pipe and we smoke it so the night
that little night can jump and it should
surely it should jump here surely that's
that's the right move in you go boy in
you go because it's not just threatening
The Rook that has a massive check is
threatening as well imagine that night
getting to the Center and
um it's quite neat I mean is that I mean
looks like a strong move right maybe the
check is good as well as you say Tanya
it's very tempting but
um I don't know it I mean the black king
I just I just don't think it it's going
to survive here
and we did just see uh after that move
the Black Knight Retreat back to E7 we
did see the computer did say Knight F7
instantly winning much stronger than
everything else but there are tempting
options uh Knight F7 not just uh those
tactics there Simon but you also covered
the eight Square kind of stopping the
black king from running away evacuating
towards the queen side you can't Castle
through track there so this would be the
killer blow Knight F7 I think uh Nordic
would struggle to survive let's uh just
show one move as well if Black's Knight
takes this Pawn to stop the check I
think you can just land on D6 with a
nasty check anyway and what if you take
the Rook on H1 David take the Rook I
mean let's just see I mean I I I mean if
you're the the thing is if you've got a
bad position you might as well take as
much as you can right so let's grab the
rook and uh we'll just finish yeah where
is the Finish indeed this is what Fabian
is calculating right now because this
position we've got on the board we see
the evaluation bar totally winning for
white but white is a rook and a bishop
down maybe it's just E6 yeah
on straight through the middle and
Knight F7 check winning the queen as a
threat uh but also you're bringing the
Rook on D1 I mean that that looks like
one very strong move I didn't play it
though that's disappointing
disappointing Fabiano he played a very
logical move there though uh bringing
the Rook into attack still lining up
with some Pawn pushers still not F7 in
the air still a check in the air he just
gets his Rook to safety all of his
pieces are playing a good part here
playing a decent role and still winning
why can't I get these positions against
uh Grandma's top Grand Masters when I
play they never allow me to have this
kind of fun David next time just let me
have this please oh you need to stop
playing against boring players like me
you need to fight uh kind of play
against these uncompromising youngsters
Simon they they fight fire with fire
they allow this type of chaos because uh
they kind of wanted themselves so
yeah get back to the board Simon all
right maybe one day but this is super
scary for black and it's the best of
dude right you guys you lose this one
and then you already feel like you're
eliminated you have to win on demand and
this feels like an all-prep line and you
won't get this last move just keeps all
the threats on the board that Fabi has
that we've been discussing the thing
that comes to my mind is that calm black
actually just grabbed that F5 Pawn which
is such a big strength in White's
position here yeah that was also my
first thought as well because you know
if black castles then the Knight will
jump to F7 but I'm also wondering you
know if the Knight does capture the pawn
can't Simon's idea of putting that
Knight into the F7 Square still come
into play
yep it's just deadly uh this kind of
recurring theme of Landing the Knight F7
hitting the rook and just to show Once
More porn steps forward here if you take
that night with a nasty check hitting
the queen not just that but if you
recapture whoops this is even Checkmate
uh in one the king is caught in the
center of the board so yeah no matter
where you go what you do it seems like
net F7 is almost inevitable uh you can
pretty much pre-move at this point and
fabiana's position it's beautiful his
air quality not great but uh beautiful
winning position right now yeah we could
be witnessing the first miniature of the
Julius bear generation cup with all
these threats it's hard to imagine not a
bag surviving it is move number 16. he's
really taking a thing but it doesn't
matter how much time he has on the clock
David what what a knight F5 on the board
felt like it was the only move and now
the move that Fabi maybe missed or not
sure if he missed or felt rookie one was
better but Knight F7 he could have
played on the last move will he find it
on this one yeah absolutely right
because otherwise where is the attack
you can't step forward with the pawn on
it from E5 to E6 because the bishop is
under Fire there and of course the
problem with chucking Queen to H5 check
can be easily blocked by the G Pawn so
process of elimination exactly forcing
moves your checks
and Simon I'm gonna
let you take it away yeah I mean that's
that's the move isn't it I mean but he
was forced to find it and you know as
soon as he played Knight G5 that's
that's the square that Knight wants to
come into I I don't know if naughty Beck
missed this move uh it is possible but
um now black can't even Castle I mean I
I think he he had to try to have castled
last move because it's not just Knight
takes Rook which is the threat
um winning material but it's actually
Knight to D6 which potentially looks
even more scary keeping the black king
stuck in the middle of the board and uh
um that you know these two Night Moves
just seem really really strong to me but
Knight D6 I think is the main threat
David I I don't know I mean look look
strong right yeah let's just show that
uh the Knight coming back for example if
black does save his rook in the corner
by moving it across Knight d6's just a
killer uh immediately you hit the king
you hit the Knight and if this is
captured in any direction uh for example
if the black Bishop takes this then it's
a discovered check and a double attack
you hit the queen as well you win
everything the whole house is collapsing
around uh NoDa Beck here he has under
five minutes in a hope this position and
this is just a peace sacrifice and in
return you've got so much here from
Fabiano you're going to win the piece
back with interest you might win the
queen you might deliver checkmate at
this point it's just Abdul sator of
picking his poison and
yeah he's gonna crash the defeat I think
the only question here is what's the
definition of a miniature is it under 20
moves under 25 will he survive that long
20 moves yeah harsh isn't it nowadays I
mean you you never get any games under
20 moves at that top Grandmaster level
you might just be um I I think it'll
last over 20. how many moves are we on
now I mean 17. he's he'll last another
three four moves even if he's completely
lost I remember in the old days you even
if you're completely lost I had this
against a junior
um when I was a grand master I was
getting smashed in about 15 moves and I
thought I've got to play on because the
otherwise this game will be in all the
newspapers you know obviously the days
before the internet and you just you
just draw it on just because it will at
least uh maybe not be featured as a
miniature then you know I
Grandma's and I have the white pieces
and it was moved
away to support live beyond move 17 and
I was like oh my God this is going to be
so embarrassing so yeah you make a good
point Simon I wrote for a newspaper and
uh one of the column there's space
control constraints so I literally have
to choose games that are 30 moves or
less so none of your games for whatever
feature I can never feature my own games
unfortunately that those would take her
10 10 pages but uh yeah under 30 moves
and this game might make it in the
newspaper yeah it's just been so brutal
and uh quite picturesque as well just
the patterns it's uh kind of really
really rare seldom that you see this uh
type of yeah aggressiveness payoff I
think this might be under 20. I mean
he's he's under three minutes right now
and he might not get checkmated but he
resigns to him shall we kind of do a
deep dive and see what happens if the
black king decides to run so I'm
thinking they only move to kind of
survive is move the Rook preserve The
Rook otherwise yeah the materialist in
me cannot handle being so much material
down and so then night gives a check and
then the king steps to the side and then
I've seen the Knight is also on priest I
mean you've got E6 series
because the night is under attack on D6
tempting but I mean it either works or
it doesn't work and when you've got lots
of time on your clock as Fabiano does I
mean Knight takes F5 it is is just
you're not even that much material down
now are you any material down actually
you're one point down and you've got all
of these threats still
um and yeah this is this is definitely
resignable this position I'd say
yeah yeah V6 was nice though it's kind
of move you wanted I really want to see
six on the ball it's like opening up
that bishop and getting every single
piece to attack but when you can just
grab a piece why not do it Knight d695
but right now a big question to not a
back how does he even survive the next
five moves David Betts here under 20 or
not
I'll say 21.
I'm going to say okay let's see who's
closest and um I think they deserve a
little prize or something so oh we have
another move here G6 and I I thought
this was a good option because at least
gives white the the idea and the the
temptation to grab that Rook grabbing
The Rook probably winning
why not well yeah and last night yeah I
mean it is a rook isn't it I mean if you
were down a piece now you're up in
exchange what's not to love yeah no it's
probably the best move but you have to
at least you know you have to calculate
Knight D6 as well here you know Simon
maybe the point is that now we're G6
that night on F5 that we were grabbing
after the check is defended exactly
that's right yeah I still want to play
Knight D6 even you know first of all but
I think grabbing The Rook is is the
sensible move but G6 is a good good
defense maybe the best defense I think
this will go on to move
30. oh 28. I'll go 28. yeah 21 28 25. 25
right the thing we know about Ivanka is
she always wins her predictions she's
like queen of predictions she needs to
buy more lottery tickets it's
really funny because in life I'm super
bad with numbers but somehow other I I
can guess
it's who's closest right and because
Ivanka said 25 I'll go with 24.
so crafty you're very good at these you
always manage to go last or something at
these predictions
ladies first has to be has to be done
but big trouble for another burger also
one and a half minutes on the clock
crazy wild position about losing
exchange but Fabi with a very tempting
option of coming in with that check to
D6 David what really happens if he
doesn't get materialistic and tries to
go for checkmate yeah let's uh check out
the most likely path from this point
Fabian is still with a lot of time of
course to work out to calculate what
happens the materialistic players would
take this rook and that is winning that
is confirmed by the engine as we see at
the bottom there as the best move and
he's just played it uh let's just go
back if he had given a check this is
also winning equally winning just in a
very different way and I think the
professional way is to take the material
think later but uh here
well where's the Checkmate maybe you
just give a check here no not that one
maybe the idea is just to go back and
win The Rook maybe that's why the
computer thinks uh in the first place uh
so okay Fabiana he went for the uh the
best approach of course he is
professional like that I just
interesting Simon here the third best
move was H4 what is that wow H4
apparently I mean I have to say if
anyone played H4 there and it was the
best computer move
because no one would play H4 in that
position at all and can he go back again
now oh I love this the Knight just cut
look at that what a beautiful idea
once
oh no just to show this would happen if
the Knight was captured but Knight to F7
it's just keeping the black king
stranded in the center you can never
Castle now I mean your material up
you're attacking You're Gonna Go Knight
D6 as well anyway so you know with an
extra Rook I saw a beautiful tactic show
us the event okay but okay it revolves
so it's making a non-non move for uh
yeah okay so I saw this idea of going
Bishop G5 and if King takes Knight work
takes Pawn
boom and you're gonna follow that
through after Queen takes work with e
sex
yep a royal Fork here with the pawn this
time you win the black queen and the
game yeah all of these tactics just in
the air and yeah how do you defend your
material down facing a brutal attack
like this it's over when the computer
says that a move like H4 gives you a
plus six plus seven whatever it's that
kind of position you know how bad it is
yeah right doesn't even give a sec
doesn't it doesn't even pick up the Rook
you can go H4 and you're completely
winning that's how bad it is for knotted
back up to satra but you might be
crossing the 20 move marks so I think I
think he's going to get to 24. I've gone
28 so it's 28 24 25 28
but David you were the closest and we do
get a miniature it is under 20 moves as
not about Abdul satra of throws in the
towel he has resigned
incredible opening there by Fabiano
caruana he takes the lead now the back
has to win the next game everything went
wrong in this one for black yeah I think
it was just a poor opening choice we
said it actually yesterday and the day
before Abdus he's been feeling out his
boundaries like seeing what he can get
away uh with kind of pushing for the
maximum in the opening and it's
backfired and uh okay he'll aim to
strike back with white in the next game
but this game still ongoing between
Wesley so and Dennis lazovic and this
looks very much more rational the
position first of all it's level
material almost symmetrical Pawn
structure the main differences being
here that white has this supreme Knight
in the center of the board on D5 nice
Outpost whereas black has the bishop
pair
first instincts here who would we choose
I'm I like the bishop there yeah I I
quite like white actually just having a
knight and in the center but
um I would also say pretty equal as well
so but I love I love having a night in
the center I'm in Knight in the center
of the board that can't be attacked is
is often better than a bishop nearly
always better than the bishop actually
but uh it's probably just fairly even
isn't it this one yeah I was also
leaning towards picking white until I I
started looking at the coordination
between all of the pieces and if you
take a look that night on G3 doesn't
have a role and doesn't can't see a
future for it either so that's why I'm
gonna say no I'm going to take the black
pieces because every single one of those
pieces minor pieces are working I like
that move that he's just played you've
got the bishop bear you want to open up
the game as much as you can trying to
create weaknesses in a white spawn
structure on the queen side it just
feels like in these kind of positions
it's sort of a long-term play for black
and that Knight on D5 it looks really
pretty Simon but perhaps black just ends
up playing around it because it doesn't
have any Targets yeah no it could be and
uh with that last move blacks Black's
creating a fret immediately I'm pretty
sure David would take black here being a
fan of the Bishops so uh and yeah I mean
it is true all the points you made look
make a lot of sense the Knight on G3 is
bad blacks attacking on the queen side
White's double pawns could be a Target
on the B file as well and with a move
like this white has to go into uh
defense as well which is which is not
ideal so uh maybe slightly better for
black then and again Dennis is uh he's
he's so good isn't he just grinding out
and this is an offer of a draw so uh
I mean I he has to fall back with the
Knight right to start with
I reckon yeah I mean I don't know I
think lazovic he'll look at the clock
he'll have one eye kind of focused on
the clock situation he'll also realize
that this is his type of position this
might be his best bet of beating Wesley
so and remember the chess gods do punish
players who don't uh play on when
they've got favorable positions if he
takes a draw here despite the fact he
has white in the next game I think
lazovic will be slightly kicking himself
he'll have it in his mind he'll say Okay
that was a bit negative so playing on
now I think would be very wise yeah
keeping the game going I mean he can buy
it as well you always have to think why
is my higher rated opponent offering a
draw and this was the move that I really
was wanted to see on the board the Night
Comes and destabilizes the protection of
the bishop and I was working it out and
it was looking quite okay for black it
also makes intentions clear that lasovic
is trying to play for a win here not
going back with the night not accepting
the repetition and that's a Champion's
mindset David when you're playing
against the wall number eight that's
true although if we're talking about
Generations do you know what a kind of
uh Grandmaster from the 1960s 1970s
would have done they would have repeated
once and then they would have played
Knight before they would have kind of
flicked in a couple of quick moves and
then asserted their dominance
psychologically they would have said
okay I teased you but no draw for you I
got your hopes up then crushed them uh
so going for this immediately night
before it's very tempting it looks like
a nice move uh from that's Vic I've
actually noticed that about the younger
generation they don't even repeat once
they say game on and not even giving
that hope but it does have a lot of
psychological aspect to doing that
because your opponent feels I mean we
saw it at the world championship right
uh with the yanding match and not
repeating it then going for that Rook G6
which pretty much won the match so yeah
yeah we played this game yesterday as
well Tanya I think you did where you
have to guess the accuracy
um or of that you know let's let's go
for Dennis's play anyone anyone want to
have a guess I mean he's he's uh he's a
machine as a clue 90s oh that's a clue I
was going to say 96 Simon uh 99 above 90
I have no idea how I find it I'm just
fine I thought I'd just throw it out
there
okay
99.7 yeah 99.7 is his accuracy wow which
is uh which is incredible right and
they've played 27 moves so it's uh it's
a lot you know yeah I mean just shows
how good he is right yeah yeah that's
why we talk about Styles in chess
because these two players especially
they have such kind of distinct Styles
they very rarely take chances they're
very smooth with their Play No risk uh
well at least averse to risk and no
chaos like we saw in the other battle uh
that kind of helps their accuracy levels
but also maybe lower risk lower reward
but here a lot of it can he push his
Advantage with more time on the clock I
want to ask you about what you mentioned
David about repetition and repeating
moves and then changing up how does it
work for you do you uh would you have
gone back and then changed knowing from
the very start that you don't want to
draw in this position yeah I would have
repeated instantly even if I knew that I
was going to play on for a win um I
think that's just a habit I've picked up
as a time travel addict In classical
chess I always want to play a couple of
extra moves to gain 30 seconds on the
clock to get closer to the time control
in Rapid chess it's maybe less relevant
where the increment here is just three
seconds but either way I found it has a
huge effect on the opponent I've known
so many opponents to just kind of lose
uh kind of lose their focus lose the
plot just by the fact that they've been
teased with the idea of a repetition an
idea of a draw
I think you have to be so strong in your
mind to know that you don't want to
repeat I've been in this situation and
for me I would want to change it up in
the first go otherwise I get really
tempted and start rethinking my decision
if I repeat it once do I want to bail
out do I have enough how does it work
for you Ivanka no I'm with David I've
read too many of those classical books
you know where it goes repeat once tempt
your opponent with that draw and then
snatch it away from the mother last
minute uh
it's the old school and I'm pretty old
school and I was looking at the position
and I was wondering what move is
Elizabeth considering is he thinking
about dropping the bishop to C2 is he
thinking about trading Knights because
there is a threat on the board of
actually White playing Bishop takes porn
although that might just be too much
greed yeah ideas such as Bishop takes
porn just undermining this night he
could have played that last move so I
guess maybe not a threat right now but
uh definitely lots of tempting options
for Las Vegas just to highlight some of
the ones you mentioned Ivanka first
thing to calculate um it wasn't even on
my radar to be honest uh Bishop to C2
looks very tempting attacking this Rook
attacking this Pawn but some calculation
to do there it becomes very very forcing
to play and uh Dennis lazovic under two
minutes maybe there are more kind of uh
pragmatic approaches you can drop your
Bishop back this way you can even just
trade Knights if you're kind of feeling
super safe here and not wanting to take
too much risk after all we've talked
about this night as being the pride and
joy of White's position and uh other
than that maybe you can take this Pawn
maybe you can activate this bishop into
the center just plenty of choice and
that's not necessarily a good thing in
Rapid chess you want one clear move that
you know is better than the rest and
lazovic eventually does trade
I like this decision as you said uh
David we've been talking about that
night being the key piece in White's
position and it's not easy what you want
to recapture with because if you go in
with the roof then your idea Bishop C2
gains in power Bishop C2 and it's on the
board we might be seeing Bishop C2 uh
and I was thinking if you take with the
pawn that's also not a happy decision
because black can then just put a
blockade in front of that pawn and
strategically these positions are so
difficult for white yeah this would have
been beautiful too this spawn looks nice
and strong it's a past Pawn but easily
blockaded and yeah Ivanka I heard you uh
exclaim that oh because Bishop C2 looks
strong and the evaluation bar has
dropped in uh lazovic's favor yeah you
guys know me so wow of course I'm gonna
get super excited if you offer me up
some free material I like my food I want
some grub and the first move that I
would be just thinking about is put that
Bishop there tack The Rook attack the
pawn
yeah and uh then I'd start calculating
looks like you win material and uh maybe
that's reflected in the computer's
evaluation as we see uh just at the
bottom of the screen it says plus 1.4
there for black and uh okay that move
was played and this is the current
position so I'm counting to be done this
Pawn is attacked and has just been taken
and the moves coming in thick and fast
here I'm expecting to see a trade maybe
you take this Pawn as well and uh I
guess Wesley is relying on the fact that
this Pawn is weak wow is there maybe
um Pawn takes pawn and then you back it
up with the move that you suggested uh
the centralized the Bishops so that you
can pounce on the weak Pawn yeah maybe
the bishop will come in the bishop we
saw it yesterday when Carolina
checkmated Magnus Carlson is two Bishops
against bishop and Knight here and it's
definitely in Black's favor it's just
about how much the advantage is how big
it is we've got most David he does start
by attacking the white Bishop on C5 and
then captures on C4 white can jump in
and take the A6 Pawn but I do see the
eval bar has leveled up so it looks like
the worst is over for white uh is it
risk free now but he jumps in with a
knight with a huge threat of a fork on
E7 first
yeah Knights on F5 being super strong
and even though this isn't the end game
that's a nasty threat Knight to E7 Shaq
would be devastating and suddenly the
clock times have totally reversed
lazovic was three four minutes up just a
few moves ago suddenly under 20 seconds
it's not just that the worst is over but
I think he's maybe missed a couple of
Wesley's uh last few moves
um still I would take back it feels like
as long as you don't walk into any nasty
night folks you're doing well but
suddenly white is active Wesley's really
upped his accuracy levels the last few
moves oh attack ing that Defender and
probably the only move in the position
for white to go on the counter of fans
of attacking blacks Bishop there yeah
maybe this is another thing that lazovic
has missed and it's so easy to miss
these one move tricks one move tactics
with only a few seconds left but okay it
continues White's Bishop now is under
Fire from the black Rook uh now that the
black bishops moved itself to safety
also watch out for the Black Sea Pawn to
drop down opening up and discovered
attack against the white Rook this was
necessary this was forced Wesley is
trying to relieve the tension
guide himself towards safety with an
exchange of Rooks seconds
yeah very tense and time I mean I I
think it should be a draw now because
the night is actually a very good piece
here I mean uh you can try to swap it
off for the bishop or just keep it in
the middle of the Border two Bishops I
mean uh is that given any advantage okay
the Knight is also maybe gonna head to
C3 at the right time to blockade that
pawn should be all right for right now I
feel it should be but we should mention
it's still a two result game only black
can really ever win this position and uh
worst comes to West for black you trade
off the dark Squad Bishop for white
tonight opposite color Bishops left it's
a draw but uh in the meantime lazovic
will push no risk at all yeah he's still
ambitious he wants to First expand on
the king side and the the concept of
creating two weaknesses try to get
another weakness going on the king side
that you can Target a black skin needs
to start coming into the game yeah it
needs to start coming into the game and
also take a look at the clock times 10
seconds for lasovic and 11 seconds and
Ticking down for Wesley so and I do like
the way that lasovic's been playing
throwing in a porn trade attack yeah is
he losing the F6 spawn
it looks that way I mean okay this is
the tactic to try and draw the game
immediately
um and I think he had to bail out there
otherwise as a pawn and the opposite Cod
Bishop's gonna be a draw yeah simply
black will protect his C Pawn with his
Bishop the black king will prevent uh
blockade the advance of any whites
kingside pawns and nothing to do with no
way to make progress that was a bit
Lucky from last Victor he was able to
pull the handbrake and uh kind of go
into reverse gear and make the draw he
had just Blended upon but in the end
Fair result yeah especially at the same
moment that he blundered he was able to
trade off and go into this opposite
color Bishop definitely quite a bailout
moment that he managed to capitalize and
now they just repeat there is nothing to
be done no progress to be made black
skin remains on shuffle on the white
squares uh and this one will end in a
draw but it was Dennis lazovic who was
pushing throughout in the game and had
some serious chances yeah and also with
the black pieces so it will be a
psychological advantage to the young
teenager and there we see the king
shuffling
I mean he's playing on he could have uh
he could have taken the draw I mean
you're a pawn-up you might as well see
if you can ever play F5 in this position
even if you can instead of dead draw so
it's actually a dead draw in every
single scenario I can think of but maybe
he just wants to say look you dominate
the game uh I I need to get back in the
right kind of State of Mind where you
know okay it's going to be a draw but
I'm a pawn up let's let's just uh let's
just annoy you a little bit even maybe
he has the idea of somehow making lots
of like none moves and then trying to
trick black this has to and put the king
and put the King on G4 if you got
everything how do you still trick black
well I just I need to put the white King
on G4 that's the only thing I can do and
then try and win the G5 points exactly
well then I would win the G5 Pawn
Yeah there'll be some check from the ca
diagonal but even then it's so obvious
as well but I don't think he has placed
the bishop on D2 though so he's kind of
buying the G5 one I thought black could
have played G4 actually just to really
you know make it a draw even more draw
than a real draw but it is yeah this is
this is even more drawn than I don't
know like kind of drawn than a drawn
draw draw I mean uh this okay well he's
I mean even an artist doesn't draw this
well yeah yes but this yeah it's just
Mind Games as you said Simon Wesley so
just trying to assert some kind of
psychological dominance over his young
opponent after suffering for most of the
game Watch Out for C3 check yeah
they have a lot of time now especially
Dennis lazovic so I don't think we'll
foresee any blunders here yeah I think
he's gonna push the
it's on the outside
's lodged that one yeah like spread
blockade obviously color Bishops dead
draw just shuffling around with the
bishop nothing to do
wow what a game and what a save by
Wesley this one too extremely fighting
games uh and it looks this will end in a
draw and then last gets uh to start with
the white pieces in the next one what
was impressive to me was his uh
declining a repetition earlier shows
that he doesn't fare Wesley and 100 yeah
I could have taken the draw
um which would have been a good result
with the black pieces uh getting white
in the next game where he could try his
little Catalan opening I expect that to
get a small Advantage but he said no I
I've got a better position I'm going to
try to win and um it made a lot of sense
and you know um he did push Wesley a
little bit and oh my God just stop it
now just stop it you've had enough he's
trolling us right now uh they're like
let's I can can they play another poor
move or something this is this is just a
bit painful now so there's absolutely no
reason to play online
is it gonna be 50 move rule that ends
this game for God's sake no I think they
should both lose if they get to 50 moves
here just give them give them like
quarter of a point each wouldn't make
any difference at all because they still
have to go play on but Dennis lazovic
has got over a minute and a half and
finally this one does end in a draw what
a marathon fight and I think it's Wesley
still who's got reasons to be relieved
after that he was a under pressure by
the 16 year old Dennis lazovic pushing
with the black pieces it ended in a draw
and in the other one it was Fabiano
caruana from the start to finish
dominating what a performance that David
what was the big moment for you for me
it was just fabulous Fabiano and his
opening preparation Carolina just
blowing his opponent off the board
winning in a mere 19 moves it was a
miniature and it all started here with
black neglecting his development not
having castled his King and this is why
we always say castle before move 12 if
you can Castle as early as possible
otherwise you might just get punished
and here the center is blocked hence why
after the story thought he could get
away with it but this was the move that
exploded the position Pawn to G4 a
beautiful Sacrifice from Fabiano uh
offering a pawn here first of all when a
night jump would have been deadly this
Pawn dropping next this night about to
Feast on some pawns but after the more
critical haunted C4 he was even willing
to sacrifice a bishop exploding the
position against the opponent's king
dropping his Knight in now was deadly
and as we saw bringing the into F7 was
the beautiful Clincher this Knight
simply taboo poisoned because of the
pawn stepping to E6 just start to finish
a great attacking game that was awesome
first sacrifice with Bishop F5 one piece
and then jumping in with that Knight to
F7 which was pure Devastation uh for
black let's take a look at our score
line and again in the losers bracket
it's a best of two for not a backup
disaster that means only one thing he
needs to win the next game to force an
Armageddon meanwhile after a big big
fight and a big battle a Wesley and
Dennis lastowick ended peacefully the
final rapid game in the loser
semi-finals is coming up but don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
10 seconds
he blundered his Queen
no 40 more seconds
overboard
he's just gonna move quickly oh
my gosh
[Music]
September Bots are here and it's time
for a Monumental Clash this Barbarian
might not Crush you on the board but he
certainly can Crush you with the board
speaking of crushing this giant is a
living Siege Tower usually found in
groups goblins are fond of sharp pointy
objects end other people's pieces
battleheart in Valkyrie might give you a
game once she's done arm wrestling a
Golem
this hog rider and his Noble Steed might
give you a headache or two skeletons
adore her boom
you'll need to bring your A game if you
want to be this witch yes that probably
is a rabbit up his sleeve or a huge
Fireball with your name on it we hear
Wizards are pretty good at chess
not just a killing machine Pekka loves
tiny butterflies but you're probably not
a butterfly so watch out
the Archer Queen thinks highly of
herself and for good reason she is a
skilled tactician deadly opponent and
your worst nightmare play them all on
chess.com
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
[Music]
oh
a power play performance by Fabiano
caruana in that game one against not the
back up to such Rove and he's been
having some great performances over the
last year and his consistent play in the
Champions Chester sees him seal that
spot into the Toronto finals already but
it has been quite a journey for Fabi
from being only three classical rating
points away from overtaking Magnus
Carlsen in the 2018 reading list the
American Grand Master did lose his
motivation but now Fabiano caruana is
definitely back
I don't know back where he belongs with
another medal around his neck feeling
motivated after three difficult years
I think covert definitely uh impacts me
negatively for quite quite a lot so the
20 20 21 years were pretty tough and I
lost a lot of motivation and I think
that definitely
um
tarnish where I play a little bit in
September 2022 Fabiana caruana dropped
to 27-54 In classical rating his lowest
rating in over nine years it all started
to spiral downwards after the first half
of the candidates in 2020. the American
was tied for third place when the
tournament was suspended
I didn't work on chess for like months
and months like at someone I wasn't even
looking at
like four months I just didn't look at a
chessboard uh
so that's definitely not good for your
chest I have to say when the candidates
continued in 2021 he was not able to
clinch the spot in the world
championship match against Magnus
Carlsen and soon Lost His World number
two rank for the first time in over
three years the Fabiano caruana that was
only three rating points away from being
world number one and came close to
beating Magnus Carlson in the world
championship in 2018 was nowhere to be
seen I think 2018 was overall my best
year
I my quality of play was probably
highest then than in any other year that
I've played 2018 it was it was far from
Clear who was playing the best chess in
the world but yeah looking back on it of
course uh it does feel like like a very
long time ago a lot has happened since
then the struggles continued in 2022
when he got another chance in the
candidates it was kind of going well for
that first happened and I just crashed
and burned so that was probably the most
difficult moment for me in last few
years after the candidates and then I
dropped all my reading as well in the in
the Olympiad I thought I think I dropped
like 20 25 points I'm not even sure and
my play was pretty much like I didn't
even know what I was doing I couldn't
even recognize my own play something had
to happen recently Fabiano started
working with Gregory o'parin he won the
U.S Championship came second in Norway
chess and most recently finished third
in the world cup to clinch a spot in his
fifth ever candidates tournament finally
Fabiana caruana is also back to being
world number two ready to chase down
Magnus Carlsen definitely there's there
have been some bright moments in the
last last few months and I started to
feel like my play has returned to a
level that I can
um that I can fight for the best spots
in the world
the reigning U.S Champion world number
two with some fantastic performance
incredible player at the World Cup and
then the video World rapid Team
Championship with a fantastic score of
nine and a half points out of a possible
11 and he did win the gold medal in that
one as well but 2018 the world
championship match it did feel like that
took a lot away from Fabi what do you
think happened there yeah it's
understandable I think for anyone in
their careers they have this huge goal
and he was climbing climbing that was
kind of the Pinnacle for him and to get
so close just a few tie break games away
just a few accurate moves away and then
uh to kind of get it ripped away from
you it's hot must be heartbreaking and
of course it takes a lot to bounce back
but it's nice to see he's rediscovered
his motivation it's great to see Fabiano
playing the kind of swashbuckling chest
we just saw in that last game yeah it is
it's really nice and uh I I guess it's
that point you know your dreams become
world champion right so you're always
trying to become world champion and um
you don't become world champion and you
start to think well I might not ever get
a chance of doing that again and uh
that's going to be quite a depressing
thought when you come so close as he did
but he's back now he's back playing
great and uh just the fact that Magnus
is probably not around to contest that
anymore is uh is is positive news for
him and uh I think he's got a chance of
becoming world champion a really good
chance actually it's a it's a nice
opportunity it's nice motivation for him
because like Fabiano said you know those
years were very difficult for him and
let's not forget that after the world
championship he also had a split from
his second of many years bristum
kazamajanov and so you know he had to
find his feet he had to find his
bearings and okay now he has the
ambition to actually go for the top yeah
and he's doing it with his recent
performances it's incredible to see Fabi
back in the Chess World with renewed
ambition motivation and some incredible
player just like what we saw in his win
against another back in round one and
this is the moment that everyone
watching you guys can win a really cool
mystery box but first you have to answer
this trivia question of the day
and here it is who was the first player
younger than Carlson to beat him after
he became world number one I'm trying to
think of the answer to this not an easy
one at all but chat everyone watching
we're not alone in struggling because
take a look at what happened when David
and Simon tried to answer this
this is just wrong I need more time so I
don't think it's going to be pride pride
was about four years old
no I don't know let me have a thing
that's a really tough one to get
oh I was so so confident that I got it
but okay no spoilers but I got the
second youngest close but not close
enough it's a tough question Simon it's
a really tough question I mean I I had
no idea I'll be honest my brain was
thinking prag but then I I worked out
he's probably about one year old at that
time so I was like oh hello and I had to
rethink and uh I got nowhere near it's a
very hard question that one see yeah
it's gonna be uh fun to get our answers
in so get your phones out and the using
the hashtag chess Champs tweet your
answers to us tweet our ex your answers
to us and one of you will win a surprise
Clash chess Mystery Box it will come
your way but you gotta get that answer
right we will reveal the answer and the
winner to our trivia at the end of the
day will this be the end of the road for
another back up to satrobe as he has to
win against Fabiano and this match which
ended in a draw it is still tight will
this go down to an Armageddon or will we
have a decisive result three events for
Wesley so meanwhile a debut for
danislasovich the youngest player ever
to make it to division one of the
Champions Chester Fabiano caruana is
ready to go not about looking confident
yeah he is a teenager after all
teenagers are renowned for their
confidence
um you know if there's some kind of
freedom in having your back against the
wall you can let go you don't need to
stress about the results and there we
see nordebec with the white pieces
opening up by developing the knights and
then fianchetta his Bishop onto that
beautiful long diagonal
yeah really flexible approach here from
White he starts with what we call the
reti opening but it can transpose will
he go into the Catalan here uh you can
play in this uh kind of really kind of
flank opening type of manner as well
where you don't necessarily fight with
the center directly as white but you
have your Bishops poised beautifully on
the longest possible diagonals and uh
later you can choose how to strike how
to uh kind of Fight For That central
ground I like the approach but Fabiano
is well prepared and of course he's seen
this all before
what do we think of this opening from
Abdus tour of does it suit her style
maybe that's the big question
I think it's um I mean it's not a bad
idea just to keep the pieces on the
board and get to a middle game position
you can play it's so hard finding
something against the likes of Fabiano
opening wise because you know you know
he's so well prepared so you just got to
try to get a position which keeps some
tension and uh this seems like such a
thing where you you keep the piece on
the board you've got a different Pawn
structure uh White can now try to
advance and send to a D4 Black's very
solid though it should be a fairly even
structure but yeah I mean you've got a
game you've got a game of chess there
right and does white wanna kind of
develop the pieces and even start moving
those pawns forward on the right side of
the board or are you going to do it like
Simon says just commit and push that
deep Pawn forward play becomes very
concrete if you do do that Santa push
yeah first I guess both players will
just be trying to Kind of Perfect their
pieces uh find the best squares for them
and only when they're ready then we'll
see those Pawn breaks black there
Fabiano hinting that he might fight on
the queen side with some Pawn pushes
white as Ivanka mentioning flexible
kingside Center
um it's all about the structure here all
about when you kind of go for that break
and until that moment happens I think
it's just pure maneuvering it's all
about peace activity and these players
of course so so good at that
early days
yeah Alita isn't it and um it seems yeah
a very quite a typical middle game I
mean you do tend to think having more
pawns than the center of the board is a
favorable thing that's why a lot of
people play the Sicilian opening because
uh they like having Pawns in the center
in the middle game and the ending so
white does have that Advantage here but
with the last move Fabiano is preparing
to advance on the queen side white stops
that but he gives away an important
Square there the the Black Knight can
now come in and grab that square at some
point so this has all been seen quite a
fair few times before I think this this
kind of uh strategy that both players
are using here a very rich middle game
with all the minor pieces on the board
everything to play for exactly what not
a Becker needs given the math situation
he's also keeping the pressure on the
club clock and while fabi's Knight jumps
in and not a back has a think on how to
create his chances in this game Let's
head over to uh Dennis lazovic with the
white pieces about to make his first
move against Wesley so he starts with
the Queen's Pawn opening uh David are we
expecting this game to be the decisive
one or will Wesley be happy getting this
into an Armageddon well we know Wesley
we know uh kind of how he approaches
chess especially with the black pieces
it's just about being Rock Solid
surviving and okay he chooses the
Queen's Gambit accepted
um very trendy stuff we've got to say
for years and years everyone was playing
the Queen's Gambit declined not
capturing the white Pawn on C4 so
temporarily at least Wesley is a pawn up
but yeah of course uh I think if he's
given a chance to just try and equalize
this game take it into Armageddon he
would do that it's just so close to
these two guys lazovic really really
fighting well this is the main kind of
start position the tabia for uh the
Queen's Gambit accepted and Dennis
Davidson you told me here I get this
position a lot and I remember you
recommended to me I've forgotten totally
what you recommended it was something to
do with E4 he recommended you said
because I said to David I had this
position a lot as white and I wasn't
getting very good positions and David
said you maybe try this idea so come on
teach me what's the move you mentioned
well there's actually various ways for
white to play this I think there are at
least five or six very viable options
here maybe even more
um yeah I did mention that pawn to E4
here is a decent sacrifice very playable
I think I also mentioned the move Rook
to E1 which uh yeah supports the pawn
pushing E4 and sell him over won a
really nice game against Animusic in the
world cup using that move uh so yeah
it's okay there's aggressive ways to
play this there's maybe more strategic
ways to play this is gone for the latter
I have to listen to a bit more in future
I think so make sure make sure that
information gets absorbed in maybe we're
down the good night though so you know
that's my excuse me yeah okay for a few
glasses of wine oh of course of course
yeah makes rates yeah that sounds good
to me
this is a very positional move though I
I mean I I do know this move uh where
the bishop tries to re-route to where
the white knight is and uh a lot of
players were playing this kind of idea
uh in some situations so if black
Advance is on the queen side and tries
to finish Chateau his light Square
Bishop uh the white Bishop is well
positioned to meet that plan a more
positional approach probably suiting
Dennis's style of play
yeah Bishop Bishop you it's not the most
often played move in my experience with
this Queen's combat accepted structures
there are all these lines with Bishop
coming back to B3 or the A4 move that
you were talking about but now with the
center all dissolved Ivanka would you
make of these trades because again in my
experience it's never as simple as it
looks even though it's sort of
liquidated there is still poison in the
position that black needs to watch out
for exactly and one of the key things
that I've actually discovered in these
type of positions it's like black that
actually doesn't have a safe place for
the queen and you might be asking me
what do you mean the queen and it's to
do with the fact that once the minor
pieces all find their home the Rooks
will all centralize and if black can
find a good Square for it
maybe out to A5 if that's possible then
uh then black will be a fine but if
black doesn't have a square then there's
going to park it and some really weird
location and that is often a problem
and white meanwhile continues to develop
his Bishops the other problem with
Black's position very often in these
setups is where do you place your light
Squad Bishop the bishop and see it
because it would be natural to push your
B5 Pawn get it to B7 but that little
Bishop B2 notice how that Bishop can
come to F3 and then start creating
problems if a black was to go for this
plan uh David is it fair to say that
Dennis given his style of play should be
pleased with this opening outcome I
definitely think so um actually B5 just
played there so allowing this uh this
move hitting the rook in the corner I
guess the move uh Rook to A7 will then
happen but yeah Dennis he's got a
symmetrical Pawn structure here minimal
risk you can create some small threats
here with white you can hit that Rook
using the move Bishop to F3 you can kind
of push this Pawn forward asking
questions later of Black's Queen side
porn structure and in general these
positions they're very close to level
but it's always seems to be black who's
fighting for equality uh often in
symmetrical positions white does have
this kind of uh small Advantage just
because you have the the advantage of
the first move just because you're the
first one to create threats to finish
development and here if we catch up with
the current position we do see this
tension between the light squared
Bishops I have actually I think seen
this position before and yeah it's very
balanced but black is the one fighting
uh black is the one who has to show
accuracy so still some questions for
Wesley so to answer he'll want to trade
as many pieces off the board as possible
and make sure that his Queen side pawns
aren't too weak oh Wesley is
and not having any apparent weakness in
the pawn structure just yet I think it
should also be level for him I'm gonna
make a prediction I think this one will
go into an exciting Armageddon meanwhile
in the other one it is absolute chaos
and let's jump over to nordeback's
position because the last move Harry the
H Pawn has started marching down the
board and that makes one commentator in
the studio extra happy it's always good
to see the H porn run down the board
um on my computer here it's been given
to dubious Mark so hang on a minute
you feeling all right yeah okay it's
never a bad move
um and black meeting that with uh push
of the F Pawn as well and the the
structure has changed quite a bit well
maybe not too much but we've had some
pieces come off and uh White's lost his
light Square Bishop which is usually a
very good piece of white so that must
benefit black and
um I don't know I mean it's it seems
fairly even still at this uh this moment
in time I guess the reason to push the H
Pawn was to support a white knight
jumping in so that that would be the the
first move I I think white could
consider here just putting the Knight
there because of his exchange you
obviously open up the H file but maybe
it's an easy threat to stop and there's
going to be a lot more maneuvering until
this really comes to life I think but it
will certainly come to life as naughty
Beck has to win hence why he's playing
moves like H4
yeah it's uh this type of Pawn structure
I've actually had it a lot throughout my
own career as mostly from the white side
and I love fabiana's last move as black
because if he had done nothing here if
he had just been too slow played the
neutral moves such as kind of uh just
moving his Queen then I think it would
be a perfect timing for white to start
advancing and it might look
counter-intuitive but as soon as your
Pawn gets to G5 black is pretty much
immobilized let's just say black gives
white next remove uh suddenly here white
has control over the entire board this
bishop will never be challenged on the
long diagonal and is simply what we call
a pawn storm uh Pawn will step four to
H5 eventually after preparing it you
step forward to G6 so it's all about
Pawn structures here Fabiano realized he
couldn't allow this kind of wedge this
structure here with the strong Advanced
White pawns so he fights for space
himself and now look at what's happening
in the center Fabiano struck out with F5
and nordeback says okay I accomplished
my g-pawn I'm gonna fight in the center
instead you note how this Pawn is
undefended at least temporarily and some
tactics now and not just upon the bishop
behind the pawn was undefended as well
so trying to sidestep those tactics
Bishop F6 but this kind of allows
another tactic what's going on if white
actually grabs that pawn I was gonna say
and then give a check and take the other
Pawn but it doesn't work David yeah it
doesn't quite work uh this would have
been on fabiana's radar of course you
would love to grab this Pawn right now
uh in an interesting position if you
don't but if you do unfortunately then
it takes Knight is a discovered attack
against the White Queen so okay instead
we see the Knight does land on G5 as
Simon predicted big threat on the board
this would be a nasty fork for porn
undefended you have to either hold it
with your Rook or with your queen I
don't think you really want to take this
Knight because again talking of Pawn
structures once a portal lands on G5
it's all about the dark squares here and
a new Avenue has been opened up for
attack along the H file uh it's
definitely not a back here kind of
making moves he's the one kind of on the
front foot putting Fabiana under
pressure and first of all big threat to
deal with
I find it super interesting the way that
nordeback has played this and to me it's
reminiscent of the new generation
because nordeback has been very careless
with his squares I mean take a look at
that G4 Square for a knight that could
potentially arrive there and then he's
also given away control of the D4 square
and I just feel like in the olden days
like 10 years ago no one would have
touched anything like that and now on
order back is like well I'm just gonna
say ugly chess but it doesn't matter
because activity is everything and I I
I kind of see where he's going but at
the same time I feel it's very very
risky because you can't Retreat porn
moves unfortunately and uh yeah Queen
does step forward and defend the E6 Pawn
I'm very very worried for Nordic because
I feel that the next move for Fabi is
actually just a plant a bishop on the D4
square and then just start kicking the
White Knight back but to the point that
you're making Ivanka it's also the math
situation right you need to go all out
you need to ask your opponent questions
early on and I think in this kind of a
format it's so important to get these
kind of dynamic positions and I I feel
like this is never the approach that not
about would have in a normal classical
game but being down a point and having
to win this game it kind of makes sense
because he gets a position for all three
results it's when you're playing against
someone like Fabi maybe that's the kind
of chest that you need to play yeah but
it can backfire big time right
because it's not easy for white to cover
those squares absolutely there is
another plan here isn't there that
that's quite common to this kind of
position when you get the Knight there
and uh
um I I don't know if it works but you've
got to calculate in this position and it
is Queen H5 you've got to calculate the
most forcing moves and the point of this
is that if H6 I mean you can take the
Knight but you open up the H file and
this should be some kind of pressure at
least so the only other way to stop this
is by playing H6 and you you can play
Queen G6 here this is a quite a common
theme now obviously the evaluation Bar
says it doesn't work but if you're
facing this you'd have to calculate this
very carefully because now you've got to
eliminate that Knight and uh obviously
you take with the H Pawn and the Rooks
come into H1 and again a very standard
attacking pattern here and the
evaluation Bar says it's nonsense but
again you've got to defend this position
you've got to find the Right Moves so
maybe this is what uh naughty Beck is
just thinking about here and I'm
assuming he can black and defend
um relatively easy they probably have to
give his Bishop up maybe here to do so
so it's uh it's kind of worth
considering at least this this
continuation yeah Simon I mean I've just
checked the engine it looks very
dangerous actually white would have a
huge attack if it wasn't for this move
Pawn to E5 and look what Fabian has done
uh the queen here on C6 suddenly opens
up kicking away the White Queen and
blacks just in time uh know how the
queen is defended as well by Black's
Knight on B4 and if you trade Queens
it's all over having sacrificed a piece
and this is the fine margins here
White's attack might even be decisive
you might be winning on the spot if it
wasn't for just this one silent move
three or four moves down the variation
that's why nordebec has now suddenly
paused for two and a half three minutes
to think because this is the direction
he's looking in and it doesn't quite
work but it's so tempting for a human if
you miss the C5 move you go for it and
you think you're winning yeah and that's
one of the reasons why Fabi is known to
be one of the best calculators in the
world to move Queen C6 not only pinning
that E4 Pawn but the line that we just
saw and making sure that the queen can
have a defense on the king side it's
also quite impressive the way nadebeck
has managed to adapt to the situation he
lost his first game in a disastrous
manner right it's not about the result
it's just the way the game went and then
to quickly have this mind shift and not
let it affect you to come back and kind
of play this aggressive style of play
which of course can backfire but also
gives white chances do you think this is
also something which is very
characteristic of this new generation
that they're really able to keep what's
happened behind them super quickly yeah
I definitely think that and I think it's
to do with the fact that they play so
many games of Chess I mean nordeback
said it himself in the interview you
know he has six to seven tournaments
lined up in the coming future I mean
before that's I'm kind of unheard of and
now you know you when you play so much
chess you have to be pragmatic you just
get used to losing and you get used to
being in those must win situations and
you just come see come sir whatever
happens
how is it for you side how did you
recover after a tough day I think I know
the answer but yeah I mean um
Family Family Show yeah I know I am yeah
I mean it's it's losing a chess is one
of the most painful experiences actually
it's really hard to explain to a
non-chess player I think those who've
had relationships with uh uh you know
other halves who don't play chess and
you lose a horrible game of chess and
they say it's only a game what are you
worried about you're like
it's not only a game it's my life and
the feeling is uh tremendous you know
what's the worst one is winning and
losing is a part of the game
when they go
oh that's all right you paid really
really well and you're just like oh
don't worry about it don't worry about
the result just have fun you tried your
best yeah yeah so I'm not gonna have fun
unless I win you know it's like anyone
who says just the taking part absolute
nonsense now you guys know what not to
say to a chess player after a game but
we are getting a big update that we
already have a result in the Wesley
versus Dennis lazovic game and that one
has ended in a draw so it goes into a
bidding Armageddon that's gonna be fun
that is gonna be fun who do you think
will choose white oh I think whoever
chooses black would have a huge
Advantage there just the fact that
they're both so solid and especially
Wesley so that last draw the The Queen's
Gambit accepted that we saw it was
painless actually after just 16 moves
lazovic was so kind of unenthused with
his chances he offered a draw and there
was still Queens on the board still
Rooks on the board but it was
symmetrical and he just said okay let's
take it to Armageddon so yeah he's he's
ready he's banking on his speed there
lazovic but whoever gets black I think
will be in charge because of the droids
and why it has to win well well that is
later first it's all eyes on this one
and we were talking about the bishop
getting planted on D4 a nice spot taking
care of taking advantage of the
weaknesses that NADA back has created
with his ambitious play uh it suddenly
looks like things are turning around is
Fabby the one who's in driver's seat
yeah I think Ivanka we need to look into
a crystal ball because you talked about
two squares a few moves ago and somehow
I mean I was thinking okay white so
active black will never get access to
those squares somehow blacks pieces seem
to be swarming forward look at it look
at those two black knights entrenched on
outposts defended outposts anchored by
pawns as well white can never kick away
those two black knights out of his half
with pawns ever again Black's Bishop
looks pretty nice right now you can
eliminate it but I don't think you
should touch that pawn there is a nasty
night check uh coming in on E3 Black's
Pieces Just flooded forward in the space
of two or three moves and none of X
actually put his Rooks on really
unfortunate squares both of the white
Rooks are targets and one of them might
well just get trapped in the next couple
of moves yeah I mean Ivanka called this
I mean you called all the squares and as
you say David look look at the pieces
all the blacks pieces have got beautiful
outposts haven't they just flooding into
the position and uh I think I it's a
Pity to seek like naughty Beck
go down this way because we've seen in
previous editions he's uh he's so strong
right he's such a good player and uh he
hasn't he hasn't really shined uh in in
this leg at all
um but you know he is qualified for the
final so maybe maybe that's why he's uh
been experimenting with uh different
styles of play here I guess when the
pressure's off but this this looks
pretty horrible right yeah how to deal
with this threat if the Knight jumping
into E3 with the track and it's not just
the Knight the bishop can also move into
the hair as well the other Rook
yeah it's not easy you would want to
eliminate one of these strong black
pieces but if you take here it's only
replaced by a pawn attack in the night
and still this idea remains uh persists
of Knight to E3 check so he's had to run
away with his Rook uh at least giving
breathing space to the other Rook as
well but the white Rook just came to D1
just a couple of turns ago he's lost uh
valuable time there valuable Tempe
um I'll do the tour of okay this night
check doesn't come with a fork this time
still looks very attempting to me this
bishop check at least uh sorry this
bishop attack would at least uh checking
the white Rook went to force a retreat
but what next look at fabiana's pieces
they've invaded but you still need the
final breakthrough at some point you
might decide when to open up the center
kind of by pushing pawns trading Pawns
Fabiano he's got a beautiful position he
just needs to back it up now
yeah I mean at some point maybe he can
open it up more with E5 if he times it
right just to try to get the Rook uh or
next to the King on f8 into the game but
you certainly don't rush that move
because you give white some squares as
well but
um this could be a key moment though is
there is there something clear here that
can give black
um some kind of
um should we say material advantage
because that's often what you do you get
a positional Advantage you dominate the
game and then you have to transform that
even to a material advantage or to a big
attack and I wouldn't be surprised if
there there was something I can't I
can't see yeah an obvious way to get get
winner porn for example here yeah I
don't see any way to transform the
advantage I think Fabiano might just
start building up he might start
doubling his Rooks on the D file uh he
might invade first and then go for a
similar idea while he even takes the
time out to just play the move H6 uh
removing the threat of the white knight
ever Landing back on this G5 Square the
threatening square that we've seen
actually uh kind of be a theme of
today's match so he's taking a slow
approach Fabiano here but he's got
control why not he's got that luxury but
you know what I think he's uh lining
things up for the bishop to come to
attack the rook and then break open with
E5
and the big idea that then you're gonna
actually go one square forward with your
F Pawn if allowed and just completely
ruin the white defenses do you know the
real problem for white has been losing
that light Square Bishop as well as
giving away a lot of squares but you
have to be so careful in nearly every
position when you have a fear and
chateaued Bishop exchanging it you
nearly always want to keep your fear and
Chateau Bishop in front of your king I
should add because it gives your king
great protection and uh I I was saying
like 80 of cases exchanging off that
Bishop in front of your king the
fianchetto bishop will weaken your
position and you can see the white king
is just feeling the absence of that
Bishop here uh the black queen lining up
against it uh you know the knights ready
to jump in and uh that was that was a
very good exchange that Fabiano made
earlier on by moving his Knight to to
make that exchange and we credited
fabiana's preparation in the previous
game for just kind of delivering that
quick early knockout but this game as
well great preparation because he
understands the pawn structure
um this type of lion uh Ivanka you were
saying oh it's really historic the old
days they wouldn't have played it
um it did go through a phase of
popularity and I think actually I
studied something similar with Fabiano
this Pawn structure at least and uh yeah
he knows where to put the pieces he knew
kind of when to try and uh go for this
B5 break forcing white to give up and
Outpost and it's kind of it flows from
the opening not all opening preparation
is memorizing this move this move this
move followed by that move if the
opponent does this sometimes it's just
okay this Pawn structure where do I put
my pieces right and uh yeah I think he's
just got this kind of Head Start in the
game because of uh knowing that kind of
that previous knowledge of uh where his
pieces really really worked territory
totally agree with you there David and I
also think that uh Nordic just simply
misplayed because I I too have studied
this type of position before and white
was always kind of using the G pool to
extend on that particular side of the
board not the edge Pawn sorry Simon
it was shots fired Harry the H Pawn
friendship over well I I have to agree
if it's right and um it's not always a
good move I'm learning pushing the H
Pawn so I have tried it on move one it
didn't work as well so you have to you
have to be careful but okay at least
White's now exchanging off somebody's
good pieces uh that black has and I'd
imagine exchanges I was going to say to
help the position but maybe they don't
because you you still got this major
problem with the open D file forever did
they say that when you have
um an advantage like this which is very
much strategic you swap off pieces
because then it becomes even bigger yeah
because it becomes harder yeah exactly
that D3 Pawn which you're talking about
Simon on the open file the more pieces
that get swapped off it's going to be
hard for white to switch the fans from
one side notice how the A4 Pawn is weak
and the D3 Pawn exactly so David and
Simon do you approve of this rule I
approve especially in situations where a
draw is fine like it is the Fabiano
swapping pieces you know it might not be
the most dynamic approach you might not
be able to deliver Checkmate anymore as
black but yeah you've got the Strategic
kind of long term I think we saw enough
fun with the pieces on the board in the
first game don't we so I mean I think
they're he's allowed to swap some off in
this game I mean he uh he delivered that
beautiful beautiful attack in the first
game and he's playing well isn't he he's
playing really well uh today making this
look very clinical game one was this
power performance from the opening and
just crushed through and here he's just
had the advantage with the black pieces
and uh Harry the H Pawn I think it all
comes down to the squares that you were
pointing out it really did backfire for
white what is the strategy then when
you're in a must win situation how do
you fight these guys
uh I wish I knew I was recently in a
must win situation at the World Cup and
I didn't know I just thought okay I'll
play a slightly aggressive opening but
they know how to take the sting out and
they know which pieces to trade they're
very good I think kind of to get to the
elite level you need to know how to draw
against the best players and then you
need to learn how to beat them and they
do have this kind of they can kind of
switch up gears depending on who they're
playing depending on the tournament
situation match situation they have
strategies openings prepared especially
I think I think a lot of top players
from the World Cup David uh they they
didn't have that they're missing that
kind of uh second gear I mean you know
even Prague I think in the final against
Magnus he sort of didn't really have
they didn't have those openings which
could really get something obviously
against Magnus that's nearly impossible
but I mean whoever you are but it's it's
so hard isn't it to literally you know
do you keep the pieces on play a normal
game wait for a chance do you play
something risky like a Gambit no one
does that anymore no one tries gambits
um some reason you know why I don't know
they're all mad just Gambit King's
Gambit Evans Gambit elephant Gambit
um that's all I can think of at the
moment come on help me out yeah no um
there we go
help your encounter there you go the
Halloween Gambit what's there's one
Gambit I can never pronounce it
ishara that's a good one actually that's
not a bad one but what's the one that's
like the Budapest but not the Budapest
where you put the knight in the middle
it's the
ferreroids that's the one that's the one
I haven't pronounced that one no right
either viewers we need help what's your
favorite Gambit yes drop it in the chat
tell us your favorite Gambit and uh and
yeah it looks like position is going
from bad to worst King been put on H3
that can't be a very good sign no and
then he switches gas with the queen
coming to F3 I was expecting black to do
the whole alkyne battery on the d-line
and try try and Target D3 so what's
going on with Fabi bringing that D7 Rook
back to d8 what's the plan how do you
improve this position with black or is
he just saying I'm going to hold on I
want to see what you got feels like
Fabiano is caught in no man's land he's
being a bit indecisive right now he's
just kind of waiting and that's a decent
strategy here because it's really hard
for white to do anything but yeah I
would have loved to see it as well uh
the Tanya just setting up the Alicorns
gun he actually got success well almost
almost won that fourth game against
Magnus yesterday he set up the alakons
gun two Rooks and a queen I kind of
lined up on the same uh file but uh okay
so that right now and that might spin
you know move it because the bishop and
A1 hangs problems
then the D3 Pawn is going to be super
weak
maybe you have to fix the center David
let's jump in and show uh the dilemma
here for another big after if it's just
a pressure on this diagonal finally we
do see the purpose behind all of those
Maneuvers and okay uh fixing the center
here would not have been ideal because
well no matter where the black queen
goes even if it steps back suddenly look
at this bishop in the corner it's never
going to break out and you're never
going to remove these two stones in your
side instead he has played Rook to C1
and this is met by simply a rook move
Fabiano he's been dancing around a bit
indecisively with those Rooks but he
clearly has this target of the D3 Pawn
backward Pawn can never move and
sooner or later it might just drop the
luxury of space right you can dance
around you can attack one side of the
board and then the other one and that's
what Fabi is doing he's combining
threats on the d-line along with the
Knight on C3 along with that pawn on A6
it's so much easier for black uh to move
around with these pieces and just set up
these track threats while for not to
back every move is costly on the clock
because it's not easy to find it's not
easy to find at all and I I got briefly
a little bit optimistic about
nordeback's position because I saw that
he has this G3 G4 push maybe open up the
G line but you can't be doing those type
of things if your Center is about to
collapse so unfortunately nordebec is in
full hold it in the middle mode
and uh Fabiano now has the tempting
option of retreating blacks Bishop
getting the black Bishop out of the way
or doing something with it at least
because the Rooks are stacked up against
that weak pawn it feels there we go he
Retreats and big big threat Rook takes
D3 that backward Pawn we highlighted on
the d-file
you have to just defend it there we go
look at how passive White's Brooks have
been just throughout the last 20 moves
uh the Rooks always seem to end up on
this kind of file just passive versus
active black Brooks and it's not a good
sign if you compare all the pieces none
of the white pieces are more active than
their counterparts and oh wow he loses
patience Ivanka again looking at Turkey
because there's nothing else to play
it's on the body
but it's burned the bridge is bad bad
bad but you know if you want to win that
is the only move that you can play I
thought he'd do it with the King on H3
at least then maybe he could uh set
something a light on the G line button
up
an interesting Fabi could have landed an
instant blow there I think he could have
clinched his place uh in the next round
but he didn't maybe show alertness he
didn't react he's just kind of
maintained the status quo let's just
jump in there was this critical moment
where white did push G4 and
okay the position is exploding if
Fabiana had taken this Pawn I just want
to say Bishop to E3 would have been a
knockout attacking The Rook winning a
pawn simply and this would have been
pretty much game over instead let's
catch up with the current game position
after the move G4 Fabiano ignored it
attacking this Knight and after Pawn
takes born he simply gobbled up a piece
and it's chaos on the board wow white is
a whole piece down but suddenly look at
the massive Pawns
it's a real army of Pawns marching
forward and David if black actually
moves that Rook white has got the option
to go E5 and disconnect
so you might have to be
albar says moving The Rook is a bad bad
idea so Black's got to capture one of
White's pieces either The Rook or the
bishop on A1 what's the way forward then
yeah we get a hint here from stockfish
from the computer at the best move the
only move to keep the advantage now is
actually to take this bishop in the
corner and he has done it Fabiano he did
capture this bishop allowing his Rook to
drop but suddenly it is chaotic black
might still have the advantage but
anything can happen with these pawns
marching forward and suddenly black
pieces are discordinated not uh ideally
placed it's just a mess let's catch up
with the current game position
and he did take the bishop on A1 Rook
captured on D7 falls back with the
bishop attacking The Rook E5 on the
board uh you can't place that Queen on
those light squares that you've been
talking about Queen to F5 would be my
move of choice
but it's going to trade queen queen E4
yeah just looks looks completely winning
yeah oh my God what happened there I
think he's just uh he just cracked yeah
completely cracked I mean that's pretty
obvious as well I mean like the Pawns in
the center are just too strong I think
he was a little bit too relaxed there I
mean going into these combinations when
he didn't need to seemed like the first
mistake but the reason this is so bad is
the Queen's come off White's pawns motor
at the board is it yeah it's going to be
Armageddon and after all that could play
as well and clean up I've just felt like
the most natural the instant move that
you want to make in the position but
it's the biggest blunder you've got to
explain this to us sir David why is this
so bad you take the queen you also get
the Rook is there no way that you can
fight against these Central pawns what's
going on here yeah simply it's all about
the pawns here callous Carolina he just
didn't calculate because uh now suddenly
after the queen takes yes you take this
Rook but it's not the fact necessarily
that you take back you can step forward
first oh my God you're threatening to
promote simply threatening to run
through with the pawns forcing the Black
Knight to go back only now do you take
the bishop and uh you're coming in with
the white Rook to collect everything
Black's King as well just sidelined
unable to get back in time and uh
White's pawns forever are going to be a
bone in your throat these three
connected past Pawns in a moment
just over you're Frozen and Fabiano
doesn't dare go for this instead he
keeps the Queens on temporarily uh by
playing G6 but it feels like this Pawn
is running through I'm not sure if you
trade Queens first but this point is
running
I think he lost a bit of control before
then that was the problem and he played
he played beautiful game and uh you know
that's that's gesso it can go wrong and
uh there's a chance here you know he
could get now knocked out of the
competition we saw we see some more
moves on the board and look at those
white pawns the white pawns are just too
strong here combined with a Central Pawn
probably coming up the board as well
that's the point is there a chance that
Fabi can just uh and there we see it
Retreat the night and try to establish a
blockade on those dark squares I think
you could have gone D4 there maybe I
don't know D4 was very interesting try
this might be strong as well um but I
think yeah this is probably winning as
well but
I'm just thinking David you have to at
some point show us what was the way
forward for Fabi because it felt like he
was so close to wrapping this up uh
completely in control from the very
start and one and suddenly not about
blitzing out his moves he's feeling the
confidence he's picking up the pawns
Black's night is jammed in the position
how does he win this does he also
Advance the Deep on and connect the C
Pawn to the central
uh the central pawns that are already
down the board yeah connect them all
just push that pawn now point to D4 I
think you called it there Tanya there we
go now not only is the white king coming
in to support the pawns but you have
three connected passports CD and e-pawns
they're just going to render the black
pieces totally passive uh they're gonna
paralyze those black pieces and
I think we're going to see that white
king come in as well this one is almost
over the black king is struggling it's
got kind of one arm blocking each white
Pawn here but you can barely move as
black eight seconds of Fabi as well and
also in his mind he's just thinking
about how in control he was this is such
a difficult moment actually
and just one wolf costume the whole game
and we were just saying how impressive
he's been all day can be a cruel game
right chess I mean you can play these
are the games which are the most painful
to lose you play a perfect game you
outplay your opponent you're about to go
through and then one move it comes to
one move and your opponent just keeps
that resourcefulness alive and well here
um I you know I think I know what he
should do now I think he's come to that
point Fabiano it has you just need to
resign my friend this is hard just
resign and now the f-bond's gonna
connect but you can't go F5 just yet
he gives a check
and did you see the shift in his body
language you just leaned forward the
moment he saw Queen F5 on the board with
these guys are sharks
that's what we want to see and you can
resign now
just resign this time he's gonna be very
annoyed by that with this game I mean
this is uh these are the more painful
games when you get out played the whole
game and you lose it's not so bad
because you like that and not a back
react after that big win for Fabiano
caruana he was so close at taking this
one mistake and it was all undone which
means that we do get two armageddon's
and this was not back after his comeback
Victory against Fabiano carono he can't
believe it himself he's done it so sharp
yeah the relief on his face there he
even shook his head and uh kind of
whispered muttered something I want to
know what he said there but I think he
was praising uh the powers that be maybe
the chess guards just saying okay thank
you I survived yeah survives to play the
Armageddon What a Day of action this has
been and we got two bidding armageddans
which will be coming up for Fabi it's
going to be difficult psychologically
and on the board as well because
momentum has shifted David what was the
highlight for you in this one well it
was just that crazy transition where
Fabiano lost control he actually had a
dominant position throughout the middle
game and it was here when the white porn
started moving just as you said Tanya
the most natural move the most obvious
move in the position seems to be to
blockade these pawns Queen to F5 however
was the losing blunder If instead
Fabiano had slid across to E6 also a
light squared blockade that he most
likely would have qualified already
simply here white cannot trade Queens
white cannot quite get the pawns
motoring and uh don't forget this Rook
is attacked next move this Pawn simply
would drop so this would have given
black an advantage instead it was a full
360 swing after Queen to F5 because of
this beautiful queen trade now and if
the Queens had come off as we saw in the
game something very similar the white
pawns marching forward and this in the
end was what clinched it for another
back
an amazing comeback there in chess you
have to be precise till the very end and
this means we do go into two armageddons
let's take a look at the scoreline it
was a best of two a very different story
in both matches while Wesley and Dennis
ended with two fighting draws we had two
decisive games another back up to satro
scoring that second win and it is the
action continues in the losers bracket
we've got the bits coming in very soon
this is action you don't want to go
anywhere for we'll be right back
[Music]
enchant your pieces with one of two
spells jump or freeze the hair start
with two jump spells in five free spells
which recharge after five moves you may
cast your spare whenever you wish before
making a regular chest move jump is a
spell cast to one square wherein if
there is a piece on that square other
pieces can jump over the Charmed piece
the freeze spell is cashed over a three
by three square area and the pieces in
this area are temporarily Frozen in
place
him bang your powers of Chess and
surgery to defeat your opponent
he went supercell and chess.com have
cooked up in our new variant space
on September 1st
buckle up the 2023 speed Chess
Championship begins this Monday
September the 4th
16 of the strongest competitors in speed
chess will duke it out until only the
speech has Champion remains will Magnus
Carlson continue his winning streak and
add this title to his name will Hikaru
Nakamura defend his crown or will world
champion dingler and prove his might in
faster time controls the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
begins September 4th tune in to our
stream on YouTube or twitch as always
use exclamation point SCC and chat for
all the details
join chess kit for the highly
anticipated conclusion of the 2023 youth
speed Chess Championship September the
6th candidate Master Aaron Mendes goes
head to head with Antoni radzinski for
the crown with fun Master Mike and
Friends covering the action over at
twitch.tv forward slash chess kid use
exclamation point yscc in chat to learn
more
[Applause]
if you're in a must win situation you do
not want to face Wesley so one of the
most precise players in chess history he
makes very few mistakes and when he has
an advantage he does not let us slip out
of his grasp just ask Magnus Carlson in
the 2019 Fisher random World
Championship Wesley so dominated his
final match against Magnus Carlsen very
one-sided Affair that showcased how
strong Wesley can be when he's at his
best back towards standard chess he
plays a healthy dose of one E4 in fact
he made a chessable course over 50 hours
worth of material on the Move E4 and all
the ins and outs of the positions he
likes while Wesley so may be one of the
most precise players it does not mean
he's unafraid to take risks in this 2016
Blitz game against Netherland Gary
Kasparov Wesley he sacrificed a pawn
he's a lead in development and he played
the spry B4 move giving up another Pawn
because after C takes B4 he made his
Rook to C1 a pin along the C file and
after black developed with Knight to E7
Queen B3 the attack rage on and Wesley
won a very nice game so he is showing
that he's unafraid to enter tactical
territory if the position calls for it
[Music]
and the player who does get white in the
upcoming Armageddon will have to win on
demand to take a match we've got
exciting chess action coming up as
Wesley so takes on Dennis lazowick he is
also the cgc champion and uh so many
accolades just one of the best players
in the world currently ranked world
number eight he is the three-time U.S
Champion but he's up against the 16 year
old Dennis lazovic who isn't making life
easy for anyone in the Julius bear
generation cup it is going to be about
the bids that are coming in and David
how low can you go to try and get black
oh I'm not very good at limbo and I
don't envy these players I think that
Dennis lazovic is going to go around 8
minutes 30 that tends to be on average
what we've seen throughout the tour uh
when players are feeling brave and
really really want the black pieces
anything less than that
feel suicidal I don't think you can get
away playing against 15 minutes when you
only have seven minutes on the clock so
that would be my guess yeah beginning
the black pieces are so important as we
say in this one because they're so
they're so solid I mean Wesley we just
saw Robert there talk about his style
and he's really hard to beat and uh
Dennis he's got a rock solid repertoire
so
um I don't know eight minutes I'm going
to say eight minutes anyone wanna go
lower than eight minutes you think
that's a bit suicidal
it's not that much time there Simon I
think I would say nine and a half
minutes nine and a half okay but then
again I'm of the opinion that it's not
that bad to play with white pieces
because you know you get that extra time
you just gotta have the right strategy
is going to be all about maintaining the
tension and keeping all the pieces on
the board and I think if you do that
you'll have good chances yeah if you get
white you have to win you have to try to
flag your opponent with the time
Advantage we are waiting for the bids
but this is not the only Armageddon
there is also not a back who survived in
that second game all he needed was one
opportunity the moment he got it the
first Mistake by Fabiano caruana and not
a back one taking it to the Armageddon
take a look at what makes not a back so
powerful on the board
foreign
is a phenomenon the teenage Prodigy from
Uzbekistan had his first big
breakthrough in 2021 when he won the
world rapid championship
since then he has smashed through the
2700 barrier and even LED his country to
their first ever gold medals at an
Olympiad it is up to torah's end game
skills that truly set him apart from his
peers he has a very mature approach to
the end game as evidenced by this win
against Magnus Carlson in the 2021 World
rapid championship
in this position abdusutorov had white
he is ahead in this race whites Pawn
only being one square away from
promotion and after a careless move by
Magnus playing the pawn to B4 he didn't
get tempted he wasn't greedy he did not
capture this Pawn instead delivering a
very accurate check this immediately
provoked a mistake from Carlson the end
game is winning for white anyway but
Carlson Advanced his King to the corner
and this cross-check forcing the queen
exchange won the game for Abdul sotorov
after the Queens disappeared white is
about to make a new Queen and he went on
to win the game
one of the Front Runners of the new
generation of chess players knotted back
up to satrov what a player he's been and
his standout performance uh was the
world rapid championship and the
performance that we saw in the 22 chess
Olympiad uh for Uzbekistan winning that
gold medal he also won the chess gate
cup where he beat Fabiano caruana in the
final he was Unstoppable in that one and
right now he's managed to make a
comeback in this match uh it wasn't easy
but he's gotten here going into the
Armageddon against Fabi has the momentum
shifted in not a Beck's favor I think so
you know in order back while we saw him
leave that game with a big smile on his
face he will feel as though he's been
living a Charmed life because there he
asked for a miracle and it was delivered
and I also think that Fabi will be
seriously tilted after that because he
was doing everything right and then one
big blunder and
he's in an Armageddon everything has
been reset that was brutal what's it
like do you think the players watched
this reaction and if Fabi actually saw
that little Celebration by not a bad
does that play on your mind I think he
was in too much pain to notice it right
I mean uh but it yeah I mean it will
play on your mind I mean I've had times
when I've lost the game and uh um my
opponent's girlfriend has come up and
given them a big kiss and started
celebrating and I I wasn't happy because
I was like no you know you're already
losing you're really in a bit of pain
and they start celebrating in front of
you and it's like oh come on just give
it half an hour please but um but yeah I
mean Fabiano's had a very strange
tournament I think because
um he's been up and down quite a lot and
uh this will be very interesting to see
if it's going to affect him now or not
that's gonna be a big Armageddon but
also the other one 16 year old dunlas he
took world number two Fabiano caruana to
an Armageddon and now he takes world
number eight Wesley to uh down to the
wire and uh as we wait for the beds we
know just how strong Dennis is his chest
com rating in Blitz over 3000 and we've
got the bids in and you guys were just
about right Dennis lazawig at nine
minutes he does lose the bit to Wesley
at eight minutes 29 seconds Wesley will
start with the black pieces Dennis gets
white with the base time of 15 minutes
but that would mean score odds uh White
has to win on demand black needs just to
draw we're also getting the bids for not
the back and Fabiano caruana let's take
a look and not a backup to such a really
wanting the white pieces David I don't
think we've ever seen a 14 minute 59
seconds bid before wow did we see one
yesterday we saw uh
let's see that bid
his reaction looking at notific's bit
when he realized that he's pretty much
just gambled his time away
Mind Games both players smiling there
and uh I think he's pretty confident
he'd win that bid uh nodded back Fabiano
may be kicking himself no he could have
been a bit higher there he could have uh
before teen minutes and got away with it
30 and a half minutes
Mind Games mind games and that's what
I'm gonna
oh my God 59 seconds and now for Fabi
the clocks are going to get adjusted uh
for Fabi he's got the draw odds NADA
back has to win not too big has to win
and so far it's a repeat of that
previous opening from that last game but
remember it did end at least the opening
phase favorably for Fabiano and this
time it's a slightly different spin on
that opening here we see the central
tension released in a different way a
bit earlier than previously and already
the knights looking at each other uh
Fabiano he's going to be itching
withdraw odds to trade-off pieces to get
to safety no more of that kind of cagey
tension-filled middle game maneuvering I
think he just wants uh quick
simplifications and head towards an end
game but what do we think of this
nudibek repeating and opening that
backfired last time despite the result
he has changed the approach though you
know as you mentioned and now the center
is pretty much open and I'm wondering
whether white will actually try to
initiate some operations there and this
was the moment I was thinking just push
the Deep pawn and
yeah I mean white is slightly better
there's no denying that but then again
black is really solid and well my advice
was not followed I wanted both sides to
kind of maintain the tension keep all
the pieces on the board and here it
looks like things could get simplified
be happy for both sides here still some
Central tension for Abdul sotorov so
maybe slightly easier Pawn structure to
play with with white less responsibility
in the center but then again Fabiano
he's got a set of pieces off the board
and uh yeah he's still solid I see
defeated chat not about crazy crazy or
genius
okay we'll find out but it was pretty
clear that he really wanted the white
pieces for this one uh 14 minutes 59
seconds that's a bit that we haven't
seen in the Champions chest star and uh
I mean I'm not surprised you wanted to
have white after that first game where
he lost in 19 moves it was like you know
he's probably like what on Earth do I do
you know I can't do anything against
Fabby so
um but I think it's a wise choice I
think he's got quite a decent position
here uh the tension's there I mean I I I
don't think White's got a big Advantage
but maybe it's easier for white to play
because uh at some point white can
exchange pawns and place pressure on
Black's Pawn on D5 but if black ever
exchanged pawns you get this typical
isolated Pawn position uh so it's
basically there we go great move and um
yeah naughty back it worked so well last
time didn't it he won the game with this
move I don't know what everyone was
saying it's a bad move in the last game
but I think the other idea is to tuck
the king to H2 and threaten Bishop H3
winning the exchange and just get in a
bit of space here but you know it's a
it's probably like as you say David both
sides should be quite happy the way this
has gone so far they've uh Black's
pretty solid but white there he goes
takes this Pawn opens things up now
while the match between these two have
been has been a roller coaster one the
other matchup which was pretty which was
peaceful with the two fighting draws is
also ready to start and we see Dennis
lazovic gets the white pieces this one
was a lot closer in beds nine minutes
was Daniel to eight minute 29 seconds
and another a repeat of the Queen's
Gambit accepted with this one a switch
up now yeah slight switch up here in the
move order from Wesley so uh of course
Black's move in the previous game Pawn
to A6 is the main line uh he just wants
Dennis last week to burn a bit of his
clock time thinking and I should mention
there were some Mind Games in this
bidding war as well yesterday in his uh
Armageddon Dennis lazovic bid around 9
Minutes 30. uh Wesley so might have seen
that he would think okay Dennis might be
brave enough to go even slightly lower
so he outbid him uh he kind of banked it
by going just under 8 minutes 30 and uh
this one is going to be an even faster
race on the clock remember Dennis
lazovic is a bullet machine Blitz
machine and uh Wesley really needs to
get a safe position before it gets down
to that time scramble
I do you know what I'd really like to
see when it comes to the bids I love to
see Magnus say I'll take one minute
I can see him doing that you know he's
playing like I don't know like I'll just
take one minute all I need is one minute
in the thing and just you know crack on
with one minute I think that'd be quite
funny for some weird reason but probably
won't happen but yeah so
David was saying that uh the lowest
someone has gone or was three minutes
three minutes it's free and I think
there have been some uh Mix-Ups
throughout the tour this season uh
Jordan van first I think bit around
three minutes and then chose the white
pieces the Arbiters were like are you
sure he was like yeah I'll take the
white pieces and it backfired there was
also a maxim matlokov who I think was in
a rush that day and um yeah he didn't do
so well in the arm again let's just say
took 30 seconds quite 30 seconds but uh
there has been a lot of drama with his
arm against meanwhile look at the pawn
structure completely symmetrical this
time uh all the pieces on the board
which I think will suit Dennis Las Vegas
in his bid uh to try and win this game
but yeah still going to be an uphill
struggle against someone as solid and uh
yeah sensible as Wesley so symmetrical
Bond structure a Tempo winning move to
develop the pieces by Dennis lazovic
gets the bishop on the long diagonal you
mentioned that Wesley saw here with some
Mind Games David of being able to
predict Dennis's time bid we've seen
Magnus do that as well in the tour where
he won uh the bid against Hikaru
Nakamura in just one second and that
really does pay off do you think this
older generation the more experienced
generation has that ability better to be
able to do that I think so the older
generation as well remember they've been
Professionals for years and years at
this point and they do their homework
even if they deny it a lot of top
players they pretend they're just kind
of cool and they just freestyle but it's
all part of the process they've looked
at the Armageddon bids they've studied
what the opponents have bid before and
uh they know roughly uh what they should
be aiming for that's why it's so close I
think the youngsters they're just super
confident they believe they'll win with
white black with one minute on the clock
with 15 minutes on the clock
um and yeah I think that's maybe just a
part of the game that of course doesn't
decide it it's all settled on the board
but it's definitely a factor and while
this one is a symmetrical position we
will come back to this let's check in
with Fabi versus not about wow David so
much has happened what is going on here
yeah this one is crazy let's just do a
quick count white is up a rook for night
it's the exchange and wow it's two
exchanges now it's two Rooks for Bishop
and Knight and uh as long as white
doesn't get checkmated on the light
squares of distorted should win this and
white has to win if Abdul satra wins he
it's it's tournament over for uh Fabiano
caruana how did all this go so wrong
should we do a quick action replay what
happened here David I think we might
have to and uh this position is crazy
we'll update you on what's Happening
Here but let's just backtrack it was
around this moment when things started
to get crazy I thought Fabiano was doing
very well a night now Landing in the
white heart of the position attacking
this Rook but suddenly The Rook stepped
up and it was here a big mistake from
Fabiano it looks very sensible to Anchor
this night but he had maybe forgotten
that after the Knight jumps forward to
D4 hitting the black queen suddenly
white gains a very important Tempo the
queen has to sidestep and after a trade
another trade of Pawns this was the if
he had missed Knight to C6 further down
the line I think six moves from that
start point of the blunder but this is a
simple fork and he had to part with
material one set of Rooks and minor
pieces were traded there and as we saw a
bit later on he had to go all in he had
to remove this bishop and this is the
current position let's catch up with it
essentially Black's only idea was to
drop the bishop back and try and
Checkmate on this diagonal so fabi's
last move uh sorry abdusatoro's last
move might be a real Heartbreaker for
Fabiano pushing the pawn to F3 means the
white king is safe behind a wall of
Pawns
yeah I think fappy's going for the hyper
hyper modern approach that bishop and
knights are better than Rooks here and
they're not the Rooks are better and
white can always uh he even sacrifice
um one of the Rooks for that night at
the right time uh but I think you know
there's going to be a threat with a back
rank as well the White Queen can step
forwards I mean all in all this position
is is just losing losing for black and
uh I think it was maybe that last game
right yeah I think it is definitely that
last game that has just uh tilted Fabby
but I mean okay Fabi just has to play
what is on the board and I think he's
making some Right Moves here he's just
trying to hustle as opponent I love his
last move getting ready to perhaps push
that pawn one square forward at least
concern the white king
but I agree with you both ultimately
he's just lost yeah objectively we know
that should be the result a win for
white here but yeah he just has to
somehow hustle said a trap here Fabiano
I like what nordebec's doing just kind
of taking it really slow and safe just
securing his King first before deciding
on any action if Clocks Were level I
would say there's some chances but it's
not gonna be easy
clearly Topsy though
to start to finish so an attacking
display he wins that game second game he
makes a comeback uh not a bad mix to
come back and now makes it look easy in
the Armageddon do you think this has
been a combination of that loss in the
second game and the Armageddon bid that
we just saw the Mind Games of it
yeah yeah I think it's mainly that lost
I don't think the Armageddon bid would
have done anything other than cause
furry some laughter but um yeah totally
that loss has really affected him and it
just caused his concentration to slip up
in those critical moments and uh well
Fabi mustn't lose too much hope though
because if he manages to hold this it is
a bit of an uphill task but you never
know we've seen stranger things on the
tour well he just has to shake off those
ghosts and uh play he has a bishop for
and a pawn for The Rook maybe there's
still some chances does black want to
keep the Queens on the board or trade
Queens here oh it's difficult if you
could somehow trade queens and not lose
a Pawn on the king side and somehow
maybe push that black F Pawn back to it
starts
then maybe some drawing chances but I
think the main question the main dilemma
here for Fabiano is you can't keep the
Queens on otherwise the black king is
about to get checked and you might lose
a pawn in the process anyway
uh so it's just kind of everything
building up in the end a rook versus a
bishop with pawns on both sides of the
board The Rook will always come out on
top
especially with an extra Pawn on one of
the flanks I think this last move if
Fabiano had time to stop it maybe some
drawing chances but this last move might
be the Killer and look at the clocks as
well not gonna be easy
might just get flagged
yeah I mean uh and also this this last
movie is quite brave from nordie Becker
I think it's worth pointing out because
you do expose your own King a little bit
I mean uh there are much safer ways to
play but again this this does sort of
emphasize naughty Beck's style he he
calculates really well and he and he
doesn't really blunder and that's been
the difference in this match hasn't it
that uh Fabiano's maybe showing a better
quality of Chess but he's actually
blundered more he blundered in the last
game and uh he blundered in this game as
well and that's what it is at the end of
day chess if you don't blunder you'll be
a grand master but um everyone and you
know everyone blunders pretty much so is
that right is that right saying if you
don't blunder do you think anyone could
be a grand master be a world champion
yeah so all you have to do in chess is
not make any mistakes simple easy yeah
so you don't even have to try to do good
moves just don't blunder but okay what
happens if you could not make any big
blunders but you're allowed to make
small mistakes do you think you could be
a Grandmaster
um it depends how big like you know I
as long as you don't make any bad moves
but small mistakes are kind of okay it's
a weird conversation isn't it now I I
did I did speak to Olf Anderson who who
was a legend of the 70s and he had a
very he was one of the best players in
the world and what White's winning this
now I think quite easily we can see that
make it look easy and fast as well see
the king and Rook are coming in I'm
going to go F6 yeah
isn't there a drawing scenario so for
instance if the port left porn were gone
you take the F upon first now that the
bishop isn't if you lose your Rook it
might be a draw
remember I yeah I was actually thinking
there might be some hope if you managed
to win the f porn impossible but um no
this and leave the H Pawn
that's isn't that yeah really trying to
find drawers aren't we yeah because if
White's porn was on the H file uh and if
White's Pawn was too far Advanced then
it would maybe be a draw but with an F
Pawn it's going to be hard to stop it
does promote on a dark Square you won't
be able to blockade forever white can
combine checkmating attacks with the
advance of this pawn it will cost the
black Bishop gotta feel for family right
now but it's so close especially that
second game and this armaged and just
everything went wrong and F6 on the
board he's touching the two and a half
minute mark
you're just gonna end up with an extra
Rook because at some point black will
have to sacrifice the bishop for the F
Bond and I think Bobby is preparing
himself he's resigned
it is much over and tournament over for
Fabiano caruana as nordeback makes a
huge comeback and goes through what a
match that has been an action still
continues in this one Dennis lazowick
with the white pieces and more active
pieces yeah it's level material but
white does have this very far Advanced
past B Pawn as well so if white is uh
accurate here maybe before the black
king is able to get off the background
before that black Rook on AJ in the
corner is able to activate maybe you can
create some threats and chances but it's
very much time of the essence here you
need to be quick if the black king moves
uh then I think Wesley will be safe so
okay he attacks this Black Knight how is
Wesley gonna react is he gonna move it
or does he just leave it I think you
might have to run I don't think you can
go down a pawn here and save the game if
you're Wesley so
to be really really careful Advantage
white for sure and you also need to move
the knights to a square where it covers
D7 because if white is allowed to line
up the two Rooks on the seventh row it's
going to be game over for Wesley
yeah game over for Wesley and uh four
minutes 30. it's not gonna be easy to
find a defense here despite the reduced
material it's kind of like walking a
tightrope you need to kind of find three
or four really really accurate moves
just to stay in this one and even then
you're facing a disadvantage oh wow he
gives up a pawn this Knight is going to
be captured in the center now he's going
to seek solace in a rook end game which
has notably drawish Tendencies this
bishop will be captured and okay it's
three versus three on the king side but
all about that white past B Pawn if the
white king ever activates I fear for
Wesley's chances
oh Wesley needs only a draw so he has to
just try and hold on to this position uh
white skin as you said is a little far
away there are still chances to be able
to get that draw and with the clocks
leveling up it's not gonna be easy for
Dennis to create his activity either
not easy but still black has to try and
find something active to do at the
moment the two black Rooks are passive
yes you have a pass H Pawn that might be
the one Saving Grace later on and wow a
rook exchange that costs Wesley some
time on the clock a huge decision I'm
wondering what happens now if you trade
Rooks and then the white Rook drops back
the white Rook on the a file drops the
whole way back and zooms behind the
white past people oh that is a nice move
because the Rooks want to be behind the
pawns and uh dropping it all the way
back as Dave has indicate it also
prevents the black Rook from chucking
the white king
I think that would work really well if
white didn't have double pawns but I
think the fact that Black's got a past H
Pawn gives him actually quite good
compensation in some of those endings
it's a little bit different we might see
it anyway and this this is happening
this is the standard way of trying to
win this but maybe black has some
Chances with this H Pawn because if a
white Pawn was over on the G file white
would easily be winning this but the
problem is he a lot of endings now that
H Pawn will will be very good for black
so I'm not convinced that this is
winning actually it's a race the white
King's got to run as far forward up the
board as possible by the time the black
king moves over uh to eliminate that
white B Pawn ah I mean the players are
calculating this fastly and furiously
right now but yeah Dennis Levick he
needs to hope that this is objectively
winning if it is a draw uh with perfect
play Then Wesley will find the best
moves black has a really kind of
straightforward plan now of running
there we go the black kings making his
move like you say Simon white wants us
to get his own King into attacking black
spawn so you won't really be able to
recapture the queen Side Pawn that white
has uh because white skin is going to
get Super Active as well King G4 King G5
yeah I mean you can always play H6 to
stop the king coming in but even if the
king comes up to I mean H5 black can
always go H5 and the problem is white
can't really exchange Rooks here and
normally in these endings white would
love to exchange Brooks because the
black king is so far away but with this
H Pawn I I think black black has very
good chances to hold
um we're gonna see Dennis's end game
technique I mean 15 years old he's gonna
have to play very well to win this it's
going to be extremely exciting finish
can maybe you should slow down a bit
though he's got six minutes I mean maybe
maybe these decisions he needs to think
about them a little bit here right but I
mean it does feel like what he has to do
is uh start prodding black on the king
side you know just maybe create a path
for the white king to get through so I
move I'm thinking of of f4 F5 I like it
a lot yeah I think you have to try and
make your king you know come into the
position somehow and also F4 F5
um if yeah will take away that that H
Pawn the strength of the H Pawn here
because uh maybe you can even play a
five in this position potentially
um with the threat taking on G6 just to
show F5 I mean it's a pawn end game that
you have to calculate here and I don't
think you're quick enough but maybe the
key factor is uh in this position you
can kind of switch attention uh kind of
towards the black king side pawns and uh
in a position like this unfortunately
for black you're a bit stuck you cannot
take this Pawn uh we're seeing something
very similar about to happen but you can
never take this Pawn because now
um I guess in this end game well I was
gonna say maybe you can give a check but
no you can just bring your Rook up the
board and well the engine thinks this is
winning this is hard to calculate two
versus two in terms of Pawns yeah this
is actually much more difficult for a
human uh yeah armed with the evaluation
bar we know that that's winning but
lazovic he has to do the same push the
pawns and I don't know what Wesley so is
doing with his King he's dropped back in
no man's land now
yeah strange and um is he just trying to
blockade the position I mean I the the
way you'd like to try and draw this is
black is to try and clarify as quickly
as possible so you'd want to take the
pawn on B5 but hang on a minute White's
now going to get a past E Pawn and if
white can get that past E Pawn so the
black king ever moves the E Pawn pushes
forwards that must be winning for white
uh you know because he's already got one
pass pawn two pass pawns will be too
strong this is also another way you can
do it the other Pawn can become past
porn as well I mean this is yeah this is
some fantastic technique by uh Dennis
and he's also up on the clock let's
remind everyone there is no increment
and the plan that you're talking about
is you get rid of the double bond push
the other F Pawn create another passer
but this is a matter of time I mean the
evaluation bar it says it's winning for
white but I think if you're inaccurate
just for one move it's gonna drop the
whole way back to equality okay he does
push this pawn and allows the black king
in so you still have to be very very
careful here basically shaking his head
there I think Wesley really sizes he's
really struggling here and let's
remember how important this match is
it's so important because if Wesley wins
he is guaranteed a place in um the the
Grand Final
um but also the only person who maybe
has a good chance to catching I believe
is Dennis
um so it's it's really close and Wesley
won't be guaranteed a place to fight in
the play
why did he go back the white King's so
passive you've doubled up your own pawns
this makes no sense at all I mean yeah I
guess he's banking of the king coming to
the H file but that that was a really
strange Choice there uh from from Dennis
it's so close this one
I think he's moving a little bit quickly
he has these really big decisions to
make and he does have three four minutes
just take 30 seconds to try and work
them out and David you you mentioned
there and uh so did you give anchored it
he might have just missed a great
opportunity to to win the game outright
easily still with some winning chances
for Dennis lasvik in this uh must win
situation but as Ivanka says he could
have knocked out Wesley so on the spot
by pushing forward to this EPO and
Ivanka and uh if you trade pawns here
the white King's simply going to guide
the e-pawn forward and uh maybe the
finesse that he'd missed is that if this
Pawn is captured where I can simply give
a check with the Rook kicking this King
away if it continues trying to defend
his Pawn you continue checking and uh
sooner or later you simply make a new
passport that's going to run through and
win the game instead he's gonna have to
battle now it's not easy because the
white king is caught trying to prevent
the H porn but also trying to Shield
blockade the blacking from moving
towards the white pawns and suddenly the
B Pawn is dropping
this might just fizzle out towards a
draw now
doesn't take it because the King Pawn
ending is perhaps lost so you could not
have grabbed the B5 Pawn
white at some point has to try to get to
the h checkpoint to win the game do you
have enough time to go over with your
king king G3 King H4 well the problem is
that the black king is really active as
well and if you win the H Pawn I'm sure
black is gonna munch on the F5 Pawn so
oh King coming on to E4 but I think you
have to push the king away and start
marching with your own King maybe this
is the way foreign
oh he's gambling now that his two pawns
are gonna beat the soul black pawn but
you can't create a passport and that's
the problem basically two double pawns
are the same as one here Black's King as
long as it gets back safe to safety
should hold this Fortress should be a
draw oh I'm just oh actually now Dennis
has got less time on the clock
the white king can come in now maybe oh
my God
could have kept his Rook on the fifth
rank it was stopping the white king
advancing Wesley so panicking due to the
clock situation but two minutes each and
we saw Fabiano lose like this yesterday
as well right so it's a similar similar
way
and in game two right with Queen F5 one
blunder and the whole game is out of
hand and now there's gonna be a bridge
The Rook comes to G7 you challenge the
black rook and then your king is
crossing over to attack the F6 Pawn yeah
it looks like it's suddenly winning
black cannot improve his position white
can meanwhile and uh Simple Plan as you
say Tanya the white king will eventually
cross over it's not going to be cut off
forever and all Wesley had to do was
keep the Rook where it was just making
sure that White's King is tied down to
defending that F5 Pawn Yeah I think he
got too carried away trying to stop his
black F Pawn from dropping but actually
the white Rook going to win that pawn
wouldn't have been the worst thing the
black king just needed to get back in
front of the white pawns now look it's
going the wrong way it's going uh kind
of behind the white pawns but it's not
going to stop the pawns running uh in a
moment so yeah I'm expecting that move
the offer of The Rook trade and that
should allow the white king to cross
into the promised land the g-file okay
first just delaying the decision
Dennis he's so experienced the Blitz and
bullet he's unmasked out a 30 second
time advantage and every move you make
it forces Wesley to think which means
less time on Wesley's clock and Rook G7
is always coming so there's nothing that
you've done wrong in your position and I
won't be surprised if you see Rook G7
now with no black king moving forward
yeah I wonder if checking and taking the
pawn what he's going for the more greedy
approach the same idea Rook G6 and you
put your King on G7 I think this is uh
probably a simple win actually because
then you know you just push the F1
simple as that and uh the black king is
in a very bad situation it needs to be
on the other side of the Rook to try and
draw this I think but or in front of the
pawn but he can't really get there Rook
G6 coming yeah it's unlucky for black if
you're Rook now was anywhere else on the
first rank I think the black king could
have made its way across and blockaded
the white pawns with the drawer but
unfortunately your idea there Simon and
we might see what is well known as the
Lucina position if Black's Rook had
taken that pawn on F4 the white king
would have crossed over and that's a
well-known win uh this one is just
straightforward now yeah really nice
technique there of just cupping off
black skin to coming into defend that f8
square wow what a turnaround this has
been
that's that was absolutely crazy and uh
you know Wesley now has to fight for his
place in the Grand Final and uh it was a
up and down game and that's it Wesley
resigns Dennis lazowick takes down
Wesley so Wesley is out of the
tournament Dennis advances forward to
play not the back up to satro of the 16
year old the youngest player in the
Champions chess store ever has in
division one has done what was a tough
task taken down world number eight what
two incredible armageddon's there David
a lot to choose from what was the big
highlight a lot to choose from but in
the end it was the Battle of the
generations and the two younger players
did progress I'm just going to highlight
in that end game though how Wesley so
could have drawn if he had a bit more
time in the clock he would surely have
found this the key here was to do
nothing to wait if the black record just
stayed on the fifth rank tying the white
king down to the defense of this pawn it
should have ended in a draw the white
Rook can actually get greedy now and
Gobble up Black's Pawn but the key here
is not that you've lost two Pawn these
two points after all are doubled it's
more that you need the black king in
front when the white Rook moves you can
blockade and there's no way to break
through with these pawns this would have
ended in a well-known draw instead he
allowed the white king to snake its way
around and lazovic took the win
you've got to read up those dwaretsky
manual those dwaretsky and games this
was just unbelievable but for Wesley a
player like Wesley we'd expect him uh to
hold on to that one bit this is what
happens in high pressure situations
which means that it is the end of the
road for Wesley saw and Fabiano caruana
while tennis will play against not a bag
after the big comeback that notabeck had
in his match and we are being joined by
notabec Abdul satrov after his win not
the back congratulations
thank you
you pulled off a crazy comeback there
how are you feeling right now oh I'm
feeling great
um yeah it was
uh it was tough of course
um I played incredibly bad today I think
is it like quality of my play was so far
from like
uh from optimal but
yeah I at the end I somehow pulled off
the win and yeah I'm I was
that's why I was emotional after after I
came back in the game too yeah we can
imagine because you were under so much
pressure was there a moment that you
felt that the match was over for you
yeah I mean
in game two you know he had a like
numerous options to
uh to repeat I think uh like Bishop E3
Bishop D4 even was a was looking good
um yeah I mean it was in the game too I
was I was just lucky yeah
uh yeah it was extremely I was extremely
close to be eliminated
yeah but not about you make your own
luck on the chessboard and you were
resilient and one mistake and it was
just awesome to watch your confidence
and your speed after that I want to ask
you what happened in that and we have a
reaction that you had after winning that
uh comeback game I want to ask you about
your Armageddon bid it's a bit that
we've never seen before in the Champions
gestal 14 minutes and 59 seconds what
was your thought process there
uh
I just desperately wanted to
wanted to
um I I I I I thought that
uh you know the only chance I have is to
just play with white and uh get some
um some kind of position where I can
play it slowly and
uh you know uh playing for his time
obviously and uh
uh yeah obviously I got a very pleasant
position I think after the opening
uh this that was ideal position that I
wanted
um yeah I mean yeah it was a bit strange
to beat 1459 because
even if he if if he would bid like 1458
he would play with black I guess
so yeah but but I was sure like he would
be
uh you know somewhere between 10 and 9
so yeah it was it was really fun
congratulations tomorrow you're facing
someone else who also won in the
Armageddon Dennis lazovic what are your
thoughts on that matchup
yeah you look very impressive
um
yeah I think I played in one of in
division two of the one of the
tournaments
uh yeah it was extremely tough match and
I pulled off a win in Armageddon yeah
but it was extremely tough
yeah I'm looking forward to playing him
tomorrow so yeah let's see how it goes
awesome come
out of back congratulations and before
you go you got a big Winners final
coming up with Magnus taking on alireza
and we'd love to get your thoughts on it
how do you think that one's going to
play out
um you know
I you know when I played alireza he
played like extremely strong I I just
felt immediately that he is in a very
good shape
and uh
I think it will be extremely tough match
for both players but I would uh
uh I would say alireza will give a tough
match maybe even a good beat Magnus
it's going to be a big fight and we're
looking forward to that one another back
we do have a viewer question coming in
for you so just before you go and it's
by Mr Toto young and he's asking what
inspiration and influences do you have
uh that have inspired your play
um you know I have
I have read many chess books like I've
read uh
[Music]
when I was a kid I read uh Gary
casparov's book
which uh you know where I got this uh
extremely
uh you know I was extremely inspired by
his uh you know life lifestyle
and uh
yeah
I got a lot of things you know reading
these books and I think it's very
helpful
uh in early stages especially to uh to
be uh you know to improve on chess and
um yeah and just to get a
uh to get to know better uh how chess
history has developed
if you had to recommend one book to the
young younger generation it would be
oh I think one of the Garrick is part of
books like migrate
producers or or My
uh like I I have reached the Russian one
but I think in English it's called My
um I don't know how to um
my great predecessors uh thank you so
much not the back that is some great
advice and great performance today as
well and we really are excited about
your mat up tomorrow get some rest
thank you
of uh what a comeback that was uh but of
course the action
continues as we've got a big Winners
final coming up and uh we will be back
with all the action get the popcorn
ready you don't want to miss it
[Music]
well number one Magnus Carlsen will be
taking on alireza feruja in the winners
final it is a clash of generations it's
you to Us's experience it is the one
player that Magnus wanted to face and
was motivated to fight in the world a
championship match and this rivalry
exploded back in 2019.
the Iranian Aldi reservaruja faced off
against the Norwegian World chess
champion of Magnus Carlson affidi World
rapid and Blitz Chess Championship in
mosquebot 2019 after the check here and
the queen captures the pawn it was this
moment right here and the words
whispered by Magnus that ultimately led
to the controversy and the challenge
Carlson correctly transitions into an
obstacode Bishop Affair where you often
have your best drawing chances but right
here right now the move Bishop D2
pointed out as a blunder by some I think
was actually Carlson really calling the
kids Bluff but now in the time scramble
we're going to see that Carlson block
hitting the dark squares and there it is
it's leading to the nerves that comes
out and after King G4 we see the drama
is real the table is slammed and the
Arbiter has set up the pieces wait for
it in a draw according to the dgt board
and we see Magnus Carlson is actually
not happy about that Carlson knew very
well that if this game led to a loss on
time for Borussia that he wins in that
call just because there's opposite code
Bishops on the board and no other mating
material does not mean that according to
the feed a bylaws black isn't winning in
fact he's right what you'll find out
later on in the news report was that the
fide ruling says as long as there's in
theory a possible Checkmate then the
game can be deemed a win despite not
having what is considered theoretical
mating material what exactly was the
chess moment the deeply frustrated
Borussia that moment we saw earlier at
about the 10 minute and 31 second Mark
where Magnus Carlson I don't think was
whispering sweet nothings to farrugia in
terms of his frustration with the
position it was this combination that
picks up the B7 pawn and ultimately the
C5 Pawn this moment that had Magnus very
frustrated and and saying whatever it
was he did that was later of course
appealed to and overruled as if it is
the case that your opponent is
distracting you which is what furuja
tried to claim he should have made that
claim in the moment but either way if
you're frustrated about something you're
is doing you have to claim it in the
moment which of course farusha did not
Sunny Ranch they're breaking down all
the drama that happened in the world uh
Blitz championship and that's really
when uh the big rivalry between Magnus
Carlson and alireza ferruja started some
dramatic moments in that Blitz uh a game
that ferrugia was winning and eventually
would have been a draw and in fact David
if it was online just the game would
have been automatically stopped that's
right uh on chess.com even if you run
out of material if your opponent only
has a bishop all night left it would be
a draw so that's where the
misunderstanding I guess evolved from
yeah not the friendliest of starts to
their rivalry but uh in the kind of
years since they've had some Mammoth
clashes I remember the banter Blitz cup
where farouj actually triumphed over
Magnus Carlson over the years yeah uh
he's definitely emerged as one of the
big rivals and I was right after this we
had this crazy moment in the world
Bloods championship and then the banter
Blitz cup which Perugia won motivating
Magnus to get a Revenge which he did in
the Magnus Invitational and it's been
going back and forth foreign
is ready to go and he is ready to start
this big Winner's final he did sound
extremely tired and fatigued yesterday
maybe a bit of lack of motivation is
what I felt but for this man right here
who hasn't booked a spot yet in the
Toronto finals motivation is not going
to be a problem uh Ivanka what do you
think is the reason that Magnus singled
alireza art is the only opponent he
wanted to defend his title against Well
normally when these two play each other
it's chaos on the board both sides have
to bring their tactical a game and
Magnus he relishes the challenge so I
think that's why he wanted to play
alireza alirez is a player who doesn't
necessarily respect him that much and
that we see both players
they are ready Magnus getting in the
zone and alireza well he's just too
eager with anticipation I would love to
see this going down to Armageddon what
are the chances of us getting an
Armageddon in this one well they're both
just in such Stellar form
it's hard to choose between them right
now farouza is a fighter that's why
Magnus kind of respects him so much and
yeah the games are always close no
matter the result and uh yeah I have a
feeling something dramatic is going to
happen along the way I
I think farrugia might need to get their
first hit in against Magnus Carlton if
he strikes first we'll see a crazy match
if Magnus strikes first we might see
Magnus trying to shut down the rest of
the game so
um yeah either way it's going to be
dramatic Simon certainly is yeah I'm
very excited about this one I'm sure
lots of people out there are as well I
mean these guys have played so much
online as well they've had many many uh
Blitz bullet games and uh now they're
playing a bit of a longer time limit as
well I'd be interested to see what kind
of action we're going to get and one
thing that really excites for Tanya is
that I've seen quite a lot of drawish
stuff so far today I don't think it's
going to be drawish Berlin so I think
we're gonna have some real attacking
chess I want to see some more hacking
and tacking I we're gonna get that with
these two because uh farugia is such an
exciting player how did you say it what
was it boom boom bang test yes exactly
that's the kind that we want right now
and
the bullet Chess Championship as well on
chess.com there was so much back and
forth with beruja the beating Magnus in
the semi-finals and then from the losers
bracket Magnus beating ferrugia so
there's definitely a lot of rivalry here
a fun matchup as we wait for the first
moves by Magnus what are we expecting
I'm expecting a night off Sicilian with
white playing Rook to G1 uh very early
on wow I have had a hint I think
what a legend Rook G1 how did you
predict that it's uh crystal ball I've
borrowed ivanka's uh well deals of
Prophecy there David it's actually been
uh preparing Magnus Carson all morning
just in case you're wondering uh was
that a mouse slip at H5 this is bizarre
this is now a very rare brunch of the
Sicilian both players already showing
their aggressive intentions here Magnus
whenever he opens one E4 with white
whenever he goes into the open Sicilian
it means he's spoiling for a fight he
really backs himself feeling confident
farouza meanwhile just the fact he's
employing this opening with black kind
of inviting an attack uh shows that he's
also scrapping for a fight and this
whole variation with White's Rook
shuffling to G1 as you mentioned Simon
it's not a mouse slip unfortunately uh
it is a kind of a signal that white
wants to throw pawns forward on the king
side and that's been prevented uh black
pushing H5 but yeah it's just gonna this
guy is going to light up very shortly
this opening just feels like Ivanka you
take every single traditional chest
wisdom that we know about opening player
and just Chuck it out of the window oh
you're not castling anymore you don't
care about your development Black's gone
ahead with the h-bond White Once the
threatened G4 what is going on here with
the shift that we're seeing and the kind
of openings we see from these youngsters
well it's super concrete stuff it's all
very much based on moves and there's no
like big picture thinking here no no no
both sides are gonna extract as much as
possible in the most unconventional way
I have to say uh out of the opening and
I have to say this is a really risky
approach from both sides because you
know if it backfires it's gonna backfire
terribly like in a lot more classical
openings you know you make a small
mistake that's fine you know life
continues you may be slightly worse
maybe much worse but here the price of a
mistake is Big yeah and White's given up
all rights to go castling on the right
side the black also looks like with H5
it's going to be super risky to go
kingside casting are we expecting the
Kings to stay in the center of the board
in this game I don't think so no I mean
uh it's kind of like a normal position a
set White's got a rook on G1 and Black's
got a Pawn on H5 so if we think
logically
um who this kind of uh should uh benefit
I I think that will sort of get a bit
nearer to the true for the position I
was going to recommend this move because
with the move H5 from black it seems
like blacks light squares a little bit
more weakened there like G6 and uh this
move is a super aggressive move all of
White's pieces have got the most
aggressive squares they can get to and
to answer your original question Tanya I
expect white will Castle Queen side
there's actually a variation in a night
off where you do this line which I play
but with the Rook on H1 with the pawn on
H7 and I think Queen E2 is is a normal
Square to put it you can even go F4
Queen F3 in this kind of structure I
really hope we see that because that'll
be the most aggressive moves on the
board and uh black will wait for his
counter chance and this move is a bit
close to my heart as well so this is
what I call the dragon door off it's a
mix between the dragon opening and the
night off so we're getting some really
funky stuff and Magnus used to play this
opening as black as well but then he
lost some horrible games and gave it up
but really interesting stuff yeah
fascinating stuff Magnus is declaring
his intentions to Castle on the queen
side next move and uh just to explain
the dragged off it is that uh dragon uh
kind of fiancato formation in Sicilian
and the night off which is kind of
signaled by A6 so kind of a mishmash of
two different very well respected
openings but if often combining openings
uh isn't the most consistent way to play
and Magnus now is not going to hesitate
surely he's going to Castle on the long
side there we go and watch out if you're
far Asia for these pawns just kind of
storm forward now it's a matter of time
black is really severely lacking in
development now uh all of White's pieces
ready maybe apart from this white rook
and G1 but
um yeah it's gonna be fire just in the
next few moves
Magnus employed this Rook G1 ideas in
the night off is this something that
alireza perhaps had bad because the move
H5 you kind of don't commit it unless
you've got some prep in mind
yeah no I agree I mean uh Rook G1 is is
a move that Ali Razer will be aware of
uh it has been around the most one of
the really popular move there uh instead
of Rook G1 was actually H3 with the same
idea of playing G4 so it's very very
similar to that except a little bit more
committal and um
um I mean I think this is why Magnus was
so excited about this match because he
knew they were going to get positions
like this and positions like this to me
are just so much fun to see and play
pieces on the board both sides trying to
attack white getting his pieces of good
squares but black ready on the queen
side to throw the B Pawn forward this is
this is like the chess I love I love
this kind of Chess and yeah looking
forward to this one
um I have to say though my experience in
these positions is that the bishop on C4
is very annoying for black in these
Dragon dwarf kind of structures here so
Black's got to be more careful in this
kind of position
yeah I just love watching for Asia play
choosing these uh really provocative
openings uh but he has to back it up now
with some accuracy Magnus is certainly
ready to start attacking uh and I think
it's a good moment to pause as well
really instructive uh this Young
Generation they're so good at kind of
stopping at critical moments and uh
realizing okay the stakes are high now
price of an error is uh yeah
unfathomable and uh yeah he needs to
find an active defense yeah I've
actually had a position very similar to
this except the Brooks on H1 and The
Bishop's on E3 and a pawn and F3 and I
that was the main line that Magnus
actually played as black Magnus has
played this kind of idea and I think the
main move there is to maybe go Queen C7
see where the bishop moves because you
can go B5 B5 is kind of the move you
want to play uh in this position but it
is committal and Bishop D5 can often be
a pain here and uh followed up with
ideas of the night coming to C6 and this
is the thing that I think uh farusha is
is calculating at this moment wherever
he can play that so he has gone Queen C7
which is kind of transposing to this
line and that's saying to the bishop
well where where are you going to move
because if you go backwards you can even
go for a bit of a safer variation for
black here or trying to snap that Bishop
off with the Knight and even castle and
queen side in these kind of positions
but uh there's there's so many little
transpositions it's a very rich rich
structure here computer doesn't like it
at all for black though so yeah
Sicilians these days these open
Sicilians they've definitely fallen out
of fashion from the black side I mean
the nidor for example used to see it
pretty much in every game these days
it's all Berlin's and uh petrovs and
that's because the risk attached is huge
is huge and that's why feroz is thinking
right now and this evaluation that we're
seeing on the board right now it reminds
me a little bit of when firusha plays
the king's Indian defense we've seen the
eval bar go super high but the position
is an absolute mess it's completely
chaotic and a game for all three results
is it similar here is this the moment
that you kind of just don't care about
the engine evaluation it's just starting
and the position is going to get wild
um if you if you're playing on the board
then obviously you know you and you're
watching the game then obviously don't
care about the um evaluation of the
computer but here this is a homework
type of position because the position is
so crazy that uh you know both sides
can't just get into this and start
freestyling especially not black because
you know and there we see B5 being
played because I mean black has to
consider all sorts of things you know
the night coming to the D5 Square the
night sacrificing itself to F5 you
always have to it's such a sharp
position that you always have to be
prepared you just can't Wing this one
yeah he has to be in prep but he has
used quite a bit of his clock or you
were talking about one idea of jumping
with the Knight to C5 I've also seen
another plan that black has in this
position to actually get that Knight to
B6 and either C4 square or even try to
get rid of that Knight on C3 some
positions with the Knight jumping to A4
I think the point that I was trying to
make Ivanka here was that even though
the eval bar gives white a big Edge this
position will develop into chaos and
it's such farouja style when he plays
the king's Indian that's exactly what he
wants when he plays the dragon Dolph
that's exactly what he wants exactly and
the fact that both players are not
moving particularly fast indicates that
yes ignoring evaluation but but if one
person is moving fast then you know that
there are an opening preparation and oh
there could be trouble ahead so be be
very careful that's all I'm saying and
if if you're looking to establish an
opening repertoire I think in general
the quiet lines you can just get a buy
by just knowing the bigger picture where
to put the pieces but something like
this sorry you got it exactly you've got
to do the hard graft
and Magnus meanwhile just gets all the
pieces to the center is it time for
black to decide where to go with the
King
yeah I mean this last one was a very
good move I mean uh the ideal setup for
Black is to develop his last piece
feature to it and um then you can even
try to Castle and start as you say this
Knight B6 idea is very nice and um
maneuver but I think Magnus is kind of
setting up a direct idea against that
bishop move which uh David I'm assuming
is throwing the Knight into the center
is uh one move that at least you have to
consider as black because of the
pressure on the e-file and uh you know
then black might not be able to get
castled at all and uh that would be a
complete disaster if you you got this
position I feel so uh again there's a
lot to think about it's much easier for
white to play because white can just
centralize the pieces white has this
Knight D5 white has F4 it's much harder
for black to to find the right strategy
because you've got to think about all
these options white can do and you've
got to decide where you put your king so
it's uh if black can get over these next
couple of moves and be okay then then
it's game one you know but there is
danger here definitely for black yeah
and that's why Ferris is burning so much
time on the clock uh severe disadvantage
now under four minutes uh what four
minutes lower than Magnus Carlsen and
yeah as you say something I do feel the
next two three moves could be where this
is decided if black can survive then
long term great chances throwing pawns
towards the white king long term extra
Central Pawn in the Sicilian always
really handy but yeah I do fear for his
chances if the next two three moves go
wrong so the question is if we will have
a long term or not yeah right and yeah
the one thing I learned about the
Sicilian the kind of advice I was given
when I was young it's like especially
with white but it kind of works for both
sides it's like riding a bike you have
to keep cycling if you stop you just
fall off and you can't play slowly
positionally and otherwise things will
turn against you so you just have to
keep going forward forward and
for Magnus that's the advice for farouja
it's kind of defend at this point and
hope for that later
the pricing how much time fruition is
taking done seven and a half minutes now
it is surprising because I would have
expected farooja to go into this type of
position knowing his homework but you
know then again we always get surprised
you know it's impossible to prepare for
every single line and as David did my
reference that Rick to G1 not the most
popular move and uh well
it does appear that farrugia has
forgotten his notes
under seven minutes now the problem is
castling again it walks into something
similar Simon that you were pointing out
the White Knight is always Landing in
the center it's just a thematic idea and
it's I mean it's one of those positions
you know what's coming you know what
what your opponent wants to do next but
finding a solution is a whole different
matter
and uh yeah it just feels like you're
one move short maybe as black if you
could kind of get your Bishop out and
Castle maybe some chances for the active
play but right now it's it's tough yeah
maybe you can go Knight B6 here I think
you I think you must play Knight B6 or
Bishop B7 right to try to take the sting
out of that move I can't really see much
else but if black can get both those
moves in Knight B6 Bishop B7 he has
Castle I think is that right so that's
that that seems kind of that's a very
gutsy move just to show you Simon Knight
V6 I'm gonna break through I think I can
play E5 if you take me there would have
been nasty sacrifices yeah and if the
queen moves away anywhere then this
would have been Checkmate so farouza
made the best idea uh kind of made the
best decision there instead of risk any
checkmates he did Castle he ran away and
Magnus Carlsen of course thinking in
fruition's time was ready to play F4 so
watch out there's going to be all sorts
of Pawn breaks in the next couple of
moves F5 might even be a severe threat
due to the pressure along this diagonal
it's all about the light squares as you
mentioned Simon
and since this position is super sharp I
mean is there any way that alireza can
defend and I was primarily thinking of
getting rid of that Bishop with Knight
C5 and the evaluation bar is like oh oh
good news but I mean why
is it just because of f
4 F5 yeah he's played the most logical
move at least uh for sure like you say
E5 F5 lots of tempting options you could
maybe even capture this Knight on F6 and
jump into D5 with the other night and
wow okay there we see the engine
suggestions just below the board and
computer does confirm actually the
margins are very small here any move
other than Bishop takes Knight and it's
just a game it's just a fight it's a
very complex battle but Bishop takes F6
gives white a large Advantage this is
due to the fact that there's no simple
there's no kind of uh Pleasant way to
recapture here but taking with the
bishop walks into a nasty Fork next move
this bishop on F6 will be eliminated
wrecking the black pawn structure if you
take with the pawn first your Bishop
might just be locked in for the rest of
the game after the move F5 and this is
just a terrible piece wow Bishop F6 uh
is a move that you really don't want to
make up because you're sort of
committing to giving a bishop pair
you're giving giving up your really
nicely based Bishop on G5 and you have
this in your head that you can do it at
any point Bishop F6 is always in your
hand uh David why is it so important to
take an F on of course if it might be a
really difficult move but not for a
player called Magnus Carlsen uh there is
like you said modern chess is so
concrete and he finds the best move no
surprises there yeah past Generations
would play maybe on Instinct on feel on
pattern recognition alone but here it's
kind of very specific and they have no
Prejudice if they see a move that looks
strong even if it kind of disobeys uh
general principles then they go for it
these top players and that's why uh
they're so strong and instantly he knows
okay he has to block in Black start
Square Bishop watch out big threat black
is threatening Bishop to H6 now the dark
squared Bishop would actually pin skewer
the White Queen to the king so I'm
expecting Magnus to run there we go the
other advice I always uh was told as a
junior if you Castle Queen side always
take your time out to shuffle your king
towards the corner it's always safe
there
and uh yeah decent position yeah do some
positions you know I'm laughing at uh
your comment that day David just because
this brings back all my bad memories of
like
2022 like I had so many good positions
but I forgot to put my king on the B1
Square I forgot to tuck it into safety
and because of that like my opponents
won they managed to get counter play I'm
like oh yeah I think it was a good idea
when you go when you go Castle on the
queen side King B1 is just a move that
you need to throw in where they
sometimes even when my opponent doesn't
have a direct threat put that King and
B1 get out of the C line get out of the
bin but do you know what I did instead
Tanya I grabbed a pawn
[Laughter]
and it was wrong
there you go it can be super dangerous
and this position is getting super
dangerous and Magnus now jumps in with
the idea that you're pointing out Knight
to D5 so Bishop 86 not a threat anymore
especially with that F6 Bond hanging but
can you really allow this Knight to stay
alive on D5 oh it's unpleasant here
there's no uh there's no kind of easy
decisions anymore taking this Knight off
the board here will just be replaced by
a very strong Bishop uh at the moment
you just need counter play that's the
name of the game with the Sicilian you
need some kind of counter play often
you're getting attacked but at least
you're attacking yourself here I just
don't see it strategically and kind of
dynamically the black king is about to
come out of some severe pressure yeah
okay he trades off this bishop first
play sense but are we going to be left
with some Knight versus Bishop position
where you can clearly see it's going to
be a good night versus bad Bishop
including a weakness on the d-line yeah
I'm expecting actually Bishop takes
Knight to appear on the board and yeah
strategically white is completely
winning yeah but you know the kings are
castled on opposite sides of the board
and black does have a straightforward
plan of just matching the A5 a pawn up
the board and seeing what damage it can
do actually not seeing praying for some
damage
Simon it's your two favorite words good
night and uh what about these two nights
in the middle of the board yeah I mean
Black's just in a lot of trouble here I
mean I I thought this is maybe the best
try and uh the one one thing I'd love to
do with black is just put the bishop on
E5 which is kind of a normal idea but
with this last move there's a made
another major hole and this hole in the
middle of the board is just I I think
it's going to be terminal unfortunately
for black uh the E6 Square uh a knight
ready to come in and uh you know just
take that black bishop and move it over
the pawn like Black's okay right because
the bishop is is on a good solid Square
control on the board that's your that's
what you want to achieve here but I just
don't think you can do it so I wanted to
go Bishop H6 to F4 but you just don't
have time because White's Frets are too
too quick here and uh you can never get
the bishop to F4 anyway so I I think the
opening's just been a bit of a disaster
for for user in this game it's just gone
wrong and alireza ferusa literally has
no time he's under the three minute Mark
as well a very difficult position to me
this game again looks like one of the
classic Magnus example where it's so
difficult to point out the moment it
went so wrong for black uh fuja he did
all these moves natural looking moves
developing the Queen the bishop on the
queen side castling and then suddenly
he's dead lost with black
how does Magnus do this
I wish we knew it's like a magic potion
that he uh just has up his sleeve and
somehow sprinkles this magic magic dust
on the board and pieces fall on good
squares you look at the white king
somehow uh I mean we were talking about
opposite side castling it's always risky
for both somehow the white king looks uh
super safe just cuddled to her by all
those white pawns and meanwhile the
black king it's counterpart
not looking great the White Knight
cemented there forever now that white
knight will forever dominate that black
Bishop uh still need the Finishing Touch
so I'm not going to write it off just
yet but uh it does look beautiful right
now and wow okay he goes for it throwing
pawns forward this is a sacrifice but I
think he's uh just banking on all the
open files that are about to uh line up
against that black king it should be as
decisive attack and it's no surprise
with such beautiful coordination
beautiful centralization uh for white
that something like this would work now
it's not even a sacrifice
[Music]
night on E6 I mean you would never want
to pick up that g for bomber you
probably don't have an option because
it's sort of choosing the Lesser evil
you pick that up that Pawn's going to
fall but also the H lines open the queen
jumps into an attack you go Queen to F4
you're hitting the pawn on DC and the
reason it's not a sacrifice is because
you can't step out five the f porn
because the Knight will come and deliver
a check
and okay you can delay picking that up
because F5 doesn't really help anymore
because the pawn is pin so you can
anyway pick up on G4 yeah just to show
that F5 tactics just always seem to work
in magnus's favor uh just putting pieces
on good healthy squares and uh it's the
pin well takes Rook would lose the black
queen and this would end in Checkmate
and okay this is on the board and I
guess farruges may be banking on the
fact this queen can move it will he try
and trade off Queens uh what's he gonna
try and do sooner or later it just feels
deadly something's happening along the H
file
doesn't look Pleasant at all doesn't
look uh Pleasant for fuja and we are
getting some big updates from division
two as well it's not been a pleasant day
for uh Lavon aronian as uh our Tammy
have advances to the Winner's Final in
division two where he our Tamia will be
facing yeah
move down to the losers bracket the
action continues there are big exciting
matches happening and you can follow all
the drama all uh all the games on chess
dojo's twitch Channel a lot at stake
let's just remind everyone only two
events remain in the 23 season of the
Champions Chester it's all about getting
to Toronto there are two ways you can do
it become a winner and any one of the
six events or through the critical tour
points the winner of division two gets
50 tour points as well as ten thousand
dollars so the fight is on follow it on
chest dojo's twitch Channel but I think
it's impossible to leave this position
that we have right now we might even be
game over a Checkmate coming in soon
that was a big threat there wasn't there
David I mean that was a very nice fret
that Magnus has set up
yeah Queen takes Bishop is the threat so
if uh ferocia hadn't played the move he
just did for example if he continued
trying to attack the white king it's
simply too slow Queen takes Bishop would
have been a beautiful sacrifice tricking
the blacking into coming forward and
look how this white knight cuts off all
the Escape squares Rook to H4 would have
been a beautiful Checkmate on the edge
of the board farooja has stopped that
though he played Queen to E7 so now this
same trick doesn't work do not sacrifice
your queen this time because this square
is suddenly covered by The Black Queen
so really really clever defense there uh
from black but it feels like Magnus
doesn't need to rush he could just move
this queen out the way uh where's he
gonna go will he drop back yeah H3 for
example and this Rook is still sliding
still the same threats persist and both
the white Rooks actually are going to be
added as ammunition in the next couple
of moves and black has just not managed
to get play going on the queen side well
white has exploded the king side and all
of that is being played out Queen H3
Rook H4 on the board how do you even
defend that Bishop okay the only way to
do it pushes the pawn but you're kind of
making more weaknesses on the king side
do you go Rook H5 here
looks most logical uh
staying consistent setting up this
battery on the H file and the blacks
pawns as you say they're just becoming
weaker and weaker the shelter around the
black king is being forced to kind of uh
remove itself simply and there we go
Knight G5 a big threat on the board now
it's just all in White's favor the White
Knight is just it's just too strong here
uh I mean it's sitting in the middle of
the board
um it's stopping the black Rooks getting
in it's threatening to take on G5
um you compare it to Black's Bishop
Black's Bishop is just pinned down and
there is that big fret as you say just
Knight takes Pawn check uh White can
also bring his last piece into the game
it's always nice when you get every
single piece attacking well not nice for
alireza but nice and Magnus and uh G4
seemed forced but even just Queen D3
here looks looks strong uh in this
position maybe King G6 holds on and have
I trapped my Rook there oh there's a
little trick is that right
so um yeah you mean you still have to
convert these positions so this why
Magnus is uh taking his time but talking
about time he's got eight minutes to uh
Ali Razor's
40 seconds so uh that's not a good sign
but maybe it's worth sharing that little
trick um I don't know if it is a trick
but it's something that and the Eraser
can maybe hope for I think the trick is
going to get tricky unfortunately
because you're ganging up on F5 and the
black king can indeed Defenders you say
Simon it looks like this Rook is trapped
but now the final piece can be added uh
to that party and Rook to F1 hitting
this this hitting this Pawn for a third
time would end the game King takes Rook
now would be met by a double attack
hitting the Rook uh hitting the king
sorry and hitting the queen and this
would be decisive we'd see I mean I'm
not sure where the Checkmate is but it
feels like it's about to arise uh it
feels like you should be winning anytime
soon the blacking surely cannot survive
so far from the rest of its Army that's
a really nice detail this Rook F1 move
because otherwise we might just be
seeing a very different game after G4 if
you don't have this idea of the other
roof coming to the rescue yeah I mean
the thing is tactics always work I mean
people might assume that and I see a lot
of beginners doing this or uh sort of
amateur players they try to force
tactics from positions of weakness but
tactics work from positions of strength
so normally you have to play a nice
positional game build up your position
and then tactics will work because
you've got that good position in the
first place and this is just the key key
example of that that White's pieces are
fantastic he's played a great positional
game and black had a rotten opening here
so tactics work and uh Rook F1 bringing
the last piece in was a nicely found
idea David showed there thinking about
yeah it's slightly strange I'm not sure
what else that looks like the most
logical once you see Rook F1 you kind of
play it but maybe he's looking I think
uh David what you just said once you see
Rook F1 it's not the easiest move to
spot uh the first time you pointed out
this King G6 trapping The Rook I I kind
of felt that this was a very tricky idea
and maybe Magnus hasn't spotted Rook F1
possible right I mean I think he has but
he might be looking deeper uh this is
kind of bread and butter for Magnus
Carlson I'm sure ferocious spotted this
as well but uh okay I'm gonna jump back
in for one second because he might be
looking at a slightly crazy line here
the queen attacks the pawn the king
steps forward to attack it uh attack
this Rook as well and uh yeah Rook F1 we
think is the killer blow but black can
defend this because the white Rook is
trapped uh on this square and can I
recommend them you want to go H3 don't
you oh uh okay no it's H3 um in the last
position I think oh in the previous
position maybe but I thought that's what
yeah yeah I don't know maybe wow nice
some some nonsense we might see this
being played out king G6 something might
not work at all but
I mean this is the key position we're
expecting now this is uh the game
position we're expecting Rook to F1 uh
meaning that the black king cannot take
this Rook uh due to Rook takes F5 but
after Rook to f8 I mean you do have
tempting options first you could take
this Rook but your own Rook is trapped
okay whoa ferrous is going for it I was
going to say here maybe you take and at
the very end you can pin this black Rook
you are winning long term but um look at
what's happened on the board I wrote
this one off I said white is just
guaranteed a Checkmate but ferrous is
calling magnus's bluff where is the
Finish
can we find it can we get there it's
like puzzle Rush right I mean H3 again
is quite tempting you know it's just uh
uh might be a good move but yeah okay
Queen G6 Queen H7 there's some Queen
checks back here yeah there's so many
tempting options you need the Knight to
add it to the attack against the black
king Magnus has given a check forcing
the black king back
I think he come yeah you know the one
player who's really good with Queen
moves in the world Magnus Carlsen so I
think he will find it and uh Simon and
your idea on the board H3 you got to
explain this to us why do you want to
sacrifice the spawn and how does it
finish after GTX H3 it's just opening up
the black king ball uh it's kind of as
simple as that I mean uh you you give
different ways you can check the black
king and um I I assume it has to be
taken and we can have a look
um and okay he hasn't taken it but um
the black King's just so weak here and
Knight and queen they're the best
attackers when a knight and queen
coordinate they can often just cause so
much chaos on the board and uh they are
they're coordinating very well here yeah
and that's the uh only piece that can
move in ways the queen can't so this is
kind of the perfect uh scenario it's
actually level material we shouldn't
forget that the White Queen and one Pawn
uh for the two black Brooks so
technically level points but it's just
about the king safety and the fact that
what is still on the board uh clearly
favors Magnuson he's going to start
munching on pawns at the very very
minimum White's King's still super safe
can slide to A2 if he wants and is he
going to start getting greedy now
Black's D6 Pawn is up for grabs you can
give a couple of checks as well there we
go and actually wait to deport might
become a second Queen
but for Asia is still creating counter
play trying to open up the a files to uh
the white king is slightly more
vulnerable or at least slightly less
comfortable but first is Magnus to start
checking yeah unfortunately the open a
line oh and there's a check there the
open a line can be closed off at the
very least by playing B3 B4 so I don't
see the danger for Magnus I'll be so
professional to put in B4 when the fire
is on one side of the board no I I just
be looking at Checkmate here not not
closing up that file and oh this is a
nice move yeah attacking the room
attacking the rook and I think the thing
I don't think Ali razor can be too too
upset here because he's uh
he moves the rug and also notice how the
queen if it would have captured The Rook
it was defending the H1 Square so you
didn't have time to take on B3 because
Rook H1 was in Checkmate so everything
just falls into place in White's
position in just five seconds for
alireza he makes a move
I might be seeing your move just
shutting down the play on The Queen side
that would be unfortunate let's say that
would be very much I mean it's a little
again there's little tricks you could go
Queen D3 and D7 but um maybe this is
what Magnus is calculating but does
allow some checks if you play that way
so this is you know you have to be
careful and it has played this
um and D7 is the move you want to play
but Rook H1 King A2 take on B free check
King takes B3 and you're safe but it's a
little bit like I want to play B4 now
you know it's kind of like you know I
just want to keep it safe because you
just have to calculate quite carefully
here I think this is winning uh for
white but you know just Magnus taking a
couple of seconds to do that and I don't
think you know early Razer should be
that upset with this game because he got
he got a rotten opening right and he
didn't really get a chance I mean uh I
don't know where he should have uh
played differently maybe it was as
simple as it was just a very bad opening
but you know I'll push back on that
because that seemed like the storyline
between the Fabi not the back game Fabi
in that game one that felt like solid
opening prep here I just felt like he
got outplayed it wasn't a miniature it
wasn't a result just out of the opening
but every move his Advantage kept going
increasing on and on and I think it's
really difficult to lose game one in
this way and to me I was hoping for an
Armageddon but with the way we've just
seen him out play ferusa I don't think
we're getting that he's got white in the
next game so you know don't don't let's
not write him off yet I mean I do think
it was a bad opening I think uh pushing
the H Pawn two squares and then being
careless with the King and then jumping
with the Knight not anticipating some
captures was too much for such a razor
sharp position and uh Magnus look at him
that's it he's done it there was nothing
more to be done in that position Ali
Reza feruja not happy with what just
happened and perhaps just checking the
opening as Simon mentioned which went
wrong and it looked like magnesis Atlas
alireza in this game one but alireza
does
uh come back with the white in the next
game so he's got his big chance that's
coming up but this one looked like a
Magnus Carlsen show David it was a
Magnus Masterpiece this game furusia
didn't really get a chance to fight back
and uh after that difficult opening
Magnus just cruised to Victory and it
was here that he really cemented a
tangible Advantage it looks like a very
complicated Sicilian typical position
but black is just one move two shorts
and Magnus clinched it here with Bishop
takes F6 not the usual move that you see
in the Sicilian but this is based on the
fact that the White Knight is jumping
into the center with gain of tempo
against this poor black queen if Bishop
takes now Knight to D5 would be a nasty
attack instead just the move that
clinched it here for me was F5 locking
down this bishop we saw it was a bad
Bishop to the end of days and now Magnus
with all the squares all the light
squares on the board was able to have
all the fun
he did have all the fun and in the end
wrapped it up with a nice tactic which
means in their best for Magnus Carlsen
takes the lead with that point coming
out of this game Ivanka for alireza uh
just the way the quality of play that we
just saw and really not getting that
game going what do you think he needs to
do in these couple of minutes he's got
before game two he just has to refresh
you know the first game bad game it
happens but you know he has the white
pieces he's beaten Magnus Carlson before
he has to draw on those experiences and
just play active chess
I think he's got to forget about that
game I mean and just tell himself it was
just the opening it was nothing to do in
my play I've got white in the next game
I'm really good with white I'm going to
attack Magnus I'm going to take him down
win the next game win the next game
Champion there you go easy so that's all
he's got to do he just needs to take
inspiration I hope he was watching the
show today uh earlier for Russia he
needs to take inspiration from Abdul
sotorov who also got a bit wiped out in
the first game against Carolina but the
younger players who've both gone through
so far in the losers bracket they
bounced back and uh I've do sort of road
is luck won a game then clinch the
Armageddon so it's been done before
already Jay you can do it again what a
day of Chess it has been two of the
world top 10 have been knocked out of
the Julius bear generation Kappa and the
big match between Magnus Carlson and
alireza farouza continues we will be
back with game two in just a few
[Music]
we are live in Oslo Norway it's a
beautiful day a beautiful summer you
know the drill we've done this before
ma'am do you mind if I ask you some
questions real quick when I say chess
what's the first word that comes to your
mind game hustle puzzle that's brilliant
chess horse smart black panther white
black and white that's two words but I'm
gonna let it pass if I say chess what's
the first word that comes to your mind
[Music]
um I I don't know if I have any other
questions for you okay when I say
strategy what's the first thing that
comes to your mind puzzle oh my God
Magnus Carlson Jess the answer was
puzzle actually that was the correct
answer that's okay though okay yeah I
love tests you do love chess do you play
chess yeah you play chess online yeah
where do you play
you know who Magnus Carlson is uh no
okay could you name any world chess
champion we shall not I knew you were
gonna say that obviously you know who
Magnus Carlson is sure right you know
how good he is the best yeah he's the
best right yeah as has Norway changed
now that Magnus isn't the world champion
yeah it's kind of a bit more sad do you
know that he's no longer the world chess
champion I did not know that yeah so you
didn't know why you felt sad and now you
know why yeah I guess so he'll he'll get
back up he'll get back do you know why
no he left chefs to become a footballer
actually yeah actually I think it's very
different chess and football yeah but
he's an athlete so he can pull it off it
makes sense it makes sense right I don't
know who he is you don't know who Magnus
Carlos is okay he's a professional
footballer one of the most well known in
Norway okay okay okay so I'm not from
here okay I heard there was a huge um
chess tournament thing where he accused
another player of cheating that's true
do you know anything about that scandal
have we done our job Oslo Oslo they are
an educated Chef city a city of deep
thinking people a city of beautiful
people a city where chess comes to life
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
so far on day three of the Julius bear
generation cup in the Battle of
generations youth has been prevailing
with not a back up to satrobe and
danislavik taking down Wesley so and
Fabiano caruana while the match in the
winners final continues we also
introduced you to another young player
who has been taking the world based on
the eight-year-old from London
and she had a lot of fun when she
challenged the 79 year old Peter Lee
take a look at what happened in that
battle of the generations
what's the best thing over here it's an
old thing for parcel posts so if you
have to send a parcel the way you put
the parcel in one and you put the
weights in the other and when it
balances you know the parcel weighs four
pounds or um so many grams
[Music]
I think the optimum age for playing my
first chess will probably be when I'm
somewhere around a teenager mid-30s is
probably the the people reach their
reach their strongest and um
so at age 79 I'm probably a bit past it
[Music]
yeah they're just inside thank you
that little girl is eight and she's the
strongest chess player of either sex in
the work in the world of her age so
she's just beating me and I'm an
ex-british champion
yeah
then takes the lead in her battle
against Peter Lee what a girl what a
match that was and a great question
there what is the optimal age in chess
so what was it for you when you played
your best chess Simon
um I can remember probably when I made
my biggest leap was around the age of 12
so I started playing like a lot of
people my dad taught me around the age
of six and um I didn't really I didn't
really progress that much but suddenly
at the age of 12 I suddenly made a big
leap and I started playing in some
International tournaments and uh so for
me it was 12 but I think that's probably
quite late nowadays isn't it I mean you
know 12 I think I was 22 50 at 12 but
most most people are Grand Masters at 12
now aren't they so it's uh yeah so it
changes it gets shorter and shorter
lower and lower every year I think so
yeah it's absolutely
chess has become
if you're not a grand Mother by the time
you're 15 it's so hard to make a career
in China is that too much
in 13 I think no I mean it's crazy you
know just now in DeSoto if I played an
11 year old who was uh 23.50 is
considered one of Germany's brightest
young talents and it was just crazy how
little they were off
scary times yeah scary times but I'm
going to suggest that actually you peek
maybe a bit later on when you have that
Perfect Blend of energy still some
youthfulness but then you also have the
experience about 50 maybe yeah
give me a chance don't break some time
yeah I think for me it was actually I
was playing my best just when I was 26
27 so quite late and it was actually my
be creating as well it's around 24 45
and I was also really enjoying chess I
felt like it took the pressure off a
little bit
um and uh oh wow look at that I wasn't
expecting that but my age is wrong oh it
was 25.50 yeah I think that's a chess
score reading I wish that was not be
creating it would be a grand master but
it was 24 40 something in classical and
I think it was back in 2014 or 2015. and
look at this for David I tried actually
David you and I pretty much similar
times yeah Yogi is this correct for you
um well the a just is one year out
[Laughter]
we've got our best years ahead guys yes
still ahead said every old person ever
[Music]
but you know it's not unheard of in
history for players to get a second wind
in their sales we have aronia and we
have Vichy Anand as well and we've also
had um I remember like some cases in
history like Mark taimanov he was doing
really well and then he had a second
wind in his cells around 43 years old so
it's possible yeah absolutely chess is
uh enjoyed and played by all ages and
that is what the Julius bear generation
cup is about but today it does feel like
it's the day of the youth the younger
generation has been dominating but in
the winners final Magnus Carlton has
taken the lead against Ali Reza furuja
alireza getting his energy up he's going
to need it with the white pieces he did
go all in with black it backfired as you
said out of the opening getting into big
trouble and Magnus never really gave him
a chance and we've got a very messy room
and a Magnus running back and uh is that
a carrot in his hand it's not a carrot
or a very orange chess piece you never
know but yeah both players actually
mimicking each other they're both
snacking just as I was during the break
confession but yeah energy levels
they're high and these players very
aware of these uh kind of small details
that do actually affect throughout such
a long match and a long day and another
Sicilian we're being treated here
Fighting Chess yeah it'd be really funny
I don't know okay it's a different
Sicilian this time so I was wondering if
the Magnus would pick the same kind of
thing that uh farooza did in the last
game but we're getting a tamanov kind of
variation here which is becoming quite
popular recently uh very flexible
and uh Magnus has been playing this now
and again isn't he on the tour I think
this the setup as well
yeah actually I did have a conversation
with uh Magnus during the World Cup one
evening I was just sitting there
depressed about my openings and he was
like you should play the taimano
Sicilian it's for Old Men and I was like
what's that mean no Sicilians for old
man surely but he was like okay there's
less Theory than the other Sicilians
you're guaranteed a rock solid uh Pawn
structure here and yeah he has been
playing it as you say Simon throughout
the tour I remember some very memorable
games he's beating Fabiano with this
line and others this season
more because it's plant-based and
team-based for black you don't need to
be as concrete as you do in a night off
for example
yeah I think that's right I mean we saw
what happened in the night off with
farrugia last game just maybe one small
careless move we can't even pinpoint it
we don't know where he went wrong but uh
suddenly he was facing a uh blistering
attack so
um yeah definitely kind of in terms of
theory in terms of survivability
it feels like time on off a decent
choice and we might be seeing another
long side Queen side castling by uh
alireza in this game uh Queen F3 is he
hinting towards getting the King on the
queen side
yeah this is this is the main line
actually uh Queen F3 here that that so I
it's good to see uh Ali Razer playing
the sharpest light I I you know I think
that's the way to take Magnus down
you've got to test him in in the sort of
uh most critical stuff and yeah castle
and queen side is very common I mean I
think here you can castle and I remember
looking at some crazy idea where you can
go Bishop A3 after Castle in Queen side
uh which is actually which is just a
really bizarre move so castling Knight
E5 is the main option but Bishop A3 is
quite fun a fun move just to you know
really uh really sort of confuse fuse
white there
um in some position I think and I'm
looking at the database main line is
actually not to put the bishop 183
although that is uh quite an interesting
idea but it's actually just to attack
the Queen by putting it in the Santa
it's on the board and uh yeah mag um
faroogia slides his Queen one square
and Black's plan is just to get going
with those pawns on the left side of the
board pick up the B Pawn move the two
squares
after all the white king is situated on
the queen side it's declared its
intentions before the black king which
is uh still flexible also White's kind
of committed to King side action you
look at the way the White Queen is
sitting really active Square kind of
pinning the knight in the center eyeing
up the king side so why not switch
attentions to the other flank uh makes a
lot of sense here and Magnus of course
knows his theory but I don't think it's
just the moves that are going through
his mind it's also where is farusha
prepared uh he's kind of so Adept at
dodging opening surprises opening bombs
and he's just trying to get a game just
get get a position
and so when you guys do your opening
preparation do you actually look at the
opening stats so like right here in
front of me I can see that if black were
to play the move B7 B5 that white has
won 47 of the time 21 time it's a draw
and 32 black Victory does that is that
good bad
I look at these things more maybe when
I'm playing Blitz uh just because
especially if you know what the most
popular moves are in Blitz you know what
may be the most instinctive moves are
for your opponent you can kind of set
traps according to how people react
there uh In classical chess I maybe
trust the engine evaluation more than
maybe the statistics because I I kind of
just assume with a lot of time on my
clock I can navigate it no matter what
and sometimes uh these stats are a bit
skewed by kind of the level of player
playing and uh ratings and time controls
and things like that but definitely a
factor I think these days in every sport
everything's more stats based right
yeah I would agree and I think even for
me it it was always about the positions
that I liked more than the percentage of
course if it's uh really bad then you
kind of want to figure out why that's
the case and you want to avoid those
lines but in general if you enjoy
playing a position uh and there's
nothing super wrong with it I feel like
this game much later on to check out the
stats uh I've played a little bit of
domino myself and I quite like it with
black same reasons Knight off too
concrete for me too many lines to
remember my memory is not the best so
it's definitely not a line I would go
for but in these positions I H5 is a
move that's really fascinating but I was
thinking of even just a simple
theoretical thematic ideas of advancing
the B Pawn B5 you develop your bishop
and B7 and I think that's still in the
air but H5 is super direct because
Magnus is also looking at planting a
knight on G4 and hitting that Bishop on
the E3 Square uh but H5 is not something
that I'm really familiar with I still
like the B5 plans the stats you know
proof oh by the way this is 69
victory for white nice yeah I think
Anish played this though I mean anisha's
played this as that position with the
black pieces and um I seem to recall
that H5 was an idea that he played and
was quite a fan of and it's not not so
stupid because uh the White Queen is in
quite a quite a strange place and you
want to kick it away so you can develop
your dark Square bishop and uh it
actually seems to make quite a logical
logical sense here just to annoy uh
White's Queen yeah I know that in a very
similar position where Black's Knight is
still on G8 and white hasn't Castle
queenside yet this is maybe the main
move playing H5 but
um during the pandemic uh I wasn't doing
too much at first uh when the virus
first hit and I was doing a bit of
coaching and uh actually I was working a
little bit with Harry griever British
champion later on and he asked me to
look at this position I was like oh come
on uh do I have to
it's too wild for me it's too crazy uh
but then I looked a bit deeper and there
was actually someone else I was working
with and I looked more seriously then I
remember this being inaccurate it feels
like Magnus is freestyling if I remember
correctly white has two moves you can
play F4 kicking away the black knight
from the center but even the move Knight
to B5 is interesting here
just because white has castled you've
gained a Tempo and the fact that farage
has paused for the first time for two
minutes means that he's not familiar
with this move order and
maybe Magnus knows something I don't
hear but uh at least if I recall
correctly with strong engines they do
say that this move
maybe not the most accurate even though
it is thematic and typical in this type
of position
very often in these online speed chest
ornaments one gets the feeling that if
Magnus finds something interesting on
the board he'll just go for it even if
it might objectively or the computer
evaluation might say something different
for him it's about posing practical
problems do you think this could be a
case of that he's feeling good about
that first round win he's got that
confidence going and he just once again
he just wants to have fun yeah certainly
but at the same time objectively if
especially in an open Sicilian where the
stakes are so high one mistake is
maybe likely to decide things I'm still
a bit surprised I mean well not sure I'm
surprised but I'm confused that the
players are spending 2-3 minutes in what
is still a very well known position
do a deep dive and take a look at what
happens in these two variations
especially this Knight B5 move that
sounds that looks really exciting yeah I
mean I've just checked with the engine
here it did say that F4 is stronger but
I do remember maybe a mistaken that
Knight B5 let's see the bar drop no it
is a move and uh after the Knight is
captured this is the sacrifice
temporarily but remember the black queen
is tied down defending her Knight in the
center of the ball too and if she
continues defending her her Knight only
one square with which to do so then
suddenly Bishop to B6 is a nasty move
threatening not just a knight check a
night Fork on C7 but also to trap The
Black Queen uh where she stands on the
back rank so if I remember correctly
black has to do some really weird and
wonderful stuff just to even survive
this next few moves
um of course it's complicated black and
for example tapes Pawn counter-attacking
the White Queen but
I mean that's beyond the point it's just
a pure mess so far Asia now I think he's
deciding whether to incite violence with
uh this move this night sacrifice Knight
to B5 taking kind of uh just a really
opportunistic
uh kind of tactical trick there or maybe
the more sensible Pawn to F4 which the
computer also seems to like hitting this
Knight forcing it away from the center
you can go two directions towards the
queen side towards the king side but
either way I think the idea for white
will be to step forward and start asking
questions of the black pieces that have
been developed to me it just feels like
white has got the momentum it's a bit
like the last game White's got all the
pieces centralized Why not start
attacking tactics look like they start
to work yeah again very interesting
games fortunately so far from uh you
know this the last game in this game and
both players of the black piece has
taken a lot of risks and it could be
that this move H5 is uh the key mistaken
in both games as well I mean the last
game H5 seemed to be a little bit too
slow we can too many squares and uh if
David's analysis is is correct which I'm
sure it is I don't want to doubt it but
if if white can uh recall that and well
maybe when white hasn't seen this but if
he can you know just get those moves on
the board then Magnus can be in a bit of
trouble do you reckon Magnus knows this
is a dubious line and he just doesn't
care he's like okay I'm gonna spin the
dice you know he's he does take risks
right he does he's played worse as well
and he's known for kind of playing the
opponent uh he's kind of on record
saying against Wesley so he takes more
risks but a bit more provocative in the
opening and uh yeah here I'm not so sure
would you take a provocative approach
against the player like alireza unless
you know he's got something worked out
against night sacrifice and his kind of
like double bluffing there well clearly
alarm Bells Are Ringing into ferris's
head there's no other excuse for
spending five and a half minutes on just
move nine in a very well known position
or very one and type of position and uh
yeah I mean clearly a red flag is there
he's saying okay this isn't the right
move order
there must be a punishment maybe he
doesn't know what the punishment is he's
never investigated all the details I
think he'll go Knight B5 I think so too
I think now that he's he's fought so
long he's looking for something a little
bit different because F4 very logical
and he's spending time he's obviously a
brilliant tactician I I think he'll play
Knight B5 here and he has to take his
chance right he has to take an
opportunity if he calculates it and sees
that the sacrifice Works he can't just
take a safer approach F4 like you said a
very reasonable move but after burning
the clock so much
the Mad situation you're down a point
you want to take the chance you get
Knight B5 on the board I think it's
coming in he's reaching out yeah I think
F4 oh let's see bets are on 95. boom on
the board and uh I mean I don't remember
any details from here other than White's
next move I just remember it was chaos I
was looking from the black side and I
thought okay this is unplayable uh the
stakes are so high you just got knocked
out in the next move or two if you're
not careful gotta play very you've got
to be very careful here as you say I
mean is there a rook takes A2
um with a knight E4 check tactic coming
in I I it's getting so complex this is
where uh yeah you know you kind of want
to have done your homework but maybe
neither aside can recall it I mean uh
I don't know I mean like it's actually
really hard to find a move uh for for
Magnuson one game played uh in this
exact position and uh black just played
the move that David actually suggested
Knight takes porn yeah I just vaguely
remember looking at this but it was
three years ago guys and A lot's
happened since so uh my details here are
a bit fuzzy but clearly Magnus now as
well just out of book I think he's
muddled something up in his Minds it's
so easy to do playing the kind of right
idea just in the wrong order and uh
playing H5 in that position it feels
like it's backfired somehow uh this
would be logical attacking the White
Queen of course but the White Queen will
just move and still the threats are on
the board how are you gonna guard
against the nasty night check or a
bishop trap of your queen on B8 and now
not just that but you've added another
problem to the mix uh this Knight is on
priest it is attacked and vulnerable as
well so Magnus he needs to really uh I
mean calculate first of all but he has
to come up with something a bit special
just to survive the next few moves the
Sicilian this is why it's kind of so
high risk it's so popular but at the
same time it's uh High demands on you to
memorize the exact uh move orders just
to avoid these kind of early potential
Miniatures dare I say it
complicated position complicated
position and Magnus in a big think right
now he's touching the 10 minute Mark
huge threats on the board Rook here too
like we said is not possible uh and uh
he has to fight against one of the
pieces arising on C7
94 it feels like it's the kind of move
that you eventually come to because it's
very hard to fight the threat on the
board otherwise you need to create an
offense of your own uh David H5 took us
by surprise but instead couldn't the
same tactics follow if black would have
made the the usual the standard B5
because these are thematic sacrifices
these are thematic sacrifices so I guess
they're Tanya the B Pawn wouldn't be uh
standing on the board it will be
basically the same position but White's
Bishop could not have landed on this
Square the black queen is actually
trapped she wishes the black B Pawn was
off the board because then actually she
has some breathing space some air uh
very good point these small details here
and there I mean that's why again
Sicilians they're so tricky that's why
most of my life I've tried to avoid them
um just yeah I've figured out that okay
my nerves can't handle these types of
positions but
um that's why the top players I mean
they tend to turn these types of
positions in their favor here though I
mean who's he going to work for and who
would you pick here would you want to be
white or black let's say you don't have
any idea about the theory you don't know
what the evaluation is you're playing
this position for the first time Ivanka
would you be white or black uh White oh
I mean I mean one of the big things
about this position is that white is not
just threatening the Knight track to C7
but also the bishop is coming to see
seven to trap the queen how are you
gonna handle that and
there's just one game in my database and
that one is actually a miniature
um
yeah it was quite a funny one actually
so uh Knight takes Pawn was played and
white played not David's move which is a
much better move but Queen moved to H4
attacking the Knight
and uh black got very excited and played
Simon's movement
hopefully I won't play it in this
position just just want to clarify that
I I'd probably think about that move for
at least a minute or two and uh
threatening Checkmate though yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's you know we've got some
ideas if I could finish it off for us
the queen did find a home on the d8
Square and that was Checkmate whoops so
that's the only game in the database but
actually there was a natural point that
the queen moving to H4 is actually wrong
and uh Moment of Truth Magnus has played
Knight takes C4 attacking the White
Queen so we're thinking that this move
is wrong it's so natural though and uh
okay farouzia doesn't go for this I
guess this move would be met by uh
which one your Banker help me out here
I don't know do you defend them pretty
fun defend the night maybe to run with
your king and hear the I guess the trick
would be if you try and trap The Black
Queen now Rook takes born uh Simon's
idea would actually threaten Checkmate
and you can Evacuate the queen but this
would have been crazy uh I think farooja
didn't want any hand in this one and
whoa we see something similar Queen to
E3 also meant by Rook takes porn
threatening Checkmate of course but now
farouzia can eliminate this Knight
wow we kind of looked at a similar
position earlier didn't we and then the
Rook comes back to wave four there's
pieces everywhere here they're they're
all uh they're all on pre aren't they
but yeah I mean
it does seem that Magnus could be in a
lot of trouble here
yeah I think he might have to sacrifice
uh his queen or sacrifice some material
for example if a knight check lands how
are we dealing with this and there we
see stockfish the computer confirms this
is by far White's best move right now
it's also the most natural move in the
position uh everything you calculate uh
interests it should start with checks
captures and threats and this is a check
so where does the black can go you
cannot step across for example the White
Knight will just run out the way
anywhere really uh with a discovered
check next move picks up the queen you
don't really want to step into the
center maybe you can get away with this
just feels so shaky feels like you're
about to get checkmated maybe this is
what Magnus is banking on uh the
alternative of course would be to
sacrifice the queen but you are only
having their two pieces if I count
correctly for the black queen so not
sufficient
that looks like big trouble in Knight C7
if King E7 isn't good and you have to
give up such big material it could be
the game that fuja actually makes his
comeback and the other thread I want to
point out uh David we've got black two
knights in the Central Square so F3 is
always in the air as well it's something
that black needs to watch out for
picking up one of the knights and 97 and
he doesn't give up the queen I think
giving up the queen would be almost like
hitting the resign button here so no
matter how ugly it is you have to make
the move King to E7 and I'm wondering if
it's time to go F3 now it looks like you
do have time I mean you have caged this
black queen you've basically trapped her
uh you're not gonna win her but you've
made sure she won't participate in any
defense and uh the move F3 does win back
this piece still big Advantage for white
maybe there's something even better here
uh Bishop B5 is very tempting as well
just develop a piece uh attack The Rook
at the same time
um whoa there you go you can see how how
it can change so quickly here I mean
look like a normal move but it looks
winning almost yeah but obviously
Black's got something here and this this
is the danger in the positioning Knight
C4 wow I mean what a move I mean it's so
easy to miss moves like this and uh in
these sharp positions but uh this is the
kind of position which uh Audi Razer
just plays so well right he he
calculates phenomenally uh phenomenally
well and just you also play Rook D4 yes
Ivanka that's a highlighted is the third
best move for white but yeah we do see
the computer giving us a helping hand we
need that in such a chaotic position the
players wish they had a helping hand and
the engine says wow Queen to B3 that's
not obvious that's not instinctive we
didn't suggest it uh ourselves this does
kick away the black rook and I guess the
idea is firstly this black Rook is
pretty much trapped it is trapped where
to go check if you go actually good
question where do you go with the Rook
even if you had a square to retreat I
think Queen before check and picking up
the Knight on e4 yeah double attack and
once you win back the piece you're
attacking for free white is a piece down
for the moment but you will win that
piece back you've basically got a free
hand this is winning if ferrugia finds
coin to B3 the other moves we suggested
and black is still alive Magnus would be
fighting this is the key move
and it all came about from this H5 move
um after H5 this this was basically a
forced variation uh pretty much up to
this point and uh it's kind of the story
of the last game I feel and the last
game Magnus after H5 the corner of the
computer had like plus one one and a
half Advantage which at that level is
enough to win and in this game it's the
same so H5 just don't play H5 in the
next game with Harry the itch funded it
it's not really working today is it I
mean bad Harry today he's bad bad
Harry's he's not he's not getting his
moves in at the right time that's for
sure and uh yeah I mean the this is this
is a key moment though there's lots of
tempting moves and um probably as you
say more than one move that should win
the game but Queen B3 is is a really
nice move so nice but I I would be just
tempted to go F3 for me that's the most
natural move on the board you hit that
night and you win your material back a
Black's King is just awful for the rest
of the game you keep all your trumps
what I'm worried about is the amount of
time that alireza is taking here he's
got to be a little careful he's hitting
the three minute Mark
um but I guess it's one of those
positions where you spend the time in
and the game can be over really soon
just find a couple of precise moves yeah
exactly I think it's well worth the
energy to spend some time in this
position and it's super helpful you know
just to run through that list checks
captures threats you know I know it's
super basic and oh hey guys
oh gosh Magnus is back he's back but
he's still walking a tightrope how is he
going to survive this one it still looks
super scary the two black knights are
forked now uh the White Queen will snack
on one of the next move the black queen
is also pretty much trapped so for
Magnus you need to be really accurate uh
I don't know if you'll be breathing a
sigh of relief yet he needs to just get
through the next few moves but yeah he
could have won The Rook he could have
trapped that black Rook essentially he's
got the same position now uh alarism but
he's traded off that Rook um so even
though he'll win the piece back
could have been so much more it's a
really weird position of the black queen
though isn't it I mean it just can't get
out the black queen and the black Bishop
next to it so
um I again finding the right move here
is so hard on that subject I mean I
would be desperate to get out and uh
well we see Magnus the fan the night in
the middle Ali Reza is gonna take the
Knight on e4 but then then the black
king becomes quite safe right I mean the
idea of that move is to give the black
king an escape Square then you can
develop your dark Square bishop and all
of a sudden if the black piece starts to
come into the game
um you know you might even take the
initiative at some point have an extra
Pawn Yeah I'm still happy why I say all
that and I say you could take the
initiative and I'm not believing a word
how could black ever take the initiative
in this position I just you know one of
the things though is that uh the Queen
the Queen the queen is a problem though
but I did see that black has the night
Retreat to D7 at some stage and try can
unravel that way
it's amazing that you know the
evaluation part is actually favoring
Magnus though it's really putting some
emphasis on that pawn is figuring that
the worse is over and and it might
actually be that it just assumes he's
he's pretty safe uh one move one move
that was what it was and queen B3 not an
easy move to find and chess is cruel
like that I mean alarisa he did the
right thing he spent time at the right
moment but now he wishes he had all that
time back again uh I mean the five
minutes six minutes he spent on Knight
B5 uh the several minutes he spent on
Rook to D4
um in the end he made one very very good
decision but the clock situation is now
going to haunt him in what's still a
complicated scenario and uh he just
looked like he exhaled there a bit
frustrated the White Queen when she
moves I mean that's going to be met
almost uh definitely by the black king
sidestepping and maybe we'll show that
Simon the black King's gonna be super
safe and uh yeah simply no ongoing
attack no matter where you put this
queen I'm not sure even where you go but
uh the black king is going to hide
safely on F7 suddenly counter-attack The
Black Queen will be uh uh kind of freed
once more and attack would totally
disappear
yeah I mean I I guess if you're white
you you're trying to make you're trying
to keep the initiative going here and uh
I think as you said earlier David you've
got to stay on the bicycle you've got to
keep attacking and uh if you allow black
to move the King get the bishop out
Black's gonna be absolutely fine so
you've got to think of ways to keep the
initiative and a move like F4
played is is the most logical move by a
mile uh but you know uh maybe black can
be the bishop but you know at least this
keeps the initiative going keeps the
game alive very good move by alirez
there yeah he's doing the right thing
he's composed himself but one and a half
minutes I do fear for his chances here
um still in the balance on the board
anything could still happen it's one of
those wild irrational positions but one
and a half minutes against six
it's not ideal and you've got to be
energetic with white and I think it was
the only move to develop your Bishop
because if you fall back with the Knight
that F1 could have perhaps Advanced down
the board even further creating problems
and even the pawn on E6 was pretty weak
as well so but I really like this
counter-attacking move from Magnus
and the queen is now out the queen is
out and it feels as a Magnus has this uh
this ability to not only convert
slightly better positions win-winning
positions flawlessly but also be able to
get out of these messes and just win
worse positions or get an advantage
after being worse out of the opening
again don't know how he does it but this
looked like Ali Reza's comeback game
just a few moves ago
I feel that this is a key game clearly I
mean I I think if Ali razor doesn't uh
win this one it's going to be really
tough right I mean uh because he's going
to look at the game afterwards probably
realize he had a winning position it's
his kind of position as well you know he
got everything he could have wished for
and he just missed that one move it's
easy to do because the movie played for
attempting we we wanted to play that
move Rook D4 it seemed logical but
Magnus is a he's brilliant everything
and he's he's defended kind of perfectly
so far I wouldn't write this game off
though because yeah it's a pawn but you
say the Queen's out of jail I mean the
black queen still still looks pretty
horrendous to me and uh white white has
you know Bishop developing The Rook
coming in the F5 move this this is uh
this is a mess still this position he's
missed his chance but it is a mess and
any result is is still possible here but
I mean I I think he's got to win this
one I just feel that for the match uh is
you know gonna be so important and
Magnus to move
I didn't expect Magnus to play so boldly
like this I was expecting him to
actually try to control White's porn
Advanced F4 F5 as Simon mentioned but
Madness
his nose no fear
it's here he's just opening the H file
and we've criticized him and alarisa for
pushing the H Pawn to H5 this time it's
going further down the board and this
makes a lot of sense actually it's not
necessarily an aggressive move this time
it's just to try and trade off Rooks
trying to eliminate as many pieces from
the board as possible but maybe a threat
at some point of Bishop takes D5 in the
center exploding things open so uh yeah
Magnus still has to be slightly wary but
rook's off the board and now check
mating attack against the black king
less likely
still going to do the same with his
Queen and dark Square Bishop though he
can't really move his Queen unless it
goes to f8 because the bishop drops a
check and uh okay so he's got to move
his Bishop so he can move his Queen and
he might even be going Queen h8 maybe
the black queen will become the best
piece on the ball quite soon he's been a
disaster the whole game but it's it's
getting ready to come out and look at
the time as well farouza has under 20
seconds now he does take control of the
H line making sure Black's Queen doesn't
get too active but Magnus Carlson with
that extra pawn and the initiative can
he take a two-point lead and we're
getting some big big updates with the
results in division two fadociev is out
tatus you have is out of the Julius bear
generation cup which means he was the
only player that could have caught up
with Wesley so Wesley so is the fifth
player to book his spot into the season
and Final in Toronto a huge congrat
congratulations to Wesley that even
though it was a tough day in office he
lost his match he has been knocked out
but with some great performances in the
past events of the Champions Chester he
does go through to the finals the 500
000 final so the pressure is off Wesley
but big pressure in this one yeah want
to line up we're going to be treated to
in Toronto and now only three spots up
for grabs farrugia really will want to
win this tournament I'm not sure he can
Bank it on points and uh this of course
will be a key game so now giving a check
with the White Queen forcing magnus's
King back to the back rank he's trying
to play for some tricks he's only got 11
seconds but look at the white Bishop
what a weird Square to land on uh trying
to eliminate Black's Knight which is a
very good defender of the king
um I like the look of that move but uh
concretely maybe Magnus has a way to
force some exchanges now if you can keep
the black king safe the extra Pawn
should count to how hard is that to do
it's still tricky I mean you can
certainly go wrong here the white pieces
are converging around around that black
king I'd be scared here uh definitely I
mean maybe you can use the knights come
back I mean there might be some other
options here as well and to keep the
position safe but you use that extra
time and that's what Magnus is doing
it's got the time Advantage you might as
well use it right yeah uh the character
was it carrot power he had some carrots
right that's the key thing it's normally
Noodles isn't it Magnus normally loves
his noodles but he was running around
with carrots there do we think it was
carrots
look like carrots pretty healthy snack
very healthy snacks yeah but meanwhile
okay he's snacked on a point he's still
one point up Magnus but okay this move
the evaluation but I didn't approve off
is it possible yeah this was the move I
was thinking about but I was wanted to
do it in a different way I wanted to
give Bishop takes Knight first
and uh then come in with the bishop to
F3
Africa's problem is he has no time he's
just going to play purely on Instinct in
such a wild position and the bar is
teasing us here but it looks like black
has traded off the dark sky Bishops and
the King should therefore be safe and
the reason he has no time is because he
burned it all on that one move that
changed the evaluation completely Rook
D4 is such a big thing there turned out
the move turned out to be the move that
gave Magnus the chance to come back into
the game finally F5 is on the board but
is it going to be enough if black was to
capture White's Bishop jumps into an
attack but the good news for black is
that the Bishop from D7 can also block
the diagonal
yeah Magnus can take on F5
will he do that he's got some tempting
checks the black queen can jump into G1
with a check but white king simply moves
everything is holding at least for now
for for Asia I like this last move at
least he's asking questions of Magnus
Magnus wants to go Queen G1 do you think
peruja will go King A2 trying to invite
a repetition or will he play on for
Knight C1 given the math situation block
that check
yeah I mean you still got a chance if
you draw I mean uh you need to win and
you you know draw a game next but just
to show this uh the queen check the king
could move this would potentially invite
a repetition of moves but uh yeah we're
expecting Magnus not to go for that with
an extra Pawn uh blocking with the
Knight does kind of walk into a self pin
maybe the idea for Magnus is you can
just take another pawn two pawns up and
uh after a Trader pawns here you do hold
everything together just about
I mean slightly risky what Magnus might
be calculating is the move Knight to C5
here or Knight to D4 uh hacking this
bishop so black is two pawns up but
still not with the safest King in the
world
Magnus still with some serious questions
to answer two minutes now against under
10 seconds will he jump in with a check
uh or will he go for tania's move also
looks pretty good to me uh taking this
pawn and then at least a safer move
Bishop to E6 but engine says no you
should get greedy yeah the engines they
they love it and uh I mean this this is
the thing though I mean it's also
something else to learn from this this
position it's a critical position he is
he is obviously doing the Right Moves I
mean that's that's what he does but in a
critical position take your time you
know a lot of people get all their
timings wrong in chess normally you only
get three four moments where you really
have to calculate you really have to
spend your time and Magnus used his time
there he had this position in his mind
and I assume he's worked out that it's
just good for him had he rushed there it
could have gone wrong and uh farouza one
second
but not I picked up that pawn because of
the check and a double attack so the B7
Pawn wasn't on pre comes back with the
Knight now Magnus two pawns up and no
attack on the black king
King is safest houses as they say and
the f and g pawns maybe not yet but
later on we'll decide this game Black's
two extra connected pawns on the king
side and uh it well when it's Magnus
Carson we've said this before it should
just be a cleaning up job here one
second makes a move with just one second
on the clock
is protecting his King and it's actually
White's King but is now going to get
awesome questions and Magnus he knows
which piece trades to make Knight's
Bishop I've left the board yeah but
there's no attack for alireza and
instead he's just material down
the bishop looks terrible as well at the
moment I mean he that Bishop is only
attacking the pawn that's defended by a
knight and the Knight Dodges all the
checks as well blocks all the checks and
I think you can just start pushing the
the f and g Pawn now I don't see any
reason why not so okay Ali Razer is
trying to get the bishop out to a more
active square but it's very loose as
well that Bishop can you not attack that
Bishop probably yeah win another Pawn
okay yeah I mean two two's enough two's
enough Pawn Grabber
calm down calm down
three is better than two can I queen a
pawn win the game or or win a pawn I'll
go for the pawn please when is the win
Simon however it is indeed we've all got
different ways of doing it and uh here
they come though coming down the board
and we often think of knights as being
these aggressive attackers but they're
also such good Defenders taking away key
squares for check and that one night on
E7 just gets the job done for black
white is hoping to get the queen into
activity trying to threaten some checks
get that Queen to be it attack that B7
Pawn but it looks like black and just
return with the queen and or even push
his Pawn again Knight a key Defender for
black skin it's amazing how good that
Knight is I mean if you put your King on
E6 in front of the Knight the queen
can't check it it's it's such a good
Defender and uh I I love how you know
pieces are used like this is very very
pretty you know what they say Simon a
dog is a man's best friend but a knight
is a king's best friend the Knight just
it is yeah very nice there it was the
one that coin yeah
the problem is the black king yeah you
always just hide behind the night if the
White Queen checks from one side you
hide the other side the White Queen has
to take two or three moves you kind of
go around again and meanwhile the black
porn start advancing this is just
one-way traffic look at that white
Bishop that poor poor piece uh just
can't get any joy in this game at all
how the black screen from B8 having no
squares at all get to this position
being on D4 dominating White's position
and white skin being the one that's in
trouble when black couldn't even Castle
it was this game yeah
The Game of Life Tanya you know when
you're playing against Magnus you know
you have a good position you have that
one chance and somehow you don't take it
and Magnus is just Relentless look at
him he's taking everything now he's
trying to check back now yeah so a bit
greedy you know trying to check mate as
well what else does he want I mean he
has allowed us some checks this is a bit
strange while he's walking into the
center of the board and no nerves at all
from Magnus Carlson yeah his pieces are
so well centralized and the pawns I mean
he's going to be able to block these
checks somehow does he go up F4 as well
or does he March forward with the King
inviting more checks okay keep walking
as well because the other one gives up a
pawn and we never give up no wow not if
we don't have to
and wow it's gonna zigzag back the black
king possibly and hide on some dark
squares the problem is White's just
playing with the queen alone and the
bishop is not contributing here we go
the black king can even go back to G5 no
more checks and that will signal at the
end
yep and it is the end uh Ali Reza faruja
resigns Magnus Carlsen making it look
easy today game one was full domination
game two he was in trouble but alireza
feruja not being precise in that
critical moment and then once again
Magnus taking the driver's seat and not
letting it get out of hand which means
that alireza has to win the next game on
demand it could be a three-game match
Magnus needs only a draw to take this
away uh David this one was an up and
down battle and it could have been for
Russia's game that's right it was so
close for Russia was one accurate move
away from securing a decisive Advantage
but in the end this game did turn on
that knife edge and it was this critical
position where he's just given a check
forcing the black king out to E7 and
here he did play the move Rook to D4 we
saw Rook trade and eventually Magnus
convert his extra material but if
instead ferja had found another attack
another hit on this black Rook he would
surely have won the game Queen to be E3
was the killer The Rook has no good
squares to go to for example if it
Retreats then at the very least white
can start to cash in this is a nasty
check hitting the king hitting the
knights next move as well he could start
to gobble up the rook in the corner
instead of finding this unfortunately he
traded Rooks lost the momentum and we
saw the result
when you're playing against Magnus
Carlsen you have to beat him on every
single move until you get that win in
and we saw that big turnaround which
means Magnus with a two-point lead Ali
Raza farusha has to win the next game
otherwise it is match over alireza will
go down to the losers bracket a big game
three for the 20 year old is coming up
and we will be back with the Julius bear
generation Cup in just a few
[Music]
yes yes
why to play and drop
oh but this this I'm pretty sure I've
seen
this looks so familiar
so he has to go to either H2 H3
I haven't been able to decide this one
but my 10 seconds pass fast yes yes yes
my feeling would be
definitely not H2 because H2 then maybe
e one night
yes so I have to go to H3 H3 Knight F4
PH2 my G4 Chuck G punch back then kh1
Knight F2 check
kh2 E1 Knights and Knight F3 Knight F3
King G3 yes very nice very good
I know this one I'm just trying to
remember
so it's when the three nines get this so
King H3 Knight F4 Knight or uh
King H2 Knight G4 Chuck Knight G4 King
H1
nice negative 39 freaking G3 right guys
now King E3 the stairway yeah very good
um okay let's
start with King H2
kind of have to I guess
um H2O would probably go E1 Knight
oh is this kh3 enough E1 light then
Knight F3
well yes but English three I will go
Knight F4
okay now I have to go to H2 Knight G4
okay now I have to go to H1 Knight F2
okay engage two E1 light
and uh
it's not into it
oh Knight F3 Knight of flicking G3 yeah
yeah Knight F3 Knight takes a three King
G3 very nice
I knew this one I was just trying to
remember the whole detail look you're
the only one that's uh remaining perfect
after
five studies last one
yeah I've seen this one okay this one I
think I've seen before Queen G7 look at
seven Knight six yes
but what's the uh what's the puzzle way
to move
because you you save the simplest one
for last one this this is
yes yes
wow
how did you get in there
so Queen G7 okay seven Knight P6 made
yeah yes that's it we saved the easiest
or less
thank you
foreign
Magnus Carlsen seems just Invincible
with his recent World Cup victory he's
already also won two events in the
Champions Chester is looking for this
hat-trick he plays and he wins how does
his mind work and how is he able to be
so good his chest looks like it is from
another planet take a look at what
Henrik Carlson his father had to say
about Magnus the workings of his mind
when he was just a kid
in fact there's an interesting episode
from GAO style when mine is just had
turned nine he was playing a tournament
up there and we played in this same
group not in the International
Tournament but uh
kind of the B tournament and I had
beaten him in our
encounter that's the only time in a
classical game
and we were analyzing and I was showing
him something with the patterns and the
opposite called the Bishops and then
this master player came over and said no
that's not right it's the other way
around
and I thought ah okay so that's not the
first time I'm saying something
I literally don't know anything about
but it's going to be the last time
something that I heard I think in 2004
was that Magnus had declined to work
with Gary Kasparov I still remember the
shock that I felt and I thought wow
you know how can a child refuse that and
then I thought hang on a second this
takes guts this takes confidence so I
mean what was the strategy for
developing Magnus as a player
well basically this is in line with the
uh what I introduced
about uh letting him be in charge of the
process and trying to to kind of guard
him from from uh people around who
wanted to influence him be because I
told people already when he was 10 11 12
Etc no no it's it's just a hobby he's he
is having fun uh I'll support him but
he'll decide because already when he was
12 or 13 people start saying well what
if he wants to stop yeah then he'll stop
playing chess what advice would you give
other parents to encourage the love of
Chess to their children would you give
them any specific tips no it's rather
than the avoid the detailed
[Music]
formulas or or paths because
I think the passion and the Curiosity
that's the only only important thing
basically that everything else is is
secondary like and you can take a lot of
the advice you get and also turn it
around like people say well you have to
study a week areas but that's you could
also say no you should study your strong
points because that's what you're
interested in and then you just start to
expand from from that basically so there
are always parallel IDs and I think the
the youth or the kid has to find his or
her own way
although of course this presupposes a
lot of
enthusiasm for the game itself
if a child is mainly occupied with the
result
that's not the same long-term Drive I
think as as a loving
Secrets or chests itself yes and that
was the mesmerized Magnus early on and
kept his interests that deep and intense
I think
I'm Rick Olson sharing his insights on
what made a Magnus Carlsen what he is
today and yovi you were there doing that
interview that felt so special and some
of his Stakes over there and what he
said about at a young age Magnus sort of
refusing that influence not many people
have the ability to do that yeah I know
and he was quite adamant that it was
very much all about the letting the
child decide on the process and he was
just simply going to enable it to happen
and I I found it quite actually
inspirational that he would give that
power and that confidence to someone as
young as a Magnus was at that time and
just had full trust in that process I
really do recommend like listening to
Henrik if you do have a child that is
super into chess and just uh taking heed
of what Henrik says because it is very
well thought out
and do you think that kind of upbringing
is what we see today as well in Magnus
taking these big decisions what he feels
is right and what he needs to do we see
him do that even now whether it's not
playing the world championship match uh
well all the decisions that he takes
yeah it's right to see such a kind of
responsibility thrown on such a young
player and it's definitely kind of grown
into this autonomy that Magnus has I
mean throwing out all these different
openings like you say on a grander scale
choosing which tournaments to play
knowing himself knowing his strengths
weaknesses knowing his body his energy
levels uh everything and uh yeah so it's
a lot for any Sportsman but this handles
it well and he looks very happy and very
relaxed right now both of them are
sipping the water at the same time for
alireza he knows what he needs to do
there's only one way out he needs to win
the next game to keep the match uh going
Magnus looks like he's having a good
time today Simon he looks a lot more
relaxed than what we saw yesterday yeah
he was clearly quite tired yesterday and
he he's more chilled out today
um and the games have been really
exciting and we've got a French defense
as well now so another interesting
opening and I remember Magnus actually
saying that if he needed to win with the
black pieces against E4 then he'd
probably played a French defense and
this was in the last year or so there's
an opening that hasn't been completely
worked out and often goes to a dynamic
position so uh yeah but wait one second
doesn't white have like the French
killer yeah
do it I don't think he will I think he's
having too much fun to do it I think if
he wants to win the match he could but I
think before
he won't do it he won't do it
he's really enjoying himself today and
he's actually playing like really sharp
positions and maybe it goes back to that
interview he's not necessarily even
trying to play the best at openings he's
playing Just openings which are going to
lead to fun games which is great for us
yeah I think he was just fighting his
inner conscience there Magnus yeah I
think he was very tempted to play The
Exchange variation just trading off
pawns going symmetrical going for the
draw but he's aware of the fans Magnus
is very aware of what people want to see
but also he loves entertaining himself
loves chess he did it yesterday against
Fabiano he didn't shut down the game
immediately and okay if that led to some
drama but
um yeah this one I'm glad to see it
Mainline classical variation of the
French right now I I remember being in a
similar situation a few years ago I was
commentating with Simon and we were
following David's game in Gibraltar and
it was the same thing and we were like
whoa we're getting ready for some Knight
C3 some Knight D2 and then David Goes
Pawn takes Sport and we were like well
we're gonna move on yeah I miss my
beautiful win no we did we then caught
up and we had to kind of go oh very good
David actually it was a really good game
thank you comment I came out following
it it was uh yeah tailored gets the
opponent for the situation and sometimes
the exchange variation isn't always
played with a draw in mind uh but Magnus
yeah he's gone for something much more
ambitious here he's got extra space look
at White's Pawn structure in the center
you have that kind of uh Trio that
triangle of Pawns on the dark squares
and uh farouza I haven't really seen him
employ this variation too much whereas
Magnus I've seen him on both the white
and black side of this position so maybe
slightly more experience here will this
be the third time that we'll see a queen
side castling wow any chances of that
happening it's actually a blunder here
I've played this position many times
black and uh study it a lot but castle
and queen side it was first played in
morsevich versus uh sheer off I think in
this position and uh it's actually a big
blunder because black can now play C4
and change the nature of the position
and you've got the B Pawn ready to run
down the board and basically the attack
here is just ready made You're Gonna Go
B4 C3 Checkmate and uh it's you know
it's really really hard uh to to have
any yes you can't you can't Castle in
this position so you've got to be quite
subtle about it and I I expect uh the
main line now yeah is is to Castle
kingside because all these ideas are
casting Queen side it gives black loads
of compensation so Bishop D3 is is one
of the more modern approaches to this
where you just want a castle kingside
you can often move your knight on C3
away so you can try to put a pawn there
as well uh Knight D1 as a common idea so
you can try to swap that with a pawn and
I think David said The Connect Four you
get the Connect Four then Connect Four
pawns
um but uh yeah this this kind of stuff's
uh an idea but it's castling King so
it's a bit annoying for players of the
black side because I've had this and I'm
like yeah come on Castle Queen side
let's have some fun and then they decide
to Castle King sign it's like uh okay
all right we have to play this position
still very interesting
um and I'm trying to remember the main
line I think it might be B6 or something
like that so you can move the F Pawn so
yeah yeah
yeah I I so you want to move the F Pawn
but uh you've got to defend your C Pawn
First and this move well I'm not sure
about this if you need to win you're
closing it down a lot maybe Magnus will
Castle queenside now
maybe that's what he's hoping for if you
say black has gotten what is that a
connect six going on right now and it's
not always good to get a Connect Four
you know not always we're you know and
the problem here is like in the French
you you especially in a must win
scenario you you have these ways of
opening up the position and as soon as
white push it sorry black pushes that
pawn he can't do that anymore but Magnus
now playing a very standard idea showing
that he can open up the position and uh
I don't C4 is not supposed to be a very
good move and it's uh I don't like it
yeah you need the tangent and the Santa
to be there because when the Santa is
closed that's when all the action
happens on this edges of the board and
that's why we can see Magnus push
forward with the F5 pawn and his big
idea is simply to capture the pawn one
takes pawn and then just leave that
Bishop on C8 completely bad
yeah and uh the dynamic uh justification
of this is Pawn takes porn is simply met
by the capture and suddenly Black's Pawn
formation the beautiful Connect Four
it's just collapsed it's all Fallen
apart this Knight will move out the way
and white will start advancing the Deep
Pawn the e-pawn and everything uh so F5
very opportunistic but uh very strong
potentially he's just getting ready to
take as see Michael mentions maybe even
castle and there's an open F line look
at where the black king is situated as
well it needs to evacuate as quickly as
possible this opening has not gone well
for for Asia uh objectively but at least
it's still tense and still all the
pieces on the board
so in terms of maybe long term if you
can stay alive
uh yeah still at least uh yeah chances
I'm trying to be optimistic here I want
to see a fight I want to see game four I
love the way you're trying to say it but
actually in your voice you can hear that
you don't really mean it as much you can
tell I don't play the French defense I
couldn't yeah I mean have you ever been
I mean the French threat is very
exciting opening I mean we have the Caro
Queen here um and it's quite similar to
the Kara Khan and uh David the like E5
King I don't actually know what you play
Tanya are you a sicilian or uh Sicilian
Okay so we've got quite a wide mix of uh
we cover all bases here at least but I
love playing against the French most he
doesn't most people do yeah good point
yeah it's always around this light Squad
Bishop that black has it just feels like
the pieces are not in the game and so
it's been surprising to see alireza go
for this opening given the math
situation and then blocking down the
center and earlier on I saw this feature
chat which said Godfather talking about
Hendrick and his uh his just his
contribution to magnus's Career I've
often noticed uh he's always there at
Thomas moments at World Championships
and Magnus Family Support has been so
crucial and critical yeah I think that's
a theme around all top players and maybe
at kind of across all sports uh family
or at least a great support network is
key I mean talking about fruition he has
a family as well who've really supported
him uh helped him move to France and uh
really kind of pushed him in his career
and it's paid off if you think of other
top players as well you see the young
Indian players now pregnant and his mum
has gone viral recently uh on Twitter uh
just supporting her son throughout his
fantastic World Cup run and it's the
same for all the top players I feel it's
incidentally you know David and I did
commentary on Norway chess and a lot of
the players brought their parents with
them
I was just commentating I brought mine I
wonder if that's the one thing you know
having that support system having that
one parent that hasn't changed over the
generations because even where she talks
about how his mom played a big big role
in his career and I think it was for
Gary as well uh so I wonder if that's
the one thing that's a constant family
I think it is yeah we see a bit of
action happening on the board but before
we get there I I mean I used to coach a
lot a lot of junior tournaments as well
and uh it's actually the really pushy
parents which are the worst ones it's
not the kids which are bad it's some of
the parents so it's so important to have
supportive parents that don't you know
are not too forcing shall we say and you
can see that with Henrik you can see
that I think with prague's Mom they're
there supporting doing the best for for
their kids and I'm sure with Ali
raiser's parents as well but I've I've
seen some horrible things like
eight-year-olds being shouted out when
they lose a game of chess in front of
loads of people and it's like oh my God
you know you want to say something but
you know it's very hard to and those
kids always give up you know because the
pressure's too much so you've got to
you're gonna have the you've got the
Fine Line uh of it and I'm sure we all
had that here I'm sure we had all had
really supportive parents there you go
and I bet they didn't shout you when you
lost a bit they encouraged you and uh
you know gave you the support that you
need so yeah no you're absolutely right
and that pressure it can really get to
the child it's just a burnout you you
don't end up growing as a player and
yeah it is definitely sad to see but I
think for all these great players as
you're saying David that's the one thing
that we see all across uh that they've
got this support system that lets them
sort of just blossom into the best
players and it's not just a support
system I I also wanted to add that for
hanrich it was also very important that
Magnus was in a good mood and so just
before going into tournaments they would
plan out their jokes they would plan out
topics just to get Magnus in the right
frame of mind wow and I was really taken
aback by that but then of course when
you think about it it makes perfect
sense and it's no coincidence that in
Norway chess where everyone well not
everyone but a lot of people had pla had
their parents with them there was a lot
of good mood everyone was really happy
and it just felt like this is how chess
should be played well relaxed and
enjoyable for everyone you play your
best just when you're in your good mood
I noticed that at the 2021 world
championship and I think this is a team
in World Championships where players
come in with their seconds with their
trainers with other chess players but
Magnus had this whole team but they were
all friends and family which is such a
different approach from uh from what we
normally see so definitely something
that's played a big big role in becoming
the best chess plan we see that across I
think Generations as well meanwhile
action is on alibraza putting on the
fight on the queen side but will the
game get into trouble will his King come
into fire yeah the problem is no matter
how active alireza is on the queen side
no matter how many pawns he pushes over
there actually the action's taking part
uh taking place on the other side of the
board and on the other flank it's
clearly Magnus in the ascendancy and I
think we just have to jump in firstly to
show what's just happened but uh also to
kind of outline why white is doing so
well and if we be traced back to this
moment the pawn break forward I think
maybe alarisa might live to regret this
decision taking with the pawn rather
than at least slightly freeing his uh
French defense Bishop I think any french
defense player wants to activate this
piece uh he took with a pawn and after
both sides castled maybe the black king
isn't actually safe on this side of the
board there are no Knights look at this
around the black king
so any attack might just be brutal we
saw how vital Defenders Knights can be
in the previous game so now Bishop to G4
attacking this point the base of the
black pawn chain always the base is the
weakest of any structure and after B4
I'm expecting either the Knight to just
Retreat or maybe a trade of Rooks first
maybe Magnus is calculating whether he
can cash in on the E6 Square yeah he
just drops back very logical move and
not just is uh this Knight attacking the
pawn the bishop attacking the pawn but
watch out for later the night joining
the fun and ganging up on this poor
backward E6 Pawn
French porn it's a very sad position for
black this unfortunately I feel White's
also going to get the open f file as
well at any moment white can swap Rooks
and put the other Rook on the f file and
you know black maybe has some chances on
the queen side later on if you can make
a break over there that's Black's one
chance but he's got to try to
distinguish magnus's initiative over on
the king side here E6 is very weak and
that that's the first problem you have
to deal with here not easy to do no not
easy to do and on top of that the Knight
isn't actually obliged to go to the F4
Square either it can jump to G3 and
support a piece landing on the H5 Square
yeah just all the pieces flooding note
how they're just kind of uh heading
towards the king side that's where
they're gravitating and blacks pieces
because the board is closed and kind of
cut in half by this kind of Pawn
formation blacks pieces are stranded on
the queen side so I think some drastic
action might be needed I'm not sure
whether it's something to do with Pawn
to C3 jumping in the Black Knight to C4
but
it feels like you're just not quick
enough not active enough
as black and I wouldn't be surprised if
he goes into a long thing now I think
that might be required he needs
something a bit special to keep this
game alive to keep his winning chances
afloat quite like you'll see free move I
mean uh in a bad situation you might as
well try to mix it up uh I I figure in
general and at least that gives some
chances okay he's making the exchange on
F1 first and he's playing it I mean I
think this is this is also in early
Razor's style he he wants to keep it
sharp he wants to get some kind of
initiative and get his Bishop to A6
never gonna happen then uh yeah it's
just never gonna happen is it okay has
this helped oh I don't know I'm looking
at the bar there but has this helped at
all I mean there are some tactics in the
air here the computer says the white is
pretty much winning now but black does
have a serious threat if the Black
Knight on B6 jumps into C4 hitting the
White Queen hitting the bishop on E3
then suddenly White's pieces start to
collapse and there's some serious
pressure look at the black queen eyeing
up two white pieces but what is the
winning move why is the engine suddenly
so excited alirez has missed something
it's not obvious though immediately to
the human eye I'm wondering if Knight F4
tactics work in this position as a
computer move if not Queen D3 seems like
a relatively safe second option I know
it doesn't because you and she might
lose a piece there so maybe it has been
I can't see Knight F4 wow we're getting
given a hint here Simon uh thank you to
the computer Gods yeah 923 not obviously
wow I was trying to work it out but it's
incredibly complicated because you know
the White Queen is gonna get hit and I
was trying to figure out Prague style
because one of the things with common
commentary is that when you comment on
the games with certain players you kind
of you are drawn to the counter attacks
because that's their trademark so I was
like well maybe you can counter-attack
the queen
um with Bishop
H5 wow Bishop to H five nope that would
lose okay so that's not the move I think
the problem is maybe after the queen has
captured The Rook is also hanging uh on
F1 I mean this is so difficult I would
probably stop my calculation here
thinking okay two pieces are attacked if
you move the White Queen then the bishop
disappears but I think now your idea
Ivanka uh Bishop to H5 would be winning
because the White Queen would be
swooping in uh to F7 this is really
difficult for a human to spot uh Magnus
plays a far more natural move uh he
plays the move H4 could never be wrong
right Simon and uh he's just backing up
his Knight we've seen it go wrong a
little bit today but uh I was gonna say
a normal human would never find that but
Magnus is the goat so I kind of expected
uh him to play Knight G3 there but H4 is
just a good move isn't it defend
everything
um maybe give yourself chances to harass
the queen with H5 which is a big move
and uh it's uh Knight F4 is also a
threat so that's a really multi-purpose
uh idea H4 and also very dangerous and
black yeah it just looks like Black's
gonna end up losing that French Pawn
that E6 Pawn Knight F4 I don't really
see a way for black to fight it and if
the E6 Pawn Falls then the position
falls apart it's
this could be just a 3-0 Victory right
now for Magnus
that's looking uh that way and first on
the camera doesn't look too happy uh
he'll still be calculating and but
unfortunately it's just the fact that
he's playing without two pieces you look
at the black Bishop the French Bishop
that we talk about still stuck on C8 on
the light squares there Black's Rook
stuck behind it you're always at least
one or two moves uh away and we've
talked about it before somehow Magnus
every game especially his two white
games he's got all of his pieces
coordinating protecting each other all
really centralized all active and no
surprise that the tactics work in
White's favor here
uh yeah no matter what trades black goes
for still Advantage weight just have to
compare every piece that Magnus has to
Black pieces right now just everything
on White's Camp is playing and doing a
job if Knight F4 is such a big threat it
to me the first thing that would come to
mind is try and trade trying to trade
off pieces so that you can neutralize
the pressure a little bit could that be
something that helps black at all
software 93 maybe oh makes sense yeah I
like the idea trade this one maybe as
well
Magnus needs to only draw right and I
thought here white is actually
threatening my OG idea which is put the
Knight on G3 and Bishop comes to age
five Queen E4 can you try it out yeah I
don't like it but I mean uh we have to
is that a move yes oh okay and
I'll let you do Bishop D7
just for the crack so background
Checkmate I said back spanker indeed do
your puzzle Rush everyone this uh is not
how the game's gonna end but it is
definitely a theme in the position and
the problem is as well not just that you
might have to trade off all your active
pieces here as black just to survive but
you are a pawn down too uh so yeah hard
times for Russia is black it's never
easy when you need to win he's only made
these kind of uncompromising decisions
because he is in that muscle in
situation but yeah isn't going to work
out that's the problem with that last
game I mean even if he'd managed to draw
that last game he could have uh played
in a lot safer way here trying to rely
on the win in game four and I think
losing the first two games against
Magnus we saw Fabiano somehow managed to
nearly come back yesterday but uh it's
it's nearly impossible against Magnus
he's just too good and um okay we'll see
Ali Razer taking a pawn there look at
those pieces they're flooding there's an
idea right you can go Bishop take no you
can't well I was I mean
Bishop takes Knight trying to do a
little trick on E3 I know but it doesn't
really work there's a bit of a back
spanker here as well so it looks clever
you're giving up the black queen it
looks like you're counter-attacking
winning the White Queen but after the
White Queen gives herself up
unfortunately the sting in the tail is
this Checkmate and uh ignore the bath
that's because it is I panic there for a
second and the black king would again be
caught uh in the crossfire but instead
okay Queen to H6 it looks like you've
lined up perfectly for white pieces to
hit you uh in the corner here but what
is the killer blow this is attacked
three times you can take it with this
night this night or with the bishop one
of them looks strong I'm not sure which
one I want it to be Knight F7 because
that's like the Fabiano game it's not
it's not night I've said I'm sure but I
want it to be Knight F7 just to have two
two great attacking games of that move
working but this I mean you just got to
calculate carefully here I mean taking
on E6 it is
this seems good doesn't it with with
something seems good maybe this way just
so you have this Pawn uh hit next move
it's just collapsing for black no matter
what you try here you can trade off one
Bishop but uh this isn't going to help
you at all next move at the very minimum
this is threatened the pawn Center has
collapsed and Magnus has indeed gone for
that move it looks like we're in the
closing stages now of this knockout
match
es Carlson with the dominating
performance so far but for alireza I
think knowing that he had this big shot
in game two it's a very difficult
situation to come out of psychologically
as well and you have to play black and a
must-win situation you tend to take
these decisions that you normally
wouldn't otherwise and it's all gone
wrong the H4 Pawn has been picked up the
D5 bond has been picked up and it's
beautiful tactics again the back crank
the back rank is there do you know do
you know what I think black should do
now
or allow the nice Checkmate to happen on
the board and David we've got to show it
aren't we this Checkmate and it's a
reoccurring theme time and time again
here yeah it keeps happening now if the
queen takes this bishop it's not a free
piece because once the defender is
eliminated and Knight takes Bishop with
a check black recaptures again it's uh
yeah that move yet again rooked f8
catching the King this is Checkmate and
it would end the game if you can't take
this bishop unfortunately with black
then you're just two pawns down and
facing a ongoing assault against the
black king
a very tough position for alireza Magnus
with his unique abilities you just have
all his pieces at the right squares to
execute an attack and finish the game I
don't know how he does it but it seems
to happen time and time again but it was
game two where alireza almost made a
comeback uh really that was a fantastic
performance in the opening but just one
inaccuracy and that's all that the world
number one needs and that went downhill
and this game also never got going
Knight takes D5 on the board alireza
having a think touching the three and a
half minute Mark we're on move 23 this
might be over in the next couple of
moves on the 25 might be
looks likely at this point and yeah it
just doesn't represent the the match
this potential score line of three nil
or three zero it's just that one move
one move could have changed everything
we could be seeing this game uh I mean
it would have been a different opening
it would have been everything different
we could have seen this go to Armageddon
this match and uh more chess instead
one-sided scoreline just one move that's
how difficult it is at top level if
you're not sharp and just a few kind of
miscalculate just once until he says
punish you thing is we say that time and
time again when we're watching magnus's
matches don't we it's the same yesterday
it was like one move his opponent missed
one chance and you only seem to get one
chance in a match against Magnus and you
must take it you know and uh
um you know he does give these chances
away occasionally it is rapid but you
don't get more than one chance it seems
against actually Sims per match Magnus
has given his opponents one chance
yeah it's like that Eminem song One Shot
One opportunity exactly yeah just use
every Magnus You Ever Wanted
yeah Bishop D7 okay he's defending for
credit to him for finding a move to
survive uh he has cleared the eighth
rank so that Blackrock in the corner
guards against that recurring Checkmate
theme
but now all white needs to do I mean
save your Bishop on G4 and 2 Pawn
Advantage still with that attack not
sure how we do it uh we can move that
Bishop we can bring the Rook up to F4 to
defend
lots of choice again
yeah I like Rook F4 because it's kind of
aggressive move opening up some tactics
but and maybe there's some other options
there as well I mean uh
yeah I mean um farusha is not out we
have to remind everyone he has a second
chance so we could even see this match
again and I think he I think his
openings are just not really works the
days and it was that last game wasn't it
it was just you know he he missed his
chance there in a very complicated
position but he hasn't played too badly
it's just uh bad openings and magmas
playing really well yeah yeah
happens it was just an openly disasting
game one game two was the makings of a
brilliancy which you just missed that
one move and that was it turned the
whole game around and this one I don't
really count because this is just
determined by the match situation yeah
completely influenced by what we saw in
game two taking these extra risks and uh
the decisions on the board but this is a
difficult one but Simon you're
absolutely right that we might even be
seeing this rematch in the Grand Final
because alireza furuja will go down to
the elimination bracket where he will
fight against the winner of not the back
of the satrov and Dennis lazovic for
that spot into the Grand Final so it's
far from over for alireza it has been a
difficult game so far any hope Magnus
has taken the decision to move the
bishop to F5 Rook to F4 is a big threat
on the board the Queen doesn't have too
many squares yeah the black queen looks
really really active but she might well
be trapped first you need something
active now
I'm struggling there's also a big threat
of Knight takes bishop and then the
bishop swooping in as well
yeah that's a massive seven Queen E7
yeah Bishop G5 you've got Knight C7
after that as well so it's uh horrendous
um position could black throw in I'm
thinking of trying to evade your threat
there Ivanka Bishop to A3 just a scary
move I'm not sure it does too much
attacking the White Queen
but at least it's the type of move that
would force Magnus to think at least
it's slightly scary the White Queen now
she might lose coordination with her
Bishop which is slightly loose
um the evaluation Bar says okay White's
just winning but that's at least what I
would be looking for
um I'm not sure what else it's a
resource it's a it's a good resource
with a direct threat and not so easy to
counter Bishop A3 you pointed it out
though
what's the move forward here David yeah
I mean the first move that came to my
mind because I'm an old man and I don't
want to lose pieces don't want to
calculate too much is to play Queen E1
but already the evaluation bar would
drop down uh the reason is I want to
Simply protect my Bishop I want to get
Queens off the board but suddenly
um after this trade maybe uh after a
capture here the white porn Center
slightly vulnerable uh at least it black
never has to worry about checkmates
anymore still good for white of course
uh down material her for black but worth
a shot yeah
under the minutes
you need to make a move and he needs to
make it fast Bishop F5 on the board
what is he thinking about if not Alex
he's played Bishop A3 but he took quite
a bit of time before making this
decision so Magnus Carlsen can't go safe
with Queen E1 are there any other
attacking idea and he does it David
knows Magnus they do well and the Queens
are off the board no checkmates uh at
least not for now but white still with
this extra Pawn the two Pawn combo in
the center I thought it's two points up
I forgot black captured on H4 a bit
earlier but now this kind of massive
pieces that we see uh in the center this
tension unfortunately for fuja it's hard
to deal with uh White's Pieces Just
coordinates so well with their pawns and
okay just Rook to B8 looks like a pseudo
active move trying to maybe uh come into
the white position with that Rook later
on the open file how can Magnus
start to unravel here still some work to
be done is there a knight G7 I was gonna
suggest that one I think maybe yeah I
see a material I grab material yeah we
love wrapping I mean they might there's
loads of tempting moves there as well
isn't there I mean uh yeah it is it's a
pawn grab isn't it that one so and quite
a simple little tactic there really I
mean one of the only problems was that
that pin was a little bit annoying on
the night so you don't just win a pawn
but you actually get out of uh the
trouble with a pin you give yourself the
X F6 Square for the other night uh so
um uh it also yeah it just opens up the
black king in general as well as winning
a pawn so that that that looks like a
pretty pretty juicy way of doing it
actually on the board yeah two pawns up
now for Magnus Carlson
I think this one was missed by it for
Asia unfortunately but again it's just
tactics working in White's favor because
he has the better coordination the
better centralization
and this could spell the end
yeah 10 seconds
he needs to make a movie oh four seconds
one second okay it takes the night he
takes it with how much time did he have
on the clock because it's a three
seconds barely any time oh wow Magnus is
just saying okay I'm gonna just have the
draw in hand in case I need it right is
that you know
that's actually a really safety first
idea from Magnus I mean he played this
really quickly but I mean uh because
remember it's enough he only draws the
same as a win right so but I mean okay
he loses he's lost a lot of his
Advantage Magnus from doing this and
black does have the air Pawn I mean
future is gonna play this out it isn't
oh not no but the key might be checked
me into a mating net is going to get
caged P4 or G4
and now he's because he has to go H5 the
problem is if he went the other way I
think it's at least a Perpetual check
right for white so you have to in a
must-win situation try this way one
second for further again if you made it
under one second only stop the Jack only
way to stop the Perpetual oh Rook H5 was
a Checkmate now the E Pawn is running
through blacks Rook is too far offside
and ferricia leans back yeah in
disappointment he's gonna resign he does
it
resigns Magnus Carlsen wrapping it up in
three games it has been a disappointing
day for alireza but he had his big
moment in game two and he could have
made that big comeback but that one
movement has cost him the match game
three again felt like a Magnus
Masterpiece David it was a Magnus
Masterpiece and uh he simply controlled
that game from start to finish it was
here though where he really secured the
victory he played Knight takes G7 as we
pointed out winning a second Pawn not
only opening up an attack against this
loose undefended black piece but uh
snatching a pawn in the process and just
to show how he closed it out how he took
all the risk out of the position after
the king took the Knight we saw Bishop
takes bishop and this Knight trade
ensured that with opposite color Bishops
there was nothing to be done just to
show the final Checkmate as well uh here
Rook takes H7 was catching the king in a
net only moved to prevent this bishop to
H6 was met by the simple E6 a queen
about to appear on the board and Magnus
is through real
Magnus is true he will get arrested
tomorrow before the Grand Final but he's
got that spot into the grand final of
the Julius bear generation cup and with
that also confirms his spot into the
next championship store division one and
these are the brackets Fusia will play
against the winner of not a back versus
Dennis lazowick to fight for that spot
to challenge Magnus in the Grand Final
it is going to be a big day after us and
we are being joined by Magnus Magnus
congratulations
thank you
Magnus you were not happy with your play
against Fabi you wrapped it up in just
three games today are you happier with
the way things went
yeah I'm pretty happy with my play today
um obviously I played uh way too riskly
in the opening in game two and I could
have could have been lost there but I
think the way that I handled the game
after was pretty good so yeah without
overall say that um
we played three very complicated games
and um
I feel like I handle them really well
yeah it was uh it felt like uh quite a
dominating performance especially with
the white pieces and you mentioned game
two that was alireza's big shot at
making the comeback Magnus what happened
when you played H5
well I knew that B5 was the move and I
couldn't really remember the lines so I
thought
um
how about H5 and then I was looking a
little bit at Knight B5 and I thought
uh
uh you know it looks very interesting so
I thought maybe I'm losing
but anyway
um
it looked it looked really interesting
uh so
I think it's probably like a bit too too
risky but
it worked out pretty well
and Magnus wall in the winners final
experience prevailed with you winning uh
in our losers bracket I don't know if
you were following the action but Sabi
and Wesley have been knocked out did you
follow the matches there
yeah I followed it
um a bit um obviously Fabi had every
chance to to win this match
well residents seem to have many chances
like
he continued kind of in the same vein as
in in the world cup that he was
surviving surviving and then suddenly
um
suddenly there was one one chance to to
too too much so yeah it's just me
against the kids now
it is you against the stick then you
will get arrested uh tomorrow Magnus
while they will fight it out for a spot
against you and you have an interesting
question that I want to bring up from
our chat it's from Muhammad one CR7 and
the question is did you miss Hikaru in
this event
I didn't really think about
I feel like I played pretty soon
stronger than the last
last couple of
um of games but um yeah I mean in
general
um in all these formats it's been
um it's been like among the very
among the very best probably probably
the second best player in the world so
um obviously any any events any event
that he doesn't blame he's slightly
slightly weaker
and the Magnus this is the generation
cup and you mentioned it's you against
the kits now which of the three
remaining kids would you rather face in
the Grand Final
it will be fun to play alireza again
maybe we'll have um three sharp or three
or four sharp games again will be will
be great but yeah I'm happy to be in the
finals so regardless of for my play I'm
um I'm happy
it's going to be exciting to watch who
makes it through that Magnus we just
have a couple more questions from our
feature chat and it's the next one's
from Mr Gil golon sorry if I'm
butchering the name and he wants to know
that what do you say to yourself when
trying to defend a difficult position
depends on
Amazon
worst position then
well
it's very hard to say though because
there are different techniques like the
two main techniques are one just trying
to
um trying to to hold and the second is
trying to hold by creating counter play
and like knowing which one to use where
is kind of the key to defensive
techniques
um if you're talking about the position
I had in game two today
um well first of all I didn't know that
it was losing so that that helped even
though I did suspect that it was was a
pretty uh pretty bad position
um but yeah I was just trying to trying
to hold on play as well as I I could the
position was so complicated that
especially especially in such a Time
control like
blue things it's not really
I don't know it's not really a thing
um it's just a complicated position that
um you try to do your best thing
I've seen this so many times Magnus you
not only have this incredible ability to
convert winning positions almost
flawlessly uh but also be able to turn
around and win worse positions how do
you do it how do you do it better than
others
I don't think I do though I think there
are others uh who are much better at
um getting out of worse positions than I
am
um so um I think there are even stats on
that that when it comes to like
scrambling in in worse positions and I'm
like I'm okay but I'm not one of the
best and I think the reason is that I
don't have that much experience being
worse so yeah
I actually I usually play from a
position of strength so people
uh people like Hikaru for instance who
often gets in Broad positions he
uh he defends them extremely well and
extremely resourcefully
um and um to be fair all the rest as
well
um
so yeah I think yeah I'm not really one
of the best when it comes to that
all right fair enough and did you feel
that today is game three with alireza
was actually a sort of a takeaway or a
carry forward from what has happened in
the first two games because it felt like
it went wrong really early on for him
yeah he played the French which I didn't
really expect so I thought uh let's just
try and
play something if it's a complicated
position that's that's still fine uh but
it did feel to me from his player that
he was that he didn't completely believe
in it
um so yeah
um yeah as you said there was probably a
bit of a carryover
and Magnus finally the burning question
that everyone wants to know in chat it's
from
krishna21234 are carrots your secret
prep for online events
really
um it's been working pretty well
um at least it worked well today
um
so um
I usually eat like my last meal of the
day before
um before I play so
um it's just um
a little something to
both for nutritious value and also
um to keep a little bit of energy
and Magnus you've earned yourself a rest
day what are you going to do with it any
chance you fancy coming here and
commentating giving me a rest day
instead
um well what have you done to the server
arrested
you caught me that he's been working
really hard yeah and doing a great job
no I'm gonna I'm gonna enjoy it for sure
um and uh be fresh for Sunday
all right Magnus get your rest uh
awesome performance today and we'll see
you back for the Grand Final
Magnus Carlson after his three-game Wick
tree against the alireza farouza that
was a dominating performance by Magnus
it was a dominating and uh he won the
positions that he was playing from a
position of strength uh game two was a
hiccup and there we could have seen Ali
Reza from Russia just perhaps changed
the match around and uh there we can see
the big stats Magnus Carlson with an
accuracy of
91.3 that's incredible yeah he just
played so well today I mean he took some
risks in that second game but um it
worked out okay and he didn't really do
anything wrong did he in the whole match
yeah and we have to give the players
credit these accuracy scores we've seen
higher of course throughout the tour
this season but in such crazy positions
like those to navigate their way through
the Maze of uh calculation there um yeah
just incredible chess and Magnus said it
himself in the interview he wouldn't
mind playing for Russia again because he
really enjoys those crazy positions that
they get against each other and it might
be because furuja does get another
chance he is on his second life uh
meanwhile for Fabiano caruana it was the
end of the road as not the back Abdul
satrov took the big match win after
making a big comeback and there we see
the accuracy of these two players pretty
uh pretty close there and in fact it was
Fabi with the higher accuracy but that
one mistake that one blunder really cost
him the whole match and for Wesley so
against
it was the end of the road for Wesley it
went down to the Armageddon but lasovic
took the match in that and even though
Wesley was knocked out good news for
Wesley he has made it through to Toronto
he's managed to book his spot into the
season and final with the results that
happen in division two and that is our
fifth player in Toronto only three spots
remain David this is turning out to be
quite the field yeah
sure and I can't wait to find out the
identity of the three remaining players
of course it could be someone who wins
division one this time but if it is
Magnus Carlson who goes on to win again
then another spot opens up for the tour
points and uh that would be good news
for a lot of players not just in
division one uh so exciting times ahead
super exciting times I had uh tour
points will be critical for all the
players fighting in the three divisions
Yobe what was your big takeaway from all
the action we had today I was full of
surprises I would first of all never
have predicted that Magnus would win the
match in three games and secondly
nordeback's completely amazing come back
against Fabiana Carona it looked like it
was Game Over out but somehow other he
pulled it back from the brink
yeah I mean I love those Sicilians in
the Magnus match I thought those first
two games where H5 was the bad move I
thought they were fantastic and really
fun to watch so uh hope we get more of
that tomorrow
Harry the h-born will we get more of
that fun I'm sure we're gonna have a
very exciting matches as the players
fight it out for the final spot in the
grand final of the Julius bear
generation cup and it is time to reveal
our winner of the trivia of the day
let's bring up the question and it was a
tricky one who was the first player
younger than Carlson to beat him after
he became world number one let's reveal
the answer
I'm gonna go for ding
and you David Anish giri
so close oh that's the correct answer is
Salman shigiro 17 when he beat Magnus in
2010 and Geary beat Magnus the year
after
and we do have a winner
and it was a tough one congratulations
to Marita Anderson you will be receiving
your Mystery Box really soon that was a
difficult one to get but well done and
it's going to be a difficult day
tomorrow for three of the kids as Magnus
pointed out to fight for that spot to
play against him in the Grand Final
while Magnus gets arrested we'll be back
the others will be the other players
will be back and chat you've got to be
back because you don't want to miss it
we will see you then
[Music]
incredible opening there by Fabiano
caruana everything went wrong in this
one for black
we're just gonna trade queen queen E4
yeah just looks looks completely winning
yeah
not happy Madness Carlson making it look
easy to dig
wrapping it up in three games it has
been a disappointing day uh for Oliver
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign